EVERY. AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISK THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WALK IN THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON. AND TELL
CONGRESS PER PRECIPITATION FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE NOTE THAT
FOR TODAY'S HEARING WITH
STUDENTS WE DO HAVE A ROOM
CHANGE. WILL BE MEETING IN
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. AS THEY JUST
ANNOUNCED RATHER THAN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT BE THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WAS DESTRUCTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING TO
ASK ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO BE
PRESENT ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED-
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH COURT BUT WE
HAVE AT THE ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF.
OF MEMBERS HERE AT THE MOMENT TO
BEGIN OUR HEARING OF WITH A
QUORUM- SO. WE HAVE FOURTEEN
ITEMS O TODAY'S AGENDA. THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE JUST GOT
ONE RIGHT. SB. NINE FIFTY.
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO. OKAY SO-
CONSULTA CAN WE ESTABLISH QUORUM
PLEASE. SENATOR HURGHADA PRESENT
SENATOR HURTADO PRESENT JONES
JONES HERE FOR TODAY HERE ARE TO
THE HERE KAMLAGER. TEN WE FOR
MEMBERS PRESENT WE HAVE THREE
MEMBERS PRESENT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM AND AT THIS
MOMENT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH- IF THE PRESENTING OF THE
FIRST BILL WHICH I AM UP. AT
PRESENT AT THE MOMENT AND I'M
GOING TO AND THE GAVEL OVER TO
MY VICE CHAIR. AND I'M GOING TO
REQUEST OF MISTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF I COULD- PRESENT SB
TEN NINETY TWO FROM MY- SIX
FAMILIES. US SENATOR TITLE HE'S
PRESENTING SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY TWO. CENTER TIED UP THANK
YOU. SO GOOD ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT SB TEN NINETY TO THE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO SERVICES ACT
. WHICH MAKES A VARIETY OF
CHANGES AIMED AT ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES PARTICULAR PEOPLE
OF COLOR. CAN MANY FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN DECISIONS ABOUT
THE SERVICES THEY RECEIVE AND IN
HEARINGS ABOUT THOSE SERVICES.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR RACE
ETHNICITY ENGLISH PROFICIENCY OR
ABILITY TO AFFORD LEGAL COUNSEL
. THE LONDON AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES ACT PROVIDES
INDIVIDUALS WITH. AN ENTITLEMENT
A RIGHT TO RECEIVE THE NECESSARY
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THAT
INDIVIDUAL REQUIRES TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER THE REALITY
OF THE SYSTEM. IS HAT MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES
FACE CHALLENGES IN ACCESSING
THOSE NEEDED SERVICES. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR CONSUMERS
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR WHOSE
PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS NOT ENGLISH
. THE EASE ACT SEEKS TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO NECESSARY SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR CONSUMERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THREE KEY AREAS THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLAN PROCESS
INFORMAL DISPUTE RESOLUTION
MEDIATION. AND FAIR HEARINGS.
THESE CHANGES ARE PROPOSED IN
RESPONSE TO A NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REPORT PUBLISHED BY
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE AND THE STANFORD
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES LONG POLICY PROJECT
THAT FOUND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
ENCOUNTER NUMEROUS BARRIERS
WHILE ATTEMPTING TO ATTEMPTING
TO ENFORCE. THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAN TO ENACT. THROUGH THESE
CHANGES WE SEEK TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM MORE ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PEOPLE IT SERVES INCREASING
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. WHILE ALSO WORKING TO
INCREASE UNDERSTANDING IMPROVE
COMMUNICATION AND REESTABLISH
TRUST BETWEEN THE SYSTEM AND
THOSE AT THE FOR. I WOULD LIKE
TO NOTE THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY INDIVIDUALS
WHO PROVIDED LETTERS OF SUPPORT
. AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE INDIVIDUAL SHARED
THEIR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THROUGH EMAILS PROVIDED TO THE
COMMITTEES EMAIL ACCOUNT. THIS
SUPPORT PRIMARILY FROM CONSUMERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR THOSE FOR THE FOR
THESE PROPOSED REFORMS. I WOULD
NOW LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
PRIMARY WITNESSES. TO SHARE
THEIR EXPERIENCES WITH A
DISABILITY SERVICES SYSTEM AND
THEIR EXPERTISE ON THESE ISSUES
. JOINING ME TODAY AND PERSON
ARE LIZABETH ABOUT YOUR SCHOOL
MYSTIC OUT CO FOUNDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INTEGRATED COMMITTEE
COLLABORATIVE WAS ALSO THE
MOTHER OF A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
WITH DOWN SYNDROME WHO SERVED.
THROUGH THE WESTERN REGIONAL
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES. AND
VIVIAN HOLLEY SENIOR ATTORNEY
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WAS ALSO A CIVIL
INTERBRED WITH AUTISM WHO IS
SERVED TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM. IF WE CAN HAVE OUR
WITNESSES COME FORWARD THAT ARE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. OF SB TEN
NINETY TWO THEY'LL EACH HAVE-
TEN MINUTES AND IF YOU CAN
RESTATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. AND YOUR COMMENTS
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
GOMES AND I AM THE PROUD MOTHER
OF A SON WITH DOWN SYNDROME. I
AM ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. WE ARE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS LED BY
PARENTS AND COMMUNITY LEADERS AS
WELL AS SELF ADVOCATES. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR GIVING US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE HER
TESTIMONY TODAY. I ALSO LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR. FOR BEING THE
CHAMPION OF OUR COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU FROM FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS TODAY ABOUT WHAT IT'S
BEEN IN OUR HEARTS FOR MANY
YEARS AND TODAY IS THERE IS
THERE IS A GREAT DAY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. OUR ORGANIZATION HAS
OKAYED IT FOR THOUSANDS OF
LATINO FAMILIES. WE WORK PEER TO
PEER AS WE TRY TO NAVIGATE THE
ROADBLOCKS AND BARRIERS FOUND
WITHIN THE COMPLEX REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM. WE CAN BEAR
WITNESS TO THE CHALLENGES AND
RESISTANCE FAMILIES OFTEN FACE.
MANY FEEL HELPLESS AND VOICELESS
AFTER BEING DENIED A SERVICE BY
A GHOST COMMITTEE USUALLY KNOWN
BY THE POS FOR THE CLINICAL TEAM
THOSE ARE THE COMMITTEES. THEY
FEEL LIKE THE AUTOMATIC RESPONSE
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER WHEN
MAKING A REQUEST IS MOST ALWAYS
TO START WITH THEIR WELL KNOWN
CULTURE OF KNOWN. WHICH WE
BELIEVE HAS MORE TO DO WITH THE
CULTURE OF THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM THAN IT DOES WITH THE
CULTURAL COMMUNITY. THE CULTURE
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM.
USUALLY THIS HAS FAMILIES FACE A
LOT OF BUREAUCRACY AND POLICY
WHICH OFTEN GETS IN THE WAY OF
INDIVIDUALS OBTAINING THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. THE END
FOR PROCESS MAKES FAMILIES HAVE
TO VILIFY THEIR LOVED ONES. AND
MANY TIMES INFORMATION SHARING
COLLECTED IS LATER USED AGAINST
THEM. THE PROCESS IS NOT ONLY
INTIMIDATING BUT HUMILIATING AND
MANY FAMILIES HERE THAT THEY
HAVE TO BEG FOR SERVICES THAT
THEIR CHILDREN NEED. PERSONALLY
WHEN FAMILIES FIND THEMSELVES
CONFRONTED BY AN ATTORNEY THAT
WAS HIGHER BY THE REGIONAL
CENTER AND PAID BY TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. THESE HEARINGS ARE
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANYONE TO
NAVIGATE WITHOUT HAVING AN
ATTORNEY OF THEIR OWN. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MOST OF US CAN
AFFORD. WHAT I SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY IS A REALITY. WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT REGIONAL CENTERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY SHOULD BE WORKING
TOGETHER AS PARTNERS NOT WORKING
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER. HE WAS
DECISIONS MAKING SUPPOSED TO BE
A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
ROADBLOCKS MANY HAVE JUST GIVEN
UP AND PURSUED THE SERVICES. OR
STOP PURSUING THE SERVICES THAT
THEIR LOVED ONE'S NEEDS. WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS HOPE WE
BELIEVE IN SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY TWO AND WE BELIEVE THAT
HE WILL ENSURE. THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL AND FAMILY WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY HAS A VOICE IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECTS OUR LIVES. WE
BELIEVE THAT HE WILL ENSURE THAT
EVERY INDIVIDUAL IS ALLOWED TO
BE PRESENT FOR. ANY MANY
REGIONAL CENTER MEETINGS THAT
ADDRESSES THEIR SERVICES. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT WILL ENSURE
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS MAKE A
BETTER EFFORT TO RESOLVE%
DISPUTES INFORMALLY WITHOUT AN
OFFICIAL HEARING. SB TEN NINETY
TWO IS ABOUT EQUITY. I STRONGLY
URGE TO SUPPORT SB TEN NINETY
TWO AND I THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO MY TESTIMONY AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. YOU CAN STATE YOUR
NAME AND OF AN ASSOCIATION AND
YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR HER TADO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VIVIAN HAN I AM A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. I AM ALSO THE
SIBLING OF A PERSON WITH AUTISM
MY BROTHER IS SERVED BY THE EAST
LOS ANGELES REGIONAL CENTER.
SENATE TEN NINETY TWO IS ABOUT
CHANGING THE WAY THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM WORKS FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY FELT THE
LEAST EMPOWERED IN IT. TOO MANY
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY FROM
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FEEL
OVERWHELMED WHEN THEY DISAGREE
WITH THEIR REGIONAL CENTER AND
ARE USHERED INTO A COMPLICATED
QUILES I JUDICIAL HEARING
PROCESS THAT FEELS IMPOSSIBLE TO
NAVIGATE WITHOUT AN ATTORNEY.
WHICH MOST PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
PUBLIC BENEFITS ME CANNOT AFFORD
. OTHER PUBLIC BENEFITS PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA LIKE I HSS OR
CALFRESH NOT ONLY RECOGNIZE THIS
FACT THEY HAVE DONE A FAR BETTER
JOB OF DESIGNING THEIR DISPUTE
RESOLUTION AND HEARING SYSTEMS
AROUND IT. AND THE FINDING WAYS
TO ENSURE MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION FOR PEOPLE EVEN IF
THEY DON'T HAVE AN ATTORNEY.
MEANING THE PLACE MUCH MORE
EMPHASIS ON WORKING OUT PROBLEMS
INFORMALLY. THEY'RE HEARING
OFFICERS DON'T JUST DECIDE
CASES. THEY HOPE SUPPORT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ATTORNEYS TO REPRESENT
THEM BY WALKING THEM STEP BY
STEP THROUGH THE LEGAL PROCESS.
AND THEY HAVE ADVISORY
COMMITTEES WHERE PEOPLE AND
THEIR FAMILIES CAN GIVE FORMAL
INPUT ON HOW THE HEARING PROCESS
CAN WORK BETTER FOR THEM.
CURRENTLY NONE OF THESE FEATURES
EXIST IN THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM. SENATE BILL TEN NINETY
YOU WOULD CHANGE THAT BY ADDING
THESE AND OTHER REFORMS TO THE
LANHAM ACT. LOOTING ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE PRESENT AND
TO HAVE A VOICE IN ANY MEETING
WITH DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
SERVICES ARE BEING MADE. AND
REQUIRING HERE IT APPEARS TO BE
TRAINED ON RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES IN THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM WITH TRAININGS
BEING COLD LED BY PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE THANK PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS. ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IS THIS SENTUL TO
ACHIEVING EQUITY. SENATE BILL
TEN NINETY TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE OF COLOR
HAVE A MEANINGFUL VOICE IN THE
DECISIONS AND LEGAL PROCEEDINGS
THAT AFFECT THEIR LIVES WE URGE
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBERS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT IF YOU CAN GIVE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU. KEVIN AS THEIR COLUSA
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS LONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU KEVIN GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN. VERTICAL KASKI
THOUGHT STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
ARE CO SPONSORS THANK YOU. YOUR
SOME A MEMBERS MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE WHEN THIS IS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE HELP ME NUMBER IS MONEY
SOME KIND OF A MESS EVEN LEVEL
YEAH LATE A SURVEY THE IS
KNOWING THAT THE BODY FOUND CARD
THE NESTED HERE TO SUPPORT SB
TEN NINETY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS ARE CONTRARY US AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT OUR DIRECTOR
ELIZABETH GOMES AND HER SUPPORT
WITH THE I. P. C. FOR SB TEN
NINETY AND I WOULD HAVE HI AMY
HOW MOM. THERE ARE PER. TO YOU
TOO. CAN FAVOR PRESS B. NINETY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. ME NUMBER THAT
ARE CAN YOU MORE FOR OF THE
UNILEVER THE HOTEL FOR BENEFIT.
I CHIEF TO SUPPORT ELIZABETH DR
AND SHE IS ALSO PART OF. MY
FAMILY. AND SHE SUPPORTER SB TEN
NINETY TWO AS WELL YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
NINETY TWO IN THE- HEARING THEM%
ANY OTHER MEMBERS INSERT
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. ONE MORE.
MAY NUMBERS IN MONTANA YOUR THEM
BE A MAN WAS ABOUT BY THE ALISON
AT LEAST SEVENTY FIVE AMENDED
ICC A LITTLE SUPPORT BY STATE
REPORT OKAY I GRANTED NECESSITY
I CENTER STILL LEANING IS FOUR
ALL OF. THE COMPLEXITY ON. WHAT
IS THOUGH IS THIS IS A FUN IS
THE EXCEPT YOU. HER NAME IS THE
AMOUNT HERE SHE'S HERE TO
SUPPORT LIZABETH A GOMEZ
DIRECTOR OF ICC SHE'S ALSO PART
OF THE ICC FAMILY. AND SHE
STATES THAT THEY HAVE SOME
COMPASSION TODAY THE SUPPORT OF
IT THERE ARE LOTS OF LOS BEHIND
US THAT ARE PRE TODAY THAT YOU
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LAST WEEK
HERE IN THE U. WANNA START
LISTENING ROOM NUMBERS BECAUSE
OF LOTUS. UBS PORSCHE A POOR
YOUNG LADY SERVICE. THE IS. WHAT
INTO A DIFFERENT LOST FORGET THE
NAME OF MUCHO NECESITA CALISTA
C. CLOSE. US THIS IS THE THIRD
MUCHO ARE YOU LET THEM BE IN.
THE PHOTO SCHOOL POLICY YOU QUE
ESTE LADY THE VILLA DO YOU HAVE
FINANCIAL LITERACY TO FOR FOUR
HOURS SORT ON HEALTH THAT
FLOODED IN ALSO HEAR SUPPORT OF
SB NINETY TWO HE'S THE FATHER OF
THE FAMILY HIS WIFE IS ALSO
HERE. AND HE STRONGLY RECOMMENDS
IT TO PASS SB TEN NINETY TWO
BECAUSE THERE ARE. LOTS OF NEAT
. THEY ARE NOT BEING MET. RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE AT
THE MARCH CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR. FOLKS ARE CALLING IN
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN NINETY TWO
WILL TAKE THOSE PHONE CALLS NOW
. YEAH LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
NINETY Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THIRTY ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND WE WILL START
WITH LINE ONE THIRTY TWO. RIGHT
NOW WHEN. YOU NUMBER EIGHT AND
NUMBER OF A NUMBER. THANK KAMALA
INCREDIBLE IN THE MOST I MEAN
THANK YOU SEE. YOU'LL END FOR
YANDLE ALLOWED EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
THE END OF ANY DAY LOSS
YESTERDAY CONNECTING YOUR
ACTIVITIES STRATEGIES BY MOST
ALL THE THING YOU ACT LIKE AN
ADULT ACT THAT. SO APPLE YANDLE
I'LL STATE BANK THE END OF AN
THOSE THAT YEAH. THANK YOU FOR
THE CALLER ON THE PHONE- WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE IS FOR YOU
JUST STATE YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
AFFILIATION. AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE. AND
MODERATOR CAN YOU INFORM US HOW
MANY CALLERS ARE. WE DO HAVE
ABOUT SEVENTEEN IN MAKE YOU
RIGHT NOW OKAY L. AGAIN-
RECOMMENDS TO THE CALLER'S NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT ON THE
BILL PLEASE. THANKS CALLER. ONE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT FOR YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED.
YEAH. YEAH THE NEW YORK I MEAN.
YEAH THANK YOU NEXT COLOR.
YOU'RE LYING IN ONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS JUDY MARC
PRESIDENT OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED INSURANCE OF THAT MANSER
BY REGIONAL CENTER AND PROUD TO
SPONSOR- THIS BILL AND ORDERED
AS YOU CAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NICE COLOR. NEVER MIND THE. ONE
OH SEVEN. R. KATHERINE HEDGES-
SELF ADVOCATE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NICE COLOR. NINE ONE FORTY FIVE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. HI MY
NAME IS NOT ARE YOU GOING PART
OF INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE AT THE TURN OF THE
CONSUMER FROM INLAND REGIONAL
CENTER I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN
NINETY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CAR. WE HAVE A LINE. ONE
FORTY NINE. WHEN I WOULD MEAN
NUMBER REYES AND MADELINE HE IS
A MEMBER OF THEIR OWN I MEAN.
BILLIONS OF HOWEVER YOU'RE NOT
THEN YES THERE'S A BANDS OF
MEMANDU ALLAY IS B. M. NIGHT.
TWO THANK YOU NEXT. MY NUMBER.
ONE MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT COULD YOU YES. NUMBER FOR ME A LOT ABOUT
ALMOST AND FOR MIGHT AS WILL BE
YOU KNOW A LITTLE FOR THE MIDDLE
IN OUR FLAT FEE OF FOR YOUR
REVIEW IF ANOTHER VITAL. THANK
YOU NICE COLOR. YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER ONE. I MY NAME IS GERALD
. I AM APPEARING CORRECT COUNTY
TRI COUNTY THREE CENTERS OKAY
ONE AND ONE- ONE THIRD ONE I
THIRD. ONE FORT. THANK YOU NICK
. THANK YOU HAVE MY NUMBER. ONE
FORTY. HELLO YES WELL. THANK YOU
MOM. SORRY THE MENU A GRIFFIN
MIGHT AND IT IN DANIEL'S GOING
OF- EIGHTY THE LOCAL. IN THEM A
BIG SUPPORT OKAY IN NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALL. I
WOULD HAVE WON NUMBER ONE FIVE
AND- HI MY NAME IS THE BOTTOM OF
THE- I AM A PARTNER. DOWN
SYNDROME LITTLE BOYS YEAR OLD
AND I DEFINITELY. ONE AND. THREE
TEN EIGHTY TWO. BRADFORD GOOD
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU NICE
COLOR. WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE
SIX. HI MY NAME MICHELLE VIA AND
FRONT OF THE INFLUX DISABLED
CHILD CARE BY THE INLAND
REGIONAL CENTER I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT THE TEN NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. NINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE. NINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE NEW
NUMBER SPACE BEFORE NESTLING
MOTHER THEY WILL CONSUME YOU
KNOW THEY'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS A LOT OF PEOPLE OFFENDED
FEET YEP WELL YOU FEEL MAY MAY.
I VIETNAM AND THANK THAT I YET.
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. YEAH MY
NUMBER ONE THIRD PLEASE GO AHEAD
. IN THIS MANNER CURRENT AM A
SEVEN HUMOR AND THE CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL AND A STRONG WITH
POOREST AND THE HEAR. THANK YOU
NICE COLOR. AND WE A BIG MORE IN
YOUR WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO CALL. HELLO NAME IS
DON. THE. MY NAME IS SANTIAGO I
WORK FOR A DISABILITIES SERVICES
PROVIDER EASTERSEALS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM STRONG LISA
FOURTEEN S. B. TEN NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. I
NUMBER ONE FIFTY SIX. GUILFORD
COUNTY. HEALTH CENTER REGIONAL
FROM FOR CARRYING ON WITH THE
FOR AND. ONE ZERO NINE YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CAR. NINE ONE
SIX THREE. I'M NUMBER ONE SIX
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
WHEN I MEAN I'M A THIRTY NOTHING
BY NESTLE MOTHER IS OPENING UP A
END OF DECEMBER. IN BOTH ONE THE
IDC HE YOUR I'M ENOUGH YOUR THAT
IS YES MOMENT THAT'LL YEP WE ARE
HAVE SAID THAT THANK YOU NEXT
CALL. YEAH MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY
FIVE ADD. HI MY NAME CURIOUS.
I'M NOT. IT WOULDN'T ONE THING
TO NOTE ON A STRONG BASIS A
FEATURE NIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NICE COLOR. YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER. ONE THREE FOUR. MY
NUMBER ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE ARE. WE WILL THEN GO
TO MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS THAT
THEY'RE GETTING THEM AGAIN I AM
THE MOTHER OF THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
AND WITH THE ICC FAMILY AND WE
LOVE TO THE HARBOR REGIONAL
CENTER AND I'M IN FAVOR OF SB
AND TWO. THANK OUR- THE BOTTOM
LINE NUMBER SEVEN ONE PLEASE
AHEAD. FOLLOWING BETTER NUMBER
IS ANYTHING MOUNTAIN BEFORE
MODEL P. AND THIS THERE'S BEEN
GROWING BELIEVE THE LIGHT. YES
AVAILABLE BE WOMEN'S REYES YES
MONDAY'S. LAST YEAR. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. LITTLE BOTTLE I
NUMBER ONE SIXTY. HELLO GO AHEAD
THE FIRM HAS HI MY NAME IS MY
VERY MY THAT AND I HERE WITH
SOME ARE THE EIGHTH MEETING TWO
AT MY MOTHER OF A CHILD GETTING
INTO FAMILIES LIKE HE THANK YOU
TO SUPPORT THE BILL IMPACT THAT
WE NEED TO SUPPORT YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT. WHAT. I WILL
TELL THEM THAT I CAN'T FIGURE
OUT OR I'M A THE MODEL HE WITH-
OF THE SEVEN FIVE THOUSAND
ORIGINAL HERE TO SUPPORT BY A BE
PAYING NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS. CALL I KNOW
ONE SIXTY ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
DON I'M A WITH THE INTEGRATED
FORM ADULT WHO IS A MEMBER OF
THE DOWNEY SYNDROME. I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. TEN NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
. YOU HAVE ONE EIGHTY THREE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LOOKING LIKE A PHONY I HAVE A
BOY WE DON'T SEE SOME TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD AND- FROM A LOT I'M A
STRONGLY SUPPORT IF WE. TEN
NINETY TWO. THANK THANKS CALLER
. MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SIX.
HELLO YOU KNOW BASED IT IS
SACRAMENTO YOU CAN GO ONLY HOPE
CONSERVATISM THE PERCENTAGE HIGH
BUT WE CANNOT- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FEMININE THANK NAY EIGHT
SEVEN. SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NAY COLOR. WE HAVE MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY THEY DROPPED OUT
WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER ONE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FERNANDO GOMEZ I HAVE A SON
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD SERVE AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM I'M ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH THE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AFTER THAT. IN
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TEN NINETY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE WILL HOLD THE LINE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE. MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NUMBER ONE YOU COULD
NOT BE YEARS REMEMBER OF
CORPORATE. ONE AT. THIRTY NINE
TWO. THANK YOU COLOR. WE HAVE.
ONE FIVE. MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PEOPLE HAD. YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT NEW TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. OKAY WE WERE BOTH A LINE
NUMBER TWO OH THREE ONE TWO OR
THREE. OKAY AND THAT ONE IS.
GETTING A NUMBER HERE SO WELL
BOTH MY NUMBER. TWO OH NINE. MY
NUMBER TWO ONE NINE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRYSTAL. I
AM WITH YOU ARE I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM AND I
SUPPORT SB TEN NINETY TWO. THANK
YOU NEXT CAR. I CAN'T HEAR THE
REPORT TO MY NUMBER TWO OH THREE
AGAINST WILL THREE. MY NUMBER
TWO OH THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY WE WILL TRY A LINE NUMBER
TWO YOU LIVE IN A LINE NUMBER
TWO ELEVEN. HELLO THE FAMILY YES
GO AHEAD OKAY. OKAY MY MAINFRAME
HERNANDEZ I HAVE A PHONE WITH US
IS THEM HE WILL GO OVER AND I
THANK ON CONCERN I'M I THINK FOR
THEY'VE BEEN. ONLY AT THE NINE
NINETY. AND I AM OF THE D. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NICE COLOR. YOU
HAVE MY NUMBER TWO FIFTEEN TO
FIFTY WE'VE HAD BEEN. HELLO
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MY OF THIS
MOTHER OF TWO CAN FROM CENTRAL
LABOR TO CENTER WE SUPPORT
FEATURE NINETY TWO PLEASE NEED
CHANGES THANK YOU THANK YOU
COLOR. WE HAVE ABOUT IN Q. AND
WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO WHILE WE
THOUGHT. HI MY NAME IS DAY AT
I'M A STAFF MEMBER AT THE I IN
SUPPORT OF BILL SB TEN NINETY
TWO YOU. THANK YOU COLOR. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER TWO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO
NINETEEN PEOPLE HAD. KUALA GO
AHEAD. WHAT WE MIGHT BE UNDER
THE FLOOR THE HOBBIT THE AMOUNT
IS THE IF THERE'S INTEREST NOW
THERE'S BEEN NO THE NOT ELSE I'M
HAVING YOUR WE HAVE BEEN WOMEN
ARE LATE ANSWERED THE YOU KNOW
IT BY THE. THANK YOU MEXICO. IN
REGARD TO LINE UP TWO TWENTY
BASEBALL. WHEN THE NUMBER IS
OBVIOUSLY IT'LL CERTAINLY HOLE
OF THE DRIVE BECAUSE YOU UNDER
YOUR FULLER THE LADY YESTERDAY
YES NINE ZERO A PLATFORM ASM OF
THE PLANET THE COMMUNITY CAN IT
WILL MAKE A MORE FROM A
POLITICAL MILLION FUNDED HI B.
C. BACK IN.
AND I. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARK AS AN ADULT I SUPPORT AS
YOU CAN NINETY TWO I'M A MOTHER
OF ONE OF THE NETWORK. WITHOUT
OBJECTION- FROM BRIGHAM CENTER
BUT IT HELPS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER. WE DO HAVE ON
WOULD BE JUST A SECOND HERE TO
GET NEAR LINE NUMBER THIS
MORNING YOU. IRATE WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
BUT SHALL I HAVE THE FATHER OF
THE CLIENT IN THE REGIONAL
CENTER I PROMISE. AS B. KENNEDY
TOO AND THAT SUPPORT TO COME
FROM WHICH THAT GOVERNMENTS FROM
AYE SHE- THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE HAD. HELLO MY
NAME ONLY YOUR LOCAL I BASED
HAVE A IT. YOU AND A STRONG FOR
HARD TO NINETY TWO. THANK YOU IT
MODERATOR THEM ANYMORE COLOR- WE
DO HAVE WIN YOU THE THIRD YOU
WERE NOT HERE SO I'M HAVE MY
NUMBER HE. FORTY ONE. ORLA
NUMBER MY AND I'M GOING YOUR
AVOID- FEMALE. LARGELY SURVEY
YES MOMENT. THANK YOU NAY COLOR
. OKAY WE DO HAVE ONE MORE LEFT
IN YOU HERE FLYING OF TWO FORTY
PLEASE AHEAD. HI MY IS JODY. ALL
A SOCIAL WORKER SUPPORT OF THAT
LEAST TEN NINETY TWO. THANK YOU
. THAT'S RIGHT- WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN THREE FOUR
AHEAD. WHAT LET ME KNOW JANET
FOR MY I'M NOT GONNA NAY YET
THAT HE SPENT A MEMBER ONE ON
CURRENT YOU YEAH MY LOOK AT ON
YEAH MY LATE MAY BE UP THAT BOTH
DROP IN THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
YOU HAVE MY NUMBER FIFTY LINE
NUMBER. FIVE ZERO. IF ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GO AHEAD
GLOBAL TRIGGERED VACUUM ONE
WOUND. OKAY LINE NUMBER TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THE NEW
DEMOCRAT A. EMMA A I AM A MOTHER
OF. A CLIENTS OR REGIONAL CENTER
FOR THE FLAG. IS UP FIFTY SIX
AND NINETY THREE LEGAL FIFTY
THREE SEVEN. THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HEY WE HAVE MY
NUMBER TWO FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHEN I FOUND THIS NUMBER
IS THE BEST TIME FOR A SINGLE
THOSE VEHICLES ARE GOOD SO
HOLDING- IS NOT GOING TO MIDDLE
EDITORS ORGANIZED THE ELECT
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER THEY LET US IF
YOU FOR THE I. FORTY SEVEN. YEP
FOR YOUR- LANDING EIGHT SEVEN
THE END OF THE DAY. GRASSROOTS
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE. HELLO IT
MY YES RIGHT OKAY- HI MY NAME
BETTER NOW THE BY MY AMERICAN
BIRD BY EACH KIND OF TO SEVEN.
AND I'M I WOULD GET THAT- WORKS
WITH IT AND I AM SUPPORT. SB TEN
NINETY TWO THANK YOU NEXT CALL-
WE DO HAVE ANY INFO. THE
STITCHES. THANK YOU MODERATOR I
WILL BRING IT TO THE HEARING
ROOM I BELIEVE THAT THERE IS NO
REGISTERED TO OPPOSITION BUT WE
WILL OPEN UP THE HEARING ROOM
FOR IF THERE'S ANYBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TEN NINETY
TWO ANY. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DESPERATE TO NAY TO SEEING NO
SPEAKERS MODERATORS WE CAN OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES IF THERE ARE
ANY- CALLERS IN OPPOSITION OF SP
TEN NINETY TWO. FOR THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE WE'RE TAKING COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN NINETY
TWO. OPPOSITION OF SB TEN NINETY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. OPPOSITION OF S.
B. YOU FROM NINETY TO ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE FUELING UP MR K. THANK
YOU MODERATOR WE WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION TO THE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION FROM THE MEMBERS.
CENTER COME UNDER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD- LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IF POSSIBLE I'D
LOVE TO SIGN ON AS A CO AUTHOR-
AND ALSO TO MOVE THE DATE THAT I
SAY THAT MOVED ABILITY
APPROPRIATE YOU CAN DOWN OKAY
I'D LIKE TO DO THAT- AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK- ALL OF THE
ADVOCATES FOR MAKING THEIR WAY
TO SACRAMENTO FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT. HEARING I TO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE MISS GOMEZ I HAVE
PARTISAN NEEDED- IN ICC'S IS
ETHOS ON A FEW OCCASIONS. AND I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT THIS IS A
GROUP OF ADVOCATES THAT. KNOW
THEIR RIGHTS. LOVE THEIR
CHILDREN AND ARE DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT SEES THEM
BOTH THE CLIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND IS WORKING REALLY
DILIGENTLY TO MOVE US TO- THE
FULLEST. UNDERSTANDING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF WHAT SELF THE
TEMPERAMENT NATION MEANS FOR OUR
FAMILIES AND THIS IS WHAT I TEN
NINETY TWO IS ABOUT. YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY. RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN REGIONAL CENTERS AND
THEIR CLIENTS CAN OFTENTIMES
TURN ADVERSARIAL. AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. ABOUT HEARINGS
IS DUE PROCESS AND MAKING SURE
THAT YOU HAVE A PROCESS THAT IS
FAIR THAT IS OBJECTIVE THAT IS
ACCESSIBLE AND THAT MAKES ROOM
AT THE TABLE FOR CLIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO PARTICIPATE-
AND HOW CLIENTS ARE LIVING. AND
I THINK THIS IS THE END AND
BEHIND THIS BILL WHICH IS WHY I
SUPPORTED SO I'M AND I THINK
THIS IS ALSO A COMMUNITY THAT
REMAINS ON THE MARGINS. THE I.
D. D. COMMUNITY REMAINS ON THE
MARGINS AND WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION. TO MOVE THEM TO THE
CENTER. SO I JUST WANNA SELL BE
DISORDER SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD THANK YOU SIR
COMMERCENTRE PAN. THANK YOU I TO
WANT TO THANK CENTER TADO FOR
LEADERSHIP AND IN OFFERING THIS
BILL- OF ACTUALLY- WE'VE-
PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TOGETHER I ACTUALLY-
CHAIRED THAT SUB. AND EVEN
BEFORE THAT AND- AND ACTUALLY
WON THE PERSISTENT CHALLENGES WE
FACE- IN TERMS OF OUR OVERSIGHT
IN THAT COMMITTEE. HAS BEEN
ACTUALLY- RACIAL DISPARITIES
OTHER DISPARITIES THAT WE SAW IN
THE- THE SYSTEM THAT WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND FACT UP NO
OTHER LEGISLATORS HAVE. WORK TO
CARRY BILLS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE- I KNOW
THAT THE- DEPARTMENT SERVICES AS
ALSO- WORKED ON THIS ISSUE TO
AND YOU KNOW WE HAD- YES SIR HAD
CONVERSATION WITH THE DIRECTOR
ABOUT IT AND- SO FORTH. BUT I
THINK ALSO HEARD THOUGH IN IN
THOSE HEARINGS- FROM- I'M NOT
JUST ADVOCATES BUT FROM PEOPLE
RECEIVING SERVICES IS THAT- D. A
DE FAIRE HEARING PROCESS. WAS
HELD IT WAS NOT WHAT WAS NOT
WORKING AND IN FACT DOES SEEM TO
BE JUST A THE AGE OF THE CALL.
IN THE- FAMILY COMES AND SALAS
WHO GETTING SERVE AND HE WASN'T
SERVED SO FOR. SO IT IS SO I DO
PER OUR TO YOU KNOW- THAT TO THE
- HAS RECOGNIZED THAT TEAM IS
NEEDED AND I AM THAT. SELF HAS
BUT IT IS IT'S BEEN LOOKING AT
THIS. BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT- CAN APPRECIATE THAT
THE LEADERS OF OUR- SAID LOOK WE
PUT- THIS FULL. I JUST FOR AND
IN AND PUSH THE INDUSTRY INTO
THE PART TO THIS FORWARD. WELL
THINGS WOULD MAKE NOTE AND I
THINK DALLAS IS A POINTS OUT-
THAT- IN THIS PROPOSAL- THERE'S
A SUGGESTION THAT IT ACTUALLY IN
THIS PUT THIS BILL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO ACTUALLY ASK THE
PHARMACEUTICAL SERVICES INSTEAD
OF- H. TO. ACTUALLY- TO HELP
HOLD. AND I HOPE THAT AND I DO
IS THE WE HAVE. THE CIVIL MORE
LEE. APPROACH A MORE CONSUMER
DRIVEN PROCESS NOT DURING THE
WHOLE DISCUSSION EVENTUAL FIGURE
OUT LIKE YOU KNOW WHICH- WHICH
BOX. NOTE THAT THIS THE SERIES
WILL FINALLY LAND IN BUT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. WE
TRY NOT TO SET UP AN ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONS THE PURPOSE OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS THE PURPOSE OF
THE VOTE NOW THAT THAT THE DDS
IS TO SUPPORT FAMILIES AND HOW
TO FIGHT WITH THEM. AND SO I IS
SO- I HOPE IS THIS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD IS. PROBABLY THE
L. ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS IN
THIS BILL YOU KNOW IT'S THE
DISCUSSIONS HAPPEN AND
EVENTUALLY WE COME TOGETHER.
THAT WE DO MAKE A PROCESS THAT.
WORKS BETTER FOR FAMILIES. AND
ALSO IS MORE EQUITABLE BECAUSE
CLEARLY WE HAVE SEEN YEAR AFTER
YEAR AND I KNOW BROUGHT IT UP
OVER AND OVER AGAIN WHEN I WAS.
IS ON BUDGETS OF THREE. THAT WE
SEE THE OUTCOMES ARE NOT
EQUITABLE. THAT THE SERVICES ARE
NOT ACTIVELY- A GROUP DELIVERED
OR ARE PEOPLE CAN ACCESS TO
ITSELF. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED- OUR
STATION THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN SO LONG
SINCE ANYONE'S REALLY LOOK YOU
KNOW ACTUALLY WENT FOR THE
HEARING PROCESS ITSELF. SO WE'VE
WE HAVE DONE OTHER THINGS TO TRY
TO SEND OF ICE BUT I THINK IT'S
TIME TO DO THIS AND- ALEX DOUBLE
BE SUPPORTING. BILL ON MY THE
BILL. THE AUTHOR. AND I KNOW MY
GOOD FRIEND READY SECONDED IT
I'D LIKE TO SECOND OR THIRD IT.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN THE COMMENTS FROM THE-
COMMITTEE. SIMILAR COMMENTS WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE ALL
POSITIVE COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR YES I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE IT THAT'S OKAY- IT
YOUR DURING THE TESTIMONY AND
COMMENTS ARE PROVIDED. FOR THIS
BILL I HEARD TWO THINGS. ONE IS
A SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE THAT IS
NOT WORKING WE KNOW WE KNOW THAT
I KNOW THAT YOU ALL VERY WELL
KNOW THAT MORE THAN US AND
PEOPLE ON THE NOT THE SECOND
THING IS THAT PEOPLE WANT TO
WORK TOGETHER- WITH THE REGIONAL
SALES THAT WE ALL WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK
WORK FOR EVERYBODY AT LEAST
THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD. HERE
TODAY. AND I WOULD. IN ALL SAY
THAT THIS REMINDS ME OF. OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S REMARKS AT THE
SUMMIT FOR DEMOCRACY. AND AT IT
AND IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO SHOW THAT
BECAUSE IT IT. THOSE REMARKS
REALLY INSPIRED AND THE WORK
THAT I DO BUT- BUT I THINK THAT
UP. THE TESTIMONY IN THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE PROVIDED BY
YOU ALL TODAY. ALSO VERY MUCH
INSPIRED ME. AND SO ARE. DURING
THE SUMMIT HE SAID THAT- AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY WARREN
OF ALMOST WORRYING OF ALL BY
INCREASING THE DISSATISFACTION
OF PEOPLE ALL AROUND THE WORLD
WITH. DEMOCRATIC GOVERNMENT THAT
THEY FEEL THEY'RE FEELING TOO
LITTLE FOR THEIR NEEDS. IN MY
VIEW THIS IS A DEFINING
CHALLENGE OF OUR TIME. DEMOCRACY
GOVERNMENT. OF THE PEOPLE BY THE
PEOPLE. FOR THE PEOPLE CAN AT
TIMES BE FRAGILE. BUT IT IS ALSO
INHERENTLY RESILIENT IT'S
CAPABLE OF SELF CORRECTION AND
IT'S CAPABLE OF SELF
IMPROVEMENT. YES THE MARCUS IS
HARD WE ALL KNOW THAT IT WORKS
BEST WITH CONSENSUS AND
COOPERATION. WHEN PEOPLE AND
PARTIES THAT MIGHT HAVE OPPOSING
VIEWS SIT DOWN AND FIVE FIND
WAYS TO WORK TOGETHER THINGS
BEGIN TO WORK. AND IT'S THE BEST
WAY TO UNLEASH HUMAN POTENTIAL
AND DEFEND HUMAN DIGNITY. AND
SOLVE BIG PROBLEMS AND IT'S UP
TO US TO PROVE THAT. AND QUOTE.
I THINK THAT'S PRETTY MUCH WHAT
I HEARD HERE TODAY PEOPLE WANT
TO WORK TOGETHER PEOPLE WANT TO
MAKE THIS WORK AND SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO COME HERE TO WORKING
WITH US TO WORKING WITH YOU OUT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT
WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE SO
WORKS. FOR US ALL. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN WHICH IS BEST. ALL
SPORTS. WE NEED. FOR THE
MULTIPLE THAT EVERY NEED I A
COMIC THAT. YOUR SECULAR SCHOOL
SAYS NO CENTRAL CONFERENCE ROOM
ON THE PART OF STATUS EITHER IN
A SCHOOL CHECK IT GET INTO A
HARSH CONTROLS BUT A K. IS THE
SYSTEM OF THE ROCKET BOTTLE
SERVICE. YES IS LOCATED MOST OF
THE WHOLE CLASS YES IT DOES LOOK
A SIGNIFICANT. LET'S GET OUT OF
THE SENSE HIM FOR IQAMA THE IT'S
SIMPLE PRODUCT BUT AT THE TIME
THAT THE WOMAN WAS PROBLEMS GET
THE NORMALCY. HE L. AS THE SLA
MUST FEED WILL BE A THE HOSPITAL
E. ON THE GOT. BERMAN MEDICARE
QUE SYMPATHY THAT THE HOUSEHOLD
BILLS THIS LOOK OFFICE AND
RENTALS PROBLEM GONE THE
VEHICLES AND ALSO THROUGH. WHICH
IS WORTH. AND I WOULD STRUCK
LAST PRIVATE THREE. WE CAN CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. HURTADO I FIR
TATTO I'D JONES I JONES II.
CORTESE I ORDERED THE I.
COMMAGER AMONG- I PANNED BY HAND
I. THAT BILL IS FIVE ZERO. THAT
BILL IS FIVE ZERO SO THAT IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL TURN
THE GAVEL BACK TO THE GERMAN.
THANK YOU THINKING OF. THANK
GOODNESS. THANK YOU MR VICE OKAY
WE HAVE CENTER HERTZBERG HERE
ARE READY TO PRESENT ON. I DON'T
NUMBER THREE SENATE BILL NINE
SEVEN THREE. VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THIS IS A
BILL. I DIDN'T LIKE SPONSORED
BILLS. I COME FROM A DIFFERENT
TIME IN HISTORY WE COME UP WITH
THEIR OWN IDEAS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I LEARNED IN THAT
HISTORY IS THAT WHEN SOMEONE HAS
AN IDEA YOU GIVEN CREDIT. AND
THE CREDIT GOES TO THE TREASURE
THE CITY CALIFORNIA FIONA MARC.
SHE CAME UP WITH A PRETTY
BRILLIANT IDEA. THAT DOES
OMETHING IN GOVERNMENT THAT IS
PRETTY NIFTY. IT IMPROVES A
PROCESS AND SAVES MONEY. AND
SAVE MONEY. WE GET THAT
OPPORTUNITY CONSIDER THAT HERE
TODAY AS A RESULT OF S. B. A
NINE. A SEVENTY THREE NOW WHAT
HAPPENS IS THIS MEASURE DIRECTS
MORE REVENUE TO S. S. I. N. S.'S
P. RECIPIENTS BY CUTTING TIES
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IF
THEY'RE COSTLY BUREAUCRACY AND
METHOD OF ISSUING S. S. P.
BENEFITS. YOU CURRENTLY CONTRACT
WITH GOVERNMENT CITY CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTS DEVELOPMENT. AND WE
PAY ONE THIRTEEN DOLLARS AND
SIXTEEN CENTS PER PAYMENT THAT'S
WHAT OUR OVERHEAD COST IS OKAY.
THAT TRANSLATES TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE THE PAYMENTS
THAT ARE BEHALF A LOT OF MONEY.
IN THIS NUMBER WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW YOUR AFTER YEAR BECAUSE THE
THIRTEEN DOLLAR MINISTRY TO FEE
IS TIED TO A CPI CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX. YOU'RE TALKING NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE A LOT OF MONEY IN
TODAY'S WORLD IS BUDGET DOES.
BUT IN FIVE YEARS TO BILLION
DOLLARS AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
YOU ARE MILLION DOLLARS IS. A
LOT OF MONEY OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS
. SO IN THE SAME TIME WE'RE
SPENDING THE MONEY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION. R. O. S. S. I.
S. IS P. BENEFITS USERS
STRUGGLING MORE THAN EVER TO
MAKE ENDS MEET INFLATION COSTS
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW. AND
FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
REPRESENT ARE DEALING WITH
PARTICULARLY HOUSING COSTS. SO
THIS MEASURE OFFERS A RATHER.
CLEVER APPROACH THAT THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE CAME UP WITH.
THE DIRECT MORE DOLLARS TOWARD
THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS BY.
ALLOWING DSS THE CONTRACT WITH
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT VENDOR TO
ADMINISTER THE S. S. P. PROGRAM
AT A COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE.
THIS VENDOR WOULD WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH CALIFORNIA
TO. TO THEN BRING THE PROCESS OF
ISSUING PAYMENTS IN STATE.
THEREBY RESULTING IN EVEN MORE
GENERAL. REASON CREATING CALIPH
MORE CALIFORNIA JOBS. BY
ADMINISTERING THE PAYMENTS OF
THEIR OWN WE COULD ULTIMATELY
SAVE AS I SUGGESTED NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO THIS MEASURE ISN'T JUST
RIGHTEOUS IT'S COMMONSENSE AND
IT'S ABOUT. GOOD GOVERNMENT AS
IT GETS CASEY O'CONNOR VERY
BRILLIANT LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR OUR GREAT STATE TREASURES
HERE TO TALK ABOUT IT AND TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE A
CENTER HERTZBERG STATED I AM
CASEY O'CONNOR STATE TREASURE
LAWS LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR THE
TREASURES PROUD TO SPONSOR SB
NINE SEVENTY THREE. AND WE KIND
OF CAME TO THIS BILL AS THE
TREASURER IS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACHIEVING A BETTER
LIFE EXPERIENCE ALSO KNOWN AS
CAL ABLE BOARD. THAT IS A
NATIONAL NETWORK FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION STATE
TREASURES AS WELL THAT'S WERE
ABLE STARTED WITH AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL SHE ALSO CHAIRS THE
FEDERAL COMMITTEE WHICH IS NOW
THE FEDERAL NETWORK SO IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE ALL KNOW THAT A
LOT OF THOSE. THAT ARE CAL ABLE
AND A LOOKOUT HOLDERS THEY ARE
SSI PAYMENT RECIPIENTS AND SO IN
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
FOUND THAT THEIR FINANCIAL
RAMIFICATIONS HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED AND IS ALREADY A
GROUP OF FOLKS. WHO HAVE A LOT
OF TROUBLE SAVING MONEY THERE
SOMETHING TOM SOMETIMES
UNINTENDED TAX TREATMENT TO THE
MONEY THEY SAY. THEY'VE BEEN
RELEASED IT OUT FINANCIAL LIMBO
SO TO SPEAK SO AT THESE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF STATE TREASURES
CONFERENCES WE SPEAK WITH THE
FIDUCIARY LEADERS FROM OTHER
STATES THERE'S FORTY EIGHT STATE
TREASURES WERE PART OF THIS
NATIONAL NETWORK IT'S BIPARTISAN
THEY'RE ALL FIDUCIARY LEADERS.
AND WE WORK TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE
COMMON GOALS SO IN OUR CAR AND
OUR CONVERSATIONS AROUND BEST
PRACTICES THE DISCUSSION HELP US
COME UP WITH UNIQUE SOLUTION TO
THIS TO POTENTIALLY CUT DOWN ON
LOWER LOWER GOVERNMENT SPENDING.
AND LEARN FROM THOSE AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CUT DOWN THESE COSTS
FOR THEIR STATES. REALLOCATE THE
MONEY SAVED DIRECTLY TO THOSE
IT'S INTENDED TO SERVE AND WE
FIGURED OUT A WAY TO DO THIS
WITHOUT RAISING TAXES OR BEEN
HIT TO THE GENERAL FUND. SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE AS IS NOT
REQUIRED. S. S. TO CONTRACT WITH
EITHER THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION HAS SSA OR
ANOTHER STATE THAT IS ABLE TO
WILLING TO ADMINISTER THE
STATE'S SUPPLEMENTARY PROGRAM.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
DIRECT MORE RESOURCES TOWARD
THOSE MOST IN NEED BY REDUCING
THE COST OF ADMINISTERING THE S.
S. P. FOR THE AGED BLIND AND
DISABLED. AS A SENATOR NOTED IF
WE CAN CUT THESE COSTS IN HALF
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS THEN
TO HAVE THOSE THOSE COSTS. GOING
TO THE- AT A RATE OF UP. TO THIS
BILL CREATE THE- I STATE. TO SEE
WHO CAN PERFORM THIS FOR US
IMMEDIATELY TO START SAVING
MONEY IMMEDIATELY AND HOUSE
WHILE TEACHING US HOW TO ACHIEVE
THIS GOAL PERMANENTLY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE
APPRECIATE ON THE WORK IN THE
CONSIDERATION THE COMMITTEE. AND
WE EXPECT THE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OKAY THIS BILL DOES HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- BUT ARE
THERE. ANY TO WE HAVE NO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO WE
HAVE ANY. ANYONE WILLING TO
TESTIFY HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED ON THIS MEASURE. NO OKAY
THE SUPPORT FOR IT ABOUT THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE SEVEN
THREE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE SEVEN THREE IT IS ONE
SEVEN ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
ONE FORTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS JERRY BROWN AND ON
BEHALF THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA- GREAT BILL GREAT
AUTHOR- DR THANK YOU. CAN MARK.
MY THERE ARE YOU KNOW WHETHER IN
Q. MADAM CHAIR. OKAY AT THE END
ONCE AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE IT YOU
ARE. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BUT WE DO HAVE SOMEONE HERE THAT
WANTS TO SPEAK OUT IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THAT OPPOSITION I'M
ALWAYS SUPPORT KEVIN OTHER
CORNERS OF CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
AND LONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THINK. THANKSGIVING I DON'T
THINK ANYONE ELSE IN IN THIS
ROOM OF TWENTY TO SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT OF. SO NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IN THE ROOM. NOW FIFTY NINE
OKAY ARE MOVING ON TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE ON
ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
SEVEN THREE IT IS ONE NINE ZERO
. THAT'S OPPOSITION FOR KATHY.
NINE SEVEN THREE ONE ONE ZERO. I
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP
MADAM CHAIR OKAY. WELL THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THE- THIS MONEY AND
IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS LISTING
NOT. THREE NINE OKAY. CENTER
HERTZBERG WOULD YOU YEAH
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER VOTE AND TO
THANK THE TREASURE FOR HER
CREATIVITY GREAT OKAY I DO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR THIS BILL.
OKAY SOME OF WE HAVE A MOTION.
OUR CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HURTADO I THE DALLAS I JONES.
JONES I COURTESY I FOR TO THE I
KAMAGRA. KAMAGRA I CAN'T. THE
BILL IS FOUR ZERO OKAY WE WILL
PLACE UP THE LONG CALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND YOU CAN CLICK. THANK
AND UP NEXT WE HAVE THE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER FOR SENATE BILL NINE
SEVEN SIX BY CENTER LEYVA.
GENERALLY THE PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I AM VERY
EXCITED AND HAPPY TO BE HERE TO
PRESENT SB NINE SEVEN SIX WHICH
PROVIDES UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL BY
ENSURING THAT PARENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. HAVE INCREASED
OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES TOCHILD
CARE CLEARLY ACCESS TO CHILD
CARE IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE PARENTS CAN WORK AND PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. SB NINE
SEVEN SIX CREATES A FREE
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL SYSTEM BY
EXPANDING ACCESS TO THE
PRESCHOOL STATE STREET PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND TO ALL THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLD REGARDLESS OF
FAMILY INCOME. THIS BILL
SUPPLEMENTS THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN BY STRENGTHENING
OUR CHILD CARE INFRASTRUCTURE
MEMBERS THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC PUSHED OUR CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. TO THE TO THE BRINK. OF
COLLAPSE MANY PROVIDERS WERE
FORCED TO CLOSE OR SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMIT THE ROMIT DURING THE
PANDEMIC CHILD CARE PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA RELY ON SERVING A
RANGE OF AGE GROUPS GIVEN THE
HIGH COST OF INFANT AND TODDLER
CARE. AS YOU MAY KNOW THIS IS AN
INDUSTRY THAT EMPLOYS PRIMARILY
WOMEN SPECIFICALLY WOMEN OF
COLOR WE MUST CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT NOT ONLY WORKS FOR FAMILIES
BUT ALSO UP LIVES OUR PROVIDERS
BY ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE. THE
ABILITY TO OPEN THEIR DOORS TO
MORE CHILDREN AND PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES A LIVING WAGE SB NINE
SEVEN SIX STRENGTHENS CHILD CARE
IN CALIFORNIA AND PROVIDES
FAMILY. NEEDED FLEXIBILITY AS
WELL AS OFFER STABILITY TO CHILD
CARE COMMUNITIES WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS LAWANDA
WESLEY WITH THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER ALSO LARA MAGNUS
DAUGHTER FROM THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK
WILL BE JOINING. THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
MEMBERS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO COME UP IN. HEY GREETINGS AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA FOR BEING A CHAMPION ON
THIS BILL AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT
SB NINE SEVEN SIX UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL MY NAME IS LAWANDA DR
MY NAME IS DR BELINDA WESLEY I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER TALK TO RESOURCE
CENTER IS A NONPROFIT AND FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION BASED
IN LOS ANGELES AND SAMPOERNA
DINO COUNTY WE PROUDLY SERVE
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. TO THAT IN OUR VISION
IS TO SEE AND HELP REALIZE THE
ALL DAY ASKED IN OF HEALTHY AND
STRONG CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
LIVING AND THRIVING COMMUNITIES
AND TO DO SO THROUGH OUR MISSION
BY CULTIVATING CHILD FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY WELL BEING WITH A
WHOLE CHILD AND WHOLE FAMILY
APPROACH ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES THERE HAS BEEN DECADES OF
LONG PROGRESSION TO OFFER PEACE
SERVICES MORE BROADLY MANY
STATES HAVE IMPLEMENTED THOSE
MODELS WITH VARYING DEGREES OF
SIX. S. CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM OTHERS
IN THIS EFFORT. ONE THING IS
CLEAR UTILIZATION OF A MIX
DELIVERY MODEL ENGAGES AND BUILT
UPON THE EXISTING COMMUNITY
BASED HEALTHCARE PROGRAMS FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES AND HEAD START.
THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
CRITICAL TO THE OVERALL SUCCESS
OF NOT ONLY OUR PRESCHOOL
EFFORTS. BUT TO ALSO R. O. BUT
ALSO TO OUR OVERALL SYSTEM OF
CHILDCARE FOR CHILDREN BIRTH TO
TWELVE. AND FOR WORKING FAMILIES
WE KNOW ONE OF THE GREATEST
BENEFITS OF UNIVERSAL MIX
DELIVERY PRESCHOOL SYSTEM IS
THAT IT SUPPORTS FAMILY CHOICE.
AND THEIR STRONG SENSE OF AGENCY
TO MAKE ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
DECISIONS OF THEIR CHILD'S EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION JOURNAL. I AM
ONE OF THOSE FAMILIES WHO RELIED
ON THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
MY FIVE CHILDREN AS A SINGLE
PARENT RELIANCE ON SUBSIDIZED
CARE. BY FAR FAMILIES ARE THEIR
CHILD'S FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANT
ADULTS IN THEIR LIVES- CHILD'S
FIRST EDUCATOR AND THEREFORE
SHOULD HAVE EACH TRUE. AND
VIABLE CHOICE NOT A FALSE CHOICE
. FAMILIES SHOULD HAVE THE
CHOICE TO SELECT. THEIR CHILD
THE ANY EARLY CARE AND LEARNING
SETTING BASED ON THEIR CHILD
BASED ON THEIR FAMILY'S UNIQUE.
NEEDS AS WELL AS THEIR
PREFERENCES SO WHAT WILL IT TAKE
TO DO THIS WITH EXCELLENCE AND
WITH EFFICIENCY WELL I'M GLAD
YOU ASKED. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE THE CENTER FOR
AMERICAN PROGRESS RELEASED A
REPORT WHICH OUTLINES SIX KEY
COMPONENTS FOR PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT WILL SUPPORT A
STRONG EQUITABLE BIRTH TO. AGE
FIVE SYSTEM INCLUDING NUMBER ONE
DESIGN A SYSTEM FOR PRESCHOOL TO
BE DOUBLE LIVES BOTH LOCAL
SETTINGS INCLUDING FAMILY
CHILDCARE. SUPPORT HEAD START TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND THIRD TO
SERVE OVER TO SERVE MORE
PRESCHOOLERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I WANTED TO
MANDATORY THANK YOU. AND THEN
INVEST IN INFANTS AND TODDLERS
INCLUDING AND MAKING SURE THEY
ARE INCLUDED IN THE SYSTEM. AND
WE WANT TO JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WANT TO TAKE THIS
TIME AND ALSO HAVE THE TIME THE
STATE THIS SELLS COOPERATE WITH
FAMILIES. AND BEING AUTHENTIC
PARTNER IN THE SYSTEM AND THEN
AT CLOSING I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE PART OF THIS-
PART OF THIS CALL THE CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL AND THAT
INCLUDES. BEFORE YOU RESEARCH A
REFERRAL NETWORK EVERY CHAO
CALIFORNIA FIRST THING I DO HAVE
A FAURIA AND THEN I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN CENTER TO LEYVA
FOR YEARS CAN'T BE FREE BE A
CHAMPION. AND THEN I WANT TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HAVE A LEAD WITNESS NUMBER TWO.
OF THAT OUR WORK BY LIMITING- WE
TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES. PER
PERSON AND- LEAD WITNESS
SOMEBODY BEGIN. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY MONEY IN THIS LARA
MCINTYRE ONLINE THE CARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORKS PUBLIC
POLICY COMMITTEE WHICH IS A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK YOU TO
SENATOR LEYVA HOPE BEING A
CHAMPION. DESPITE THE SLOW. THE
BILL BACK BETTER WHICH CALLED
FOR AN EXTRA LIVER UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL WHICH HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN- ANY OTHER STATE.
I AM EXCITED THAT CALIFORNIA NOW
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE BOLD
AND CREATE THAT YOU TRULY
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THAT
ARE DIVERSE FAMILY TO SERVE A
NEED. I HAVE WORKED AT FORESEES
HEALTHCARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
AGENCY FOR SIXTEEN YEARS AND I'M
ALSO A PARENT OF A CHILD WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS WHO WAS NOT READY
FOR KINDERGARTEN. AND I WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH. I THINK A
MONTH TO BE ABLE TO PAY AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR OF PRIVATE
PRESCHOOL FOR HIM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND TO THRIVE IN
SCHOOL. I KNOW HOW DESPERATE ON
A CHILD SPENT INTEREST EFFECT
HELPS. PARENTS AND FAMILY. IT IS
WORKABLE TO FIND A PARTICULAR
CHILD CARE SETTING THEBEST MEET
THEIR YOUNG CHILD'S INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS AND BEING ABLE TO AFFORD
PROGRAM. THERE CAN BE A GREAT.
BETWEEN THAT DEVELOPMENTALLY A
VERY YOUNG CHILDREN AND WE
CANNOT EVER FORGET THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT VERY LITTLE HUMAN-
MAYBE FORTY EIGHT MONTHS. I'M
STILL MEETING NOW AND HELP WITH
SELF REGULATION AND SELF CARE.
AND FROM THE STANDPOINT LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES ARE MORE LIKELY
TO CHOOSE THE FREE OPTION WHAT
IS THAT BEST MEETS THEIR CHILD
NEED OR NOT. NOT YOUR CHILD UP
FOR SIX IS A GOOD FOR A PARENT
MANY FAMILIES WORK HOURS AND
WHILE SOME MAKE READY STRUCK
PROGRAM ON THE LARGEST CAMPUS.
OTHERS MAY NEED A SMALLER
SETTING UP FOR JUST A WHILE
LONGER OFFENDING REFLECTING
THEIR HOME LANGUAGE OR WITH A
PROVIDER WHO KNOWS I CAN MEET
THEIR CHILD'S PARTICULAR NEEDS.
OUR GREAT STATE. WORKED TO MEET
OUR FAMILY SEVERAS NEEDS.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR THE
STUDY OF HEALTHCARE EMPLOYMENT
70% IN Q. ONE TWO MINUTES IN
APPLICATORS ARE STEEPLE. THANK
YOU ARE PEOPLE PRIMARILY WOMEN
OF COLOR DURING THAT DIVERSITY
OF OUR CHILDREN YOU'RE READY FOR
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PRESCHOOL
TEACHER HAVE A SEAT. REQUIRE A
TEACHER FOR. AVERAGE EXPERIENCE
FAMILY TALK YOUR PROVIDERS IN
THE FIELD EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
SIXTEEN YEARS IN PRESCHOOL THANK
YOU SB NINE SEVENTY SIX OKAY
CALIFORNIA FAMILY OPTIONS THAT
CAN MEET THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
THEIR CHILDREN AND FAMILY
SITUATIONS AND FOR THESE REASONS
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL
HERE ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. WE
GOT WE GOT. NO
LINED UP- PLEASE REMEMBER TO
STATE YOUR NAME OR A POSITION ON
THE BILL WITH PLEASE COME
FORWARD. OUR DOOR TENURE IN
BURNHAM ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN
SIX. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON DEGREE
WITH CANDOR CARE LEARNING
COMPANIES I CAN- CARES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. ANY ADDITIONAL
ANA COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE HERE IN THIS ROOM NO
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE A
TOTAL OF PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVEN SIX. ONE NINE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AND WEBER TOLD MY NUMBER
ONE FORTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS ROBERT
MACROMOLECULE ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FOR STAMP IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WERE BOTH THE LINE NUMBER
TWO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANYBODY ON WHICH
POLITICAL SOLUTION CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB NINE SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT THE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON FIFTY
THAT'S BEEN WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
VERSION YOUR SUPPORT AND VOTE
FOR SB NINE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DONNA HOFFMAN
CALLING AND MARK WITH ANY
COUNCIL FOR A STRONG AMERICA
READY NATION FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS AND MISSION
READINESS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHT
MARIN Q. IT IS FINE OVER TO
EIGHTY EIGHT. A GOOD AFTERNOON
IN A FIFTY WITH EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROBLEMS CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT SB NINE SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR. BROUGH
NINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY NINE
SEIZE BY HAND. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE MICHELETTI COLBERN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT IS SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
TODDLER WAITING TO TIE. LINE
AND- TWO EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISTINE TRAN QUALITY
CISTICOLA BEYOND GRACE AND
TOPKAPI CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT SB NINE SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NUMBER NUMBER TWO
OH TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS COURTNEY BALL PC
WITH THE YMCA OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND OUR CHILD CARE
RESOURCE SERVICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXAVAR
CONVERT. OR HELLO THIS IS NANCY
WHY IT THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY CAL
CARE NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT
SB. NINE SEVEN SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE NEXT BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. THE
THREAT THAT. YOU KNOW I YOU WITH
THE CARE LAW AND THEIR INSTRUCT
WHAT ABOUT THE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WHAT THE LINE WHERE
WE NIGHT. THESE AHEAD. JENNIFER
REPRESENTING COLORFUL. YOU FOR
THE EDUCATION OF YOUNG CHILDREN
AND SUPPORT SB. NINE THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU HEY WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN THESE BY
HAND. HI THIRTY NINE I MEAN IT'S
NOT THE NOW WITH CHILDREN NOW
COMING IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYMORE IN THE QUEUE. CARE
MADAM CHAIR. NO PROBLEM THANK
YOU I WAS EXPECTING VIA AT THE
TOP OR IN THE BACKGROUND THE
STEP UP AS WELL BUT I WILL MOVE
ON TO IT WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IN THIS
ROOM. ANYONE OKAY ART THEN WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND LOOK TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
FOR ANY ONE- READY TO SPEAK ON
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVEN
SIX. IN OPPOSITION SB NINE SEVEN
CLICK THIS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. ONE FOR OPPOSITION. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN YOU MADAM
CHAIR. OKAY WELL I DO WE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ON HERE WHEN YOU
CREATE A TWENTY. FIRST. WE HAVE.
WE DON'T KNOW SHOULD I. APRIL
THIRTEENTH FOR THAT THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU IS PERFECT. IT
IS A LIE LOS DAY. OKAY WELL WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS MEASURE TO
REMOVE THE VEIL AND DO WE HAVE A
COUPLE CLICKS AND COMMENTS FROM
THE FIRST OKAY IT'S A LITTLE BIT
. RESPECT S. FOR AN AYE VOTE
OKAY TODD. MOST ALCOHOL TO KEEP
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS THE
PAST BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FOR TITLE I TITLE II JONES. FOR
DAILY RIGHT OR TO THE I. FROM
OTHER. PROMOTER I CAN'T FIGHT
YEAH I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS LOCAL PLACES
BELONG CALL THANK YOU. OKAY UP
NEXT WE HAVE A FIVE SENATE BILL
NINE NINE SIX. BY SENATOR COM
LONGER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB NINE SIX SIX
THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM IS TO MOVE
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY AND
TOWARDS. I SHOULD. EIGHT THOSE
LAWS I AM CARRYING SB NINE SIX
SIX WHICH WOULD HELP IN TWO WAYS
IT WOULD REPEAL LIMITATIONS ON
ASSETS WITH REGARDS TO CAO WORKS
ELIGIBILITY AND IT WOULD REPEAL
THE ONE HUNDRED OUR STANDARD
USED HERMAN AT THAT PROVISION OF
PARENTAL SUPPORT DUE TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT OF THEIR PARENT.
ASSET UNFAIRLY COURAGE
CALIFORNIA FROM SAVING
FINANCIALLY. RECIPIENTS FEAR
SAVING BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT
EVEN A SMALL AMOUNT OF EMERGENCY
SAVINGS WILL MAKE THEM APPEAR
LESS IN NEED OF ASSISTANCE. BUT
AS A RULE. BLACK THIS IS NEEDED
TO COPE COMMA FINANCIAL SETBACKS
SUCH AS GETTING A CAR FIXED OR
MEDICAL EMERGENCY. THE MAJORITY
OF CHARACTER KANSEN RECIPIENTS
NEVER COME CLOSE TO EXCEEDING
THE ASSET LIMIT LESS THAN 1% OF
TOTAL COWARDS CASES ARE
DISQUALIFIED BECAUSE THEY IF
HE'D CAN. VEHICLE AT LIMIT. ARE
MORE LIKELY GET STRUCK BY. THAN
TO BE- DISQUALIFIED STILL COUNTY
WORKERS ARE REQUIRED TO SCREEN
ALL APPLICANTS AND RECIPIENTS TO
VERIFY THEIR ELIGIBILITY UNDER
THE RULE. IS AT MATED THAT
ELIMINATING SAID TEST COULD
RESULT IN SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADMINISTRATIVE
SAVINGS. SB NINE NINE SIX WOULD
ALSO REMOVE THE CAL WORKS ONE
HUNDRED OUR ROLE IN THE PAST
STAYS WERE BARRED FEDERALLY FROM
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO
HOUSEHOLDS UNLESS IT OUT IN THE
HOME WAS DEPRIVED OF PARENTAL
SUPPORT. NO MATTER HOW IN THE
FAMILY IS. UNDER THIS NOW
DEFUNCT FEDERAL RULE TWO PARENT
HOUSEHOLDS WERE DEFINED
UNEMPLOYED IF BOTH PARENTS WORK
LESS ONE HUNDRED HOURS IN THE
MONTH. UPON IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE NEW FEDERAL LAW STATES WERE
NO LONGER REQUIRED TO RETAIN A
LOT MANY REPEAL IT. WE DID NOT.
THE DEPRIVATION TEST IS
ESTIMATED TO IMPACT THOUSANDS OF
POOR TWO PARENT WORKING FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THIS. DENYING THEM
CAL WORKS ASSISTANCE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE PRIMARY WAGE EARNER
WORKED TOO MANY HOURS. SO YOU
WORK TOO MANY HOURS TO MEAN YOUR
PORCH IS MEAN YOU WORK TOO MANY
HOURS. SB NINE NINE SIX WOULD
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR TWO
PARENT HOUSEHOLDS WHOSE PRIMARY
WAGER. IS WORKING FOR A LOW. BY
ALLOWING THESE FAMILIES TO
QUALIFY FOR CAL WORKS REGARDLESS
OF HOW MANY HOURS THEY WORK IF
THEIR INCOME IS BELOW THE
APPROPRIATE THRESHOLDS. THESE
OUTDATED AND UNNECESSARY CAL
WORKS RESTRICTIONS ARE CONTRARY
TO THE STATED GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM WHICH ENCOURAGES WORK
AND FAMILY UNITY. AS WELL AS
MAINTAINING FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE MIKE
HERALD WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON POVERTY. AND KEVIN AS LATE IN
WITH COLIN CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU CENTER CALL. ME FIRST
YOU MAY YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MY CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY- AND
WE STAND BY ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT THE SENATOR'S MAID- AND WE
WERE JUST REMIND FOLKS THAT WHEN
YOU KNOW WE ESTABLISHED PROGRAM
LIKE A WORKS IN THE PAST FIVE OR
MORE YEARS AGO- THE LAW OF
REALLY. THAT WERE FRANK DESIGNED
TO SAY NO TO PEOPLE TO DENY
PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY POOR THE
VERY ASSISTANCE THAT THEY NEED.
AND THIS COMMITTEE ARM FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS OR SO HAS BEEN IN
THE BUSINESS OF REMOVING A BUNCH
. MAKING IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO LIVE FOR ASSISTANCE
BEING ABLE TO GET ON ASSISTANCE
THAT THEY DESPERATELY NEED- THE
ASSET TEST IS REALLY A NEW.
ASSET EXAMPLE THE PAPER CHASE
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED
TO GO THROUGH WHEN WE ALL KNOW
OF THESE CLIENTSCOME IN THE
DOOR. HAVE THE ASSETS SO WE'RE-
IN GOVERNMENT SINCE. THAT COULD
BE UTILIZED. ACTUALLY HELPING
PEOPLE TEND TO QUE IN. THE KIND
OF ISSUES AND BEAR THEY HAVE A
THEIR LIVES BUT- WERE TRYING TO
DOWN YOU. THAT'S THE. BEST I
REALLY SUPPORT FOR MAYES HELLO
MY THE ONE HUNDRED HOURLY WHICH
I THE AUTHOR YOU KNOW LAY OUT
VERY WELL I'M REALLY WAS ANOTHER
ATTEMPT TO SIMPLY CASE. YOU KNOW
WE MAKING A JUDGMENT THAT IF YOU
WORK A HUNDRED HOURS SOMEHOW YOU
GOT ENOUGH MONEY AND IT'S THIS.
IF YOU'RE- ABOUT HELPING PEOPLE
GET TO A PLACE WHERE THEY MOVE
OUT OF POVERTY PERMANENTLY AND
WE DENY THEM THE CHILD CARE IN
THE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WATER TOWERS PROVIDES WERE
HOLDING THEM BACK AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL AND URGE AND LYFT THANK YOU
. NEXT KEVIN KEVIN AS THE COLUSA
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS THIS BILL DESIGNED
TO SIMPLIFY THE PROGRAM ALSO A
MERIT CAL IN FOOD STAMPS WE HAVE
THE WEST OF FIFTH AND MEDICARE
HOW IN A FOOD STAMPS WE HAVE
THOUGH DEPRAVATION NO HUNDRED
OVERALL THIS WOULD SIMPLIFY THE
PROCESS OF AND THE PLUSES AND
THE HUNDRED OUR RULE IS ATTACK
AGAINST TWO PARENT FAMILIES. WHO
APPLY YES TWO HUNDRED OF RULE
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH
YOU THINK EVEN IF YOU MAKE TEN
DOLLARS THEN YOU WORKED UNDER
HOURS THEY WOULD DENY YOU FOR
THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT A BILL
THAT YOU. TODAY AT WALTER NUMBER
FOUR TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM ON THIS
MEASURE. GOOD AFTERNOON BOTTOM
TRIPLE MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- PERTAIN BIRD AGAIN- ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES- IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL NINE NINE SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHERS HERE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THOSE IN
SUPPORT ON THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF NINE NINE THANK. THAT
IS THE ONE BAND ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE BUT AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE NINE SIX ONE
NINE ZERO. THEN WILL START WORK
MY NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WITH ALL THIS
GREENBERG TRAURIG REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HEY NEXT WILL BOTTOM
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU KNOW
LIKE WITH A TRUCK ALONG ON THE
COURT YEAH THANK YOU. AB ONE
MORE MOMENT WE HAVE WARNING
YOU'RE GETTING THERE MY NUMBER.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN Q. IN SUPPORT AND SHARE
OKAY WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT OF
WE DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE ANY
A WITNESSES HERE IN THIS ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THEKNOT
OKAY ARE MOVING ON TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
AND THOSE THAT WANT TO DESPITE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. NAME
AN ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON
THE- ON THE BILL. OUR MODERATOR
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THAT LINE. WE
HAVE OPPOSITION OF F. E. NINE
NINE SIX THAT IS ONE AND YOU'RE
ON YOUR PHONE. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION AND YOU MADAM CHAIR.
OKAY WELL- I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS BEFORE HAND OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES INTERESTS THANK YOU
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL. R. AS
YOU'RE WORKING FAMILIES- COULD
YOU STRUGGLE TO AFFORD BASIC
NEEDS WE LIKE RENT AND FOOD.
YOUR CALL WORKS IS AN IMPORTANT
SAFETY NET AND THIS BILL WILL
WILL- HELP SIMPLIFY THE
ELIGIBILITY PROCESS AND SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH I THINK IT KIND OF
WATER TODAY THAT THERE IS A NEED
TO MODERNIZE DIFFERENT TIME SO.
OF MUCH NEEDED BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND IT COMES FROM OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK- BECAUSE CENTER COM LARGER
FOR BRING THIS BILL FORWARD I
MEAN AND FRANKLY THIS IS THIS IS
NOT ACTUALLY SAVING THE
GOVERNMENT MONEY. RIGHT SO I
MEAN THERE'S A LOT OF THE GOOD
REASONS WHICH WAS ARTICULATED BY
THE AUTHOR BUT- NO LET'S LET'S
NOT WASTE GOVERNMENT MONEY- BY
SENSUALLY GO THROUGH GOING TO
PERFORM IT IS- ACTIONS. YES
MAYBE THERE IS. A NON TOPIC
SOMEWHERE WHO SOMEHOW ACTUALLY
HAS A LOT OF ASSETS PROBABLY
PHONE REALLY HARD TIMES. OUT
THERE BUT FOR US TO SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO TRY TO.
FIND THAT PERSON TO KEEP THEM
FROM GETTING CAL WORKS. IS NOT
VERY EFFICIENT USE OF GOVERNMENT
FUNDS I'D ALSO POINT OUT THAT
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THAT. IT'S
AMAZING THAT IN A PROGRAM CALLED
CAL WORKS WE ACTUALLY DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO WORK BY PUTTING AN
HOUR LIMIT ON HOW MUCH THEY CAN
WORK. CLEARLY IF YOU'RE NOT
MAKING ANY MONEY THEN YOU'RE
PROBABLY UNDERPAID AND YOU STILL
GET TO OUR X. AND IF YOU HAPPEN
TO MAKE MORE YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO. THAT'S IT. GOOD REASONS I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND BE SURE TO
GOVERNMENT WORKS MORE
EFFECTIVELY SAVE TAXPAYERS MONEY
AS A TAXPAYER THANK YOU. I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OKAY WITH
THE NON ARTS CENTER COME. YEAH I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT THE ASSET
TEST AND THE ONE HUNDRED OUR
RULE PENALIZE PEOPLE FOR BEING
POOR AND THEN SHAME THEM FOR
TRYING NOT TO BE AND WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. THANK YOU I. HAVING A MOTION
ON HERE WILL GO AHEAD BY CENTER
PANNED- A COUPLE THAT YOU PLEASE
CALL THE- MOTION IT PASSED BUT
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS HURTADO. AYE
HURTADO AYE JONES. OUR DAILY ALL
RIGHT OR TO THE I HOWEVER HI
FROM WHERE I STAND HI CAN I. THE
VOTED FOUR ZERO THE VOTE WAS
FOUR ZERO AND THE PERCEPTUAL ON
CALL THANK YOU UP NEXT WE HAVE
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TEN
FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LA MALL
ON THE WELCOME. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SB TEN FORTY SEVEN MAKES
SEVERAL IMPORTANT CHANGES TO OUR
CHILD CARE SYSTEM PARTICULARLY
BY MAKING ENROLLMENT EASIER FOR
PROVIDERS AND FAMILY AS WELL AS
PROVIDING MORE CARE FOR
TODDLERS. AS A WORKING MOTHER
WITH THE TOP I'VE CERTAINLY HAD
CHALLENGES WITH HEALTH CARE MANY
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS FACE THE
SAME STRUGGLE. CURRENTLY OUR
SYSTEMS ONLY SERVING 10% OF IN
ELIGIBLE INFANTS AND TODDLERS
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
CHILDCARE SB FIFTY WILL ADDRESS
INEFFICIENCIES IN THE SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE CHILDREN. FIGHTERS
THIS. CHOIR METERS TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES BUT ALLOWS CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND PARENTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY THIS BILL WILL OPEN
UP THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
TO YOUNGER CHILDREN BY OPENING
TO CHILDREN EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
FIVE YEARS WE CAN SERVE MORE
ANDERSON OF TODDLERS
ADDITIONALLY AS FIFTY WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER FOR FAMILIES FROM ALL
AND STATE ENROLLED IN CHILD CARE
IT EASES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON PARENTS AND PROVIDES.
FORMER I MEAN FOR SOME MINOR
PORTABILITY IF A PARENT CAN SHOW
THAT THEY ARE ENROLLED IN
PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICARE CALFRESH
OR WAKE OR HEAD START THE WILL
BE PRESUMED ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE I HAVE MET WITH-
TODAY WE HAVE MADE. FROM AT
TODAY OKAY GREEN BERNARDO TO
PRESENT IN SUPPORT AND SPEAKING
FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU WILL
START WITH THE FIRST WITNESSES
THE. GOOD AFTERNOON CEMEX AND
SURFACE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS A NEW BERNARDO MY
HUSBAND AND I LIVE IN HAYWARD
AND SENATE DISTRICT TEN AT. CAN
RESONATE.
IF YOU CAME OUT HERE. I THANK HI
IT'S THREE YEARS OLD AND THE
YOUNGEST IS NINE MONTHS OLD.
BOTH OF MY BOYS ATTENDED AN
INFANT AND TODDLER CARE PROGRAM
FAMILY ANDRO. HOWEVER WHEN HIGH
TREE THREE ACTOR RECERTIFY AND
CAMPBELL HANJIN ANOTHER PEOPLE
ENTER IN UNION CITY. BEING ABLE
TO HAVE TIME CARE FOR MY
CHILDREN EX. IT HAPPENED IN THE
WORLD IN THE SAME PROGRAM I'M
NOT NEEDING TO LEARN HOW TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH ENROLLMENT
PROCESS WHAT THE POLICIES ARE.
OR SON HAD ALREADY BEEN A THE
INFANT AND APPROACH. DURING THAT
RUN ACROSS IN ROME BRUSHLESS
FLAT AND WORK WITH ME FOR THREE
HOURS TO GET BOTH OF THE PEOPLE
WORK THAT. I THINK THAT FAMILIES
WHO ARE ENROLLED IN CALFRESH AND
MEDI CAL SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
ENROLL IN STATE PRESCHOOL. BUT
THE PROCESS IS LESS OF A BURDEN
FOR FAMILIES AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. HI MY THREE YEAR OLD
IS DOING VERY WELL AND INCREASED
CORE CENTER. SHE STARTED IN. THE
COLOR PROGRAM THE TOP CENTER
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF LIFE SKILLS
THAT YOU'LL BE USING FOR THE
REST OF HIS LIFE. OKAY
APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS BILL IS
THAT IT CREATES CONTINUITY OF
CARE FOR CHILDREN TREMAYNE IN
THE CENTER OF. THE PROGRAM
CURTAIN LOCAL. DO YOU TAKE
RECERTIFICATION PROCESS HI AND
MY YOUNGER SON ARE NO LONGER
ACCEPTING CHAPTER CENTER. HAS
MADE MY- SHOPPING. I ALSO HAD
ABOUT THE WORK OUR- CANCELLED
MOST OF MY PARENTS GAVE ME
ACTIVITIES FOR MYSELF. AT THE
TEN FORTY SEVEN LAKE NUCLEAR
PROGRAM ME THAT OF COURSE
CHILDCARE AND PRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDER.
THANK YOU WE HAVE AN DO WE HAVE
NEXT FOOT. ON THE CALL. THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MIGHT
HAVE A MARK FIVE OF ADVOCACY AND
POLICY WITH THE TANGO A CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL PROVIDER IN
THE GATE AREA SERVING FOUR
THOUSAND I MEAN. I'M IN OF
COURSE THERE OF THIS. PRETTY
SEVEN WITH TRYING. BUT I THINK
THE FEMININE MADE. PROVIDER
COULD BETTER SERVE NEEDS OF OUR
CHILDREN FAMILY. ESPECIALLY
TODDLERS WHICH IS WHERE WE SEE
THE GREATEST UNMET NEEDS. WE
KNOW THAT QUALITY CHILDCARE
DURING THOSE EARLY YEARS OF
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT THAT THE
STRONG ON THE- IF YOU. THE
FOURTEENTH. AND THE PLAN ONLY
ONE IN FIVE FIELDS WERE ELGIN-
ARE IN ROLE IN SUBSIDIZED
PROGRAM FURTHERMORE THE CURRENT
SYSTEM OF THE FLAG EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE IS OVERLY
COMPLEX COORDINATED AND YOU CAN
FORTY ONE TRIES TO REMEDY THIS
ISSUE BY MOVING YOUR APPROACH.
AND UP WILL PROBE SERVES
CHILDREN EIGHT MONTHS TO FIVE
YEARS RATHER THAN ONLY THREE TO
FOUR OLD RIGHT NOW. THAT'S RIGHT
YEAH AND THE OF MONEY THEY
INCREASED CONTRA DOESN'T ALWAYS
THAN OF OUR FAN. THE PROVIDED.
TO SERVE YOUNGER WITHIN PROJECT
CONTRACT OUR GOAL WITH THIS IS
TO EXPAND A ELIGIBILITY WILEMAN
QUALITY I WONDERS. THREE IN ALL
BRANDS YOUR CONTRACT AND SERVICE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY THE BILL ALSO
ALLOW AMAGE CARE HOME TO SERVE
CHILDREN IN THE PRE GROUP WHICH
WE THREE OTHERS SHOCK TO PROVIDE
TWICE FOR PARENTS AND THE BILL
IS FOR PROVIDERS WELCOME. FOR
FAMILY. BY REDUCE BURDEN WORK
ACT THANK YOU AND METAL CAL
PROPER WITH. AND ALSO FOR WITH
THEIR BOOK ACTUAL THEY WOULDN'T
TO WITH CONTINUALLY FOR THE
MIDDLE A DAY PAPERWORK THIS BILL
HOW TOWARDS A MORE TO SOMEWHERE
LOW. SO I'M WORKING. TWENTY
FOUR. ONE WORK AND THEIR
CHILDREN CAN LEARN AND STABLE
HIGH QUALITY AND THEREFORE I
URGE YOU SUPPORT FOR YOU CAN
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK I
THANK YOU FOR THE BOTH OF YOU
FOR A TEST NOW BEGIN WHAT MISS.
PART OF THIS. THANK YOU MOVING
ON TO PUBLIC COME FOR THOSE WORK
. YOUR SUPPORT OF F. TEN SEVEN
IS ONE TWENTY ON YOUR PHONE AND
WE WERE BOTH A LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY NINE. DAPHNE MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE A
HORRIBLE ON BEHALF OF EARLY I.
PROBABLY COULD SPONSOR OF THAT
YOU CAN FORTY SEVEN- DR THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NUMBER NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SOMEONE
WITH A CALIFORNIA PHONE POLICE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEMPLATE I MEAN THINK OF. THANK
YOU. TWO EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE FATAH
HAWKS AND CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COUNCIL FOR SOFTWARE RIGHT ASIA
. ABOUT AIDS AND MISSED
READINESS THE COURT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WOULD HAVE WON NUMBER
TWO NINETY TWO THE BILL HAS.
SURE MEMBERS ATTEND NATIONAL OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINETY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON UNIVERSITY WITH EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINETY GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER CLICK HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR THE EDUCATION OF
YOUNG CHILDREN IN SUPPORT OF
ATHLETES AND FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU HAVE A LINE NUMBER NINETY
NINE. AFTERNOON CARE NUMBERS
CHAIRED CALL WITH NURSE
CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTOR FOR THANK
YOU. EIGHTY NINE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY NINE. I NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A HEARING NOTHING FROM TWO
SEVENTY NINE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYMORE IN YOU MADAM CHAIR. OKAY
PEOPLE THINK WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OF. ANYONE HERE THAT NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO ANY. WILL
TO MOVE UP MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN A POSITION TO THIS
BILL- HERE AND WE'RE TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. NO NONE OF ALL RIGHT-
WHAT ABOUT ON THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. YOUR IN
OPPOSITION IT IS ONE ZERO.
OPPOSITION ONE THEN ZERO ONE YOU
FOUND. WE HAVE SO MANY CUTE SIGN
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY NINE- IS THAT
ME YES HI CAN YOU STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE. YES SORRY ABOUT
THAT TRY TO GET IN FOR THE
SUPPORT LINE- EVERYTHING FROM A
YOUNG WITH POLITICAL SOLUTIONS
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY OTHER
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT WE
COULD NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
MESSENGER. OKAY GREAT- I WANTED
IT HANDED OVER TO- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ANY COMMENTS ON THIS
MEASURE THE BILL OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS A MEASURE. AND
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OKAY. CONTROL TO KEEP ON SB TEN
FORTY SEVEN GIVEN WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAT. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HURTADO. FOR DIAL
BY JONES. COURTESY OF THE I.
FROM MARKER. PAN HI. THAT IS
THREE ZERO WE WILL PLACE THIS
BILL ON CALL CENTER LAMONT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR A FIELD. OKAY UP
NEXT WE HAVE- CENTER I'M BURKE
WITH. SIX RESULT OF A ME TO WALK
UP HERE YEAH RIGHT MY PLACE
THAT'S OKAY WITH. BY NEXT MONTH
I'M ACTUALLY NEXT. YEAR THAT'LL
GO HEAD GO HEAD TO. HEAD RIGHT
WELL AGENDA ITEM EIGHT SENATOR
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FIVE CENTER-
BURKE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
YOUR CRITICS HAITIANS. OF IN
MEMBERS ON A PARTICULAR THANK
BRIDGET HANKERSON FOR HER HARD
WORK AND EFFECTIVE WORK ON THIS
BILL. THIS IS S. B. ELEVEN FORTY
ONE IS THE REPLACEMENT OF
ELECTRONIC BENEFIT. THEFT OF
THOSE WHO RECEIVE EBT CARDS. I
SUBJECT THE SAME KIND OF STUFF
THAT OTHERS ARE THIS- AGE OF
TECHNOLOGY IN THIS BILL SIMPLY.
ALLOWS THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN THE
VICTIM OF THEFT- AS TO THEIR EBT
CARD TO BASICALLY I HAVE THAT
AMOUNT REPLACED- AS YOU WOULD
EXPECT IF YOU'RE THE VICTIM OF A
CRIME. ME TODAY MY CURLED WITH
THE WEST THERE ARE A LOT OF
POVERTY AND ANDREW BECAUSE
IRAQIS WITH THE LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES. WHAT
SIR. THANK YOU CENTER MADAM
CHAIR MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW POVERTY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- THIS IS A
CASE THAT THE BILL THAT REALLY
INNATE ANIMAL OUT OF A LAWSUIT
THAT WE DID WITH THE- THEY
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES AND I
LET MY COLLEAGUE FOR LAUGHS THIS
BETTER MORE RETAILERS. BUT FOR
MANY YEARS- WE HAVEN'T I
CONTINUE THE NUMBER OF THE CAR
BROWN CALIFORNIA- AND WHAT
THAT'S WHAT. A SOMEWHERE TO GET
- BENEFITS RESTORED APPLYING-
THIS ISSUE IS STILL UP AND
CODIFY THE LOS. TO READ THE WAY
IT USED TO HENCE THE NEED FOR
THE BILL- BUT THE PROBLEM OF
BENEFIT THEFT IS AN ONGOING AND
SERIOUS ONE WE HEAR ABOUT THESE
REPORTS STATEWIDE ON A REGULAR
BASIS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THE
A. G. ACTUALLY ARRESTED SOMEBODY
WHO STOLE. FIRST ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE. WAS ANY. IT'S ALL. I
THINK THE- OVER HUNDRED GOT.
WAIT SO THE NEED FOR OF IN THIS
IS REALLY IN IN AND SOMETHING WE
NEED TO TAKE CARE OF AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT- AT
ELEVEN. TONIGHT AND WE HOPE TO
HEAR FROM THE WILL TRUMP-
LEGALLY FOUNDATION NOW. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE THE FIVE IN THE
AFTERNOON. THESE AGAIN HI GOOD
AFTERNOON. HAVE A POLITICS GOOD
AFTERNOON NONE OF A PROVIDER
MARK THE COMMITTEE BUT IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FORTY WHICH I. SUPPORT
OF ONE I THINK SENATOR ROBERT
FOR INTRODUCING. MY NAME IS
JESSICA DOCKET AND ON THE TOP
THIRTY WITH LAUGHABLE M. AS PART
OF THE TEAM RETURN ALONG WITH
WESTERN CENTER WHO BROUGHT THE
ORTEGA V. JOHN CASE. WHICH HELD
THAT LONG OVERLOOKED STATE
REGULATIONS. BUT APART. TWENTY
BOB MIGHT THE TOP MANY SKIMMING
OF THE YEARS AND SEEN HOW
PAINFUL IS FOR LOW INCOME HOW.
WHICH INCLUDE YOUNG CHILDREN
BEING OR PEOPLE LIVING WITH. IN
THE HACKERS WERE GREATLY FEEL
EACH ACCOUNT INFORMATION. WAIT
UNTIL THE DATE THAT BENEFITS ARE
LOADED ONTO THE ACCOUNT AND THEN
DURING THE FAMILY'S ENTIRE FOOD
ALLOTMENT FOR THE MONTH IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. ORTEGA'S
JOHNSON THE DEPARTMENT REFUSED
TO RESTORE THE STOLEN COULD
BENEFIT BECAUSE THE CURRENT
STATE STATUTE. ONLY EXPRESSLY
REQUIRES SKIN CASH BENEFITS TO
BE RESTORED NOT FOOD. MY CLIENTS
WOULD ASK ME. FOR THE CREDIT
CARDS AND DEBIT CARDS YOU GET
HACKED GET THEIR MONEY BACK IN A
FEW DAYS BUT I CAN'T GET MY FOOD
STAMPS BACK WHAT I NEED. SO I
CAN EAT- THERE WAS NO GOOD
ANSWER FOR THE COMMONSENSE
QUESTION WHICH IS WHY SB ELEVEN
FORTY IT'S SUCH NECESSARY
LEGISLATION. THE BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROTECTED
AGAINST WEAKENING UNDER
STATUTORY LAW NOT JUST STATE
REGULATION. URBAN REGIONALLY
DIDN'T WANT TO FOLLOW AND THEY
CAN BE EASILY REMOVED BY FUTURE
REGULATORY ABOUT. THIS BILL BUT
ALSO CRUCIALLY MAKER REPORTING
PROCESS SIMPLER FOR EVERYONE.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TWO SEPARATE
CLAIMS PROPERTIES FOR STOLEN
CASH AND FOOD WITH SEPARATE
ELIGIBILITY AND TIGHTENING RULES
AND IT. RELATES BACK TO THE FACT
THAT. ONE TRACK COMES FROM THE
OTHER COMES REGULATION SO JUST
KIND OF A RANDOM ANOMALY.
MYSTIFICATION CREATES CONFUSION
WITH COUNTY WORKERS TIME AND
CREATES A HEADACHE FOR VICTIMS
WHO ARE ALREADY STRAPPED OUT
AFTER BEING ROBBED THE BENEFITS.
ENOUGH NOW TO GET YOU SET UP
YOUR CREDIT RULES. AND BECAUSE
THE DEADLINE TO REPORT FOOD
THEFT IS MUCH SHORTER FOR
STERLING CACHET- I'M SORRY IT.
IT'S MUCH BETTER THAN FILLING
CASCADE MANY HOUSEHOLDS STILL
CAN'T GET THEIR FOOD BENEFITS
BACK EVEN NOW. THIS BILL WOULD
BE EVERYONE A FAVOR BY UNIFIED
THE UNIFYING ALL ELECTRONIC
STUFF PLAN TO THINK PROCEDURE
WITH A SINGLE REASONABLE TIME
FRAME. AND FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE YOU TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THE SCHOOL THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE HERE
IN THIS ROOM. KEVIN AS A
CHORISTER CALIFORNIA OVER RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TO HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS
WINNING OKAY AND HERE IN THIS
ROOM. THREE NINE WILL MOVE ON TO
TELL FROM PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. IF YOU
ARE IN. SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT IS
ONE THEN YOU'RE ON YOUR PHONE.
THAT IS IN SUPPORT AT E. ONE ONE
FOUR ZERO. AND WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER NINETY NINE. YOUR CALL
FROM NURSE CALIFORNIANS FOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. MADAM
CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION WITNESS BUT
WILL TAKE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
OFFICE THIS BILL BEGINNING IN
THIS ROOM. SEEN NONE. OF ONTO
THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMON LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
YOUR IN OPPOSITION OF ACT II
ELEVEN FORTY ONE NINE ZERO I
FOUND. THAT'S OPPOSITION SB
ELEVEN FORTY. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY IN HERE MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU WHAT I DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON ON THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE JUST HAVE A QUESTION TO
THE ALTERNATE THIS THIS IS AN
AREA THAT I THINK. IT'S KIND OF.
THE FUTURE RIGHT IN TERMS OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WILL FACE WITHIN
THE STATE AND THAT'S HAKKINEN.
AND AS A WAY TO CREATE MORE MORE
TENSION WITHIN OUR COMMUTE TO.
IT FOLDABLE COMMUNITIES STRUGGLE
EVEN MORE I. WAS WONDERING I
KNOW THERE'S- THERE'S THE
REPORTING PIECE ON FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT- WE DO TO YOU
KNOW TO. FOURTEEN OF CAN
INCIDENTS FROM ITALY LIKE DOES
THE DEPARTMENT. IT REPORT THAT
TO ANYBODY OR IS THAT JUST KIND
OF GOES NO WHERE WHAT DO YOU
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT- LET
ME. FIRST TAKE A CRACK AND THEN
DEFERRED MY WITNESSES OKAY- THE
ANSWER IS YES IS PREVALENT- AS
TO. THE PREVALENCE- AND IT'S
BECOME A LARGER LARGER ISSUE AS
FOLKS BECOME MORE SOPHISTICATED-
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
ACQUIRE THINGS THAT DON'T BELONG
TO THEM ELECTRONICALLY. AND THEN
IN TERMS OF REPORTING YES I
BELIEVE THAT THAT THEY ARE
REPORTING THAT WHEN THIS. IS
FOUND IT IS REPORTED LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT LET ME LET ME
ASK- HERALD OR OTHERS WHO ARE
PRESENT TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
THAT. FROM EACH OF THESE CASES
HAS TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS OF
BEING APPROVED BY THE COUNTY NOW
SO- IF CDSS WANTED TO TALLY UP
ALL. THE DIRT BETTER. PROCESS
VENUS BY THE CAN'T BY THE
COUNTIES WE GET DETERMINE NUMBER
I'M NOT AWARE THAT THAT HAS
HAPPENED TO DATE- BUT I THINK AS
WE BOTH OF THE TWO WITNESSES FOR
THE BILL THAT. IS A GROWING
PROBLEM WE'RE SEEING IT IN A
OFFICES- SO GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE PEOPLE GOT RID OFF.
EIGHTEEN IS A FAIR NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THIS IS. TO AYE THINK
YOU'RE POINT IS VERY WELL TAKEN
MADAM CHAIR THAT THIS IS A
GROWING PROBLEM SOMETHING THAT
THE COMMITTEE SHOULD REALLY KEEP
AN EYE ON AS WE GO FORWARD. AND
MAY WANT TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
ITSELF TO COME BACK AND REPORT
ON THE DATA. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ACTUALLY- BUT THE REASON WHY I
ASK IS BECAUSE I DO HAVE A CYBER
SECURITY BILL. BUT THE FOCUS IS
ON. WATER AND FOOD SLASH
AGRICULTURE BUT IT DOESN'T. I'M
NOT. I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT.
ACTUALLY EXTENDS TO. YOUR THE
SOCIAL SERVICES AND I THINK
THAT. THE BILL SHOULD. ACTUALLY
BE EXPANDED TO ARE CRITICAL. AS
FIFTY OF SEX. I MEANT TO. HAPPEN
REAL UNDERSTANDING OF. WHAT HOW
BAD IT IS AND WHAT MORE WE NEED
TO DO TO DO RIGHT BECAUSE I I'M
I'M ASSUMING IT'S AT MINIMUM
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
THAT WE JUST WE DON'T HAVE
ANYMORE AND SO I REALLY PPQ-
BRING IN THIS TO BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND HAPPY TO. BID
THAT YOU BROUGHT FORTH FALL I'LL
DEVELOP TWENTY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT ARE PAN. BUT THANK
YOU AND THE SERVER OF THE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- THERE WAS A
COMMENT IN THE- IN THE ANALYSIS-
THAT AND IT IS IT'S ROUND I
GUESS THE TERM ELECTRONIC
BENEFITS WHETHER THERE'S CLEARLY
IN THAT VERSES THAT THE USING
CASH AND FOOD BENEFITS I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO JUST
CLARIFY THAT. IT'S NOT JUST
PLEASE VISIT CASH. BUT I THINK
IT WAS ALSO THE CONSOLE AT LEAST
IN THEIR HOUSES THEY RAISE THE
ISSUE OF WHETHER THE TERM
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS IS CLEAR
ENOUGH FOR WHAT WE HAVE TO
BETTER DEFINE THAT OR USE
ANOTHER TERMINOLOGY SO. I'M THE
END OF THE- DRESS THAT AS AND
CERTAINLY GIVE ME SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
ADDRESS THAT YOU'LL FIX AS IT
MOVES FORWARD BUT AND NOBODY HAD
ANY. COMMENTS ABOUT THAT AT THIS
POINT CERTAINLY THE INTENT OF
THE BILLS TO MAKE SURE THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS A
BENEFIT THAT IS. LESSENED BY
VIRTUE OF ANOTHER- TAKING THAT
BENEFIT. THEN WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S REPLENISH ACTUALLY SO
WHATEVER TERMINOLOGY.
ACCOMPLISHES THAT THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO DO AND IF WE
NEED TO MAKE IT CLEAR WILL DO
SO. OKAY YEAH IT DOES MAKE NOTE.
ANALYSIS AND I. AGAINST SUPPORT
THE INTENT TO YOUR BILL- SOUNDS
LIKE. I WISH THE BUDGET OR- AT
IS THE THREE SAID TO GO TO COURT
THAT THE STATION ACTUALLY HAD TO
INTERPRET THE LATEST SO NARAL.
THAT WITH DID NOT ALLOW. FOR
THEM FOR THE ADDRESS AND TO TAKE
. SETS.
SHOW COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEE NINE OKAY
WE HAVE. AMOTION TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD US SENATOR UMBERG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THE
THANK YOU A MANAGER YOU RAISE AN
IMPORTANT POINT HERE AND IF IT'S
NOT THE CASE. THEN IT SHOULD BE
THE CASE AND EITHER THROUGH YOUR
BILL THIS BILL- THAT IN ADDITION
TO REPLENISHING THE BENEFITS WE
WANT TO. HEAD AND IDENTIFY AND-
SEEK EITHER RESTITUTION OR
PERHAPS BOTH OF SOME PUNISHMENT.
FROM THOSE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
PREYING UPON THOSE WITH EBT
CARDS. SO IF THAT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT THEN WE WILL
CONSIDER MAKING. BUT WITH THAT
AND I WILL. OKAY CONTROL TO CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THIS
MEASURE. THE MOTION IS THE PATH
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HURTADO. I HURTADO I'D JONES.
COURTESY REALLY FOR THE I
CONAGRA COM WEBER I CAN'T FIGHT
IN. I THANK YOU CENTER VIRTUAL
PLACE THAT WILL HOLD UP BILL FOR
. A CALL TO ALLOW OTHERS TO VOTE
AND WE WILL GO BACK TO. AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. WHICH IS
SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY SIX THAT
IS ME. I AND I WILL GO AHEAD AND
IF THAT'S OKAY CENTER PANDA.
WITH OVER TWO. I GO BACK. THANK. THIRTY TADO GOING TO TESTIFY
FROM THE YOUR CARE R. YES OKAY
ALL RIGHT- SO WE'RE NOW ON ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB. TEN SIXTY SIX
BY CENTER TADO THESE BEGIN.
THANK RESEARCH CHAIR OF THE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB TEN SIXTY SIX
THE CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS
DROUGHT RESILIENCE PILOT PROJECT
OF WE KNOW THAT WE WERE IN A
DROUGHT AND OUR STATE CONTINUES
TO STRUGGLE THROUGH AND IT HAS
OVERWHELMING YOU HURT
CALIFORNIA'S FARMS AND FARM
FIRST IT IS THAT WE HAVE. NOT
SEEN BEFORE AND IT HAS IT BEEN
HAS BEEN. A SIGNIFICANT LOSS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BUT- IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALLOW ALONE-
THE DROUGHT BECAUSE ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN DIRECT
COSTS TO THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY IN THE LOSS OF OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED JOBS
. AND YET THE RAMIFICATIONS WE
SEE NOW ARE ONLY THE BEGINNING
OF A LONG AND ARDUOUS PROCESS.
BASED ON THIS YEAR'S RAINFALL
AND SNOWPACK AND JUST OVER ALL
OF WATER CLIMATE IN THE STATE
ARE WE KNOW THAT. WE'RE JUST
IT'S ONE ABOUT THE TRAJECTORY
HERE ARE AND THE DROUGHT HAS LED
TO CHANGES IN DAY TO DAY LIFE
FOR ALL OF US OF CALIFORNIANS
AND TO BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
STATE THAT ARE COMING TO TERMS
WITH THE NEED OF. HAVING TO
RATION THE THEIR WATER USAGE BUT
THE IMPACTS HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD ON AT THE AT
THE PEOPLE IN IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT IN THE HEART OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. ARE A STEADY
WATER SUPPLY EIGHT YOU KNOW THAT
OUR FARMS ARE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE
OUR OUTPUTS ALONG FARMWORKERS TO
WORK THE HOURS RECEIVE THE WAGES
THEY NECESSARY TO MEET THEIR
BOATS BASED IN. BUT WITH THE- NO
END TO THE DROP INSIDE SOME
FARMERS ARE HAVING TO MAKE THAT
TOUGH DECISION TO REDUCE PLENTY
AND IN SOME CASES FELLOW
PORTIONS OF THEIR LANDING
FARMWORKERS WITHOUT HOURS OR
WITHOUT WORK MORE THAN EVER AS
THEY LOSE VITAL WORK
OPPORTUNITIES. I TO COMBAT THIS
WE MUST CONSIDER NEW CREATIVE
APPROACHES TO LEGISLATION THAT.
THE BIG GET CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
SB TEN SIXTY SIX CREEK THE
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER DROUGHT
RESILIENCE BY THE PORCH BE STAE
FUNDED SUPPLEMENTAL PROGRAM THAT
WILL PROVIDE CASH ASSISTANCE TO
ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS SO THEY CAN
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS. OF THIS
PILOT PROJECT WOULD PROVIDE ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH TO
HEALTH TO HOUSEHOLDS WHO MEET
SPECIFIC ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA.
CALIFORNIA'S FARMWORKERS ARE
CRUCIAL TO OUR STATE FOOD SUPPLY
CHAIN AND OUR OVERALL ECONOMY
AND THIS PILOT PROJECT WILL
ENSURE THE FUNDS GO DIRECTLY TO
OUR MOST AFFORDABLE FARMWORKERS.
THE BACKBONE OF OUR STATE WHO
REALLY NEED NEED THE FUNDS THE
MOST AND QUITE FRANKLY ALWAYS
END UP GETTING LEFT BEHIND WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE. WE
NEVER REALLY TALK ABOUT IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF FARMWORKERS. AS
THE REALITY ELECT THE IPCC
REPORT CAME OUT JUST LAST YEAR
THAT THE CLIMATE CHANGES HERE
THERE'S NO WORD TO RUN THERE'S
NOWHERE TO HIDE THAT WAS ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE- PUTS THAT WAS
THAT WAS PROVIDED AND- AND
THAT'S THAT'S VERY MUCH TRUE AND
THAT'S BEEN VERY MUCH FELT BY
OUR MOST VULNERABLE. COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE PARTICULARLY
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND FOOD
SYSTEMS OUR FOOD SYSTEM IS GONE
IS ALREADY BEING SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
DUE TO THE DROUGHT TO. AND SO WE
MUST DO MORE BUT WE MUST D MORE
FOR THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY BEEN LEFT LEFT
BEHIND. AND WE MUST RECOGNIZE
THE VALUE OF THEIR HARD OF THE
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH SUPPORT THEY
NEED NOW. BECAUSE THEY THEY
HONESTLY THEY NEEDED THE SUPPORT
YESTERDAY- OR THE- LAST YEAR THE
YEAR BEFORE THAT AND WE HAVEN'T
PROVIDED THAT SUPPORT TO THEM SO
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE- WHAT WHEN
IS JOINING US FROM WHAT LEE. AND
THAT- AND NON A NON THIS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER FOUNDATION
. RIGHT THANK YOU US AT HER
TADO- MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON
TO LINE HER NAY HERNANDEZ
HERNANDEZ FROM CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKER FOUNDATION. THAT'S TO
FIND SUPPORT. YEAH THANK YOU
HAVE A PHOTO OF THE FORMER FARM
WORKER AND THE LEADER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC A FOUNDATION A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVES OVER THIRTY. THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS LAST YEAR AND AS AN
ORGANIZATION I CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA DROUGHT IS AFFECTING
THE LIVES OF FARMWORKERS BY
DECREASING THE HOURS OF. THE
BASE. THERE ARE NOW HAVING
FUTURE GOOD ON THE TABLE BEING
AS THEIR IS LESS WORK
AGRICULTURE BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF WATER AVAILABILITY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. SB TEN SIXTY SIX
WILL BRING MUCH NEEDED RELIEF
FOR FARMWORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES BY PROVIDING THEM WITH
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE TO CONTINUE
TO LIVE UNDER THE CURRENT
CHANGES IN CLIMATE I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE ON F. B. TEN
SIXTY SIX I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I THINK
FEDERAL DOLLARS. FORMER BUT
FAMILIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHEN MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN
ROOM TWO HUNDRED RIGHT THERE
WITNESSES APARTMENT TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SEEN OUR PROTEIN
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. TEN
SIXTY SIX NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. FINALLY IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF EXPEDIENCE AND
SIXTY SIX IT IS ONE NINE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. ONE NINE ZERO NOW
FOR SUPPORT. IN WE DO HAVE ONE
OR TWO QUEUING UP HERE TO BE
JUMPED FROM MOMENT ALL RIGHT
THANK.
AND ONCE AGAIN IT IS IN SUPPORT
OF AT LEAST ONE ZERO SIX SIX IT
IS ONE NINE ZERO ON THE PHONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF. ONE
FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CODY BOILED IN
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL IN CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THEN WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE QUEUED UP
FOR SUPPORT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE INTO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN SIXTY SIX THERE'S NO FORMAL
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. DANONE APPROACHING
MICROPHONE MODERATOR IS OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO IS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
SIXTY SIX NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. YOUR IN
OPPOSITION EITHER YOU TEN FIFTY
SIX THAT'S ONE ZERO. OPPOSITION
S. HE. ONE ZERO SIX ONE NINE
ZERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
KILLING UP OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE ANYONE WISH TO MAKE A
MOTION. HI GRAYSON MOVE BY SARAH
CORTESE- AND SO WITH THE NO
OTHER COMMENTS A THIRD TITLE
WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES. THANK A
TEACHER ART I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I AND I
AM HAPPY- SEE AND HEAR THAT- WE
ALSO- ARE UNITING AROUND THE
SUPPORT FOR FARMWORKERS AND
HAVING. OUR BUT- FARMERS BE IN
SUPPORT OF THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES TO
MAKE POSITIVE CHANGE FOR ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATORS RICARDO-
CONSULTANTS- CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTIONS DO PASSED
THE FIRST REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS AGAIN SECONDED BY
TERRY CORTESE A CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OUR DATA.
FOR DATA II JONES. COURTESY FOR
THE I. FROM OTHER HI I CAN'T HI
. THE ROAD IS FOUR ZERO PUT THE
BILL ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CHAIR THE GAVEL
BACK TO SIR THOMAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE DOCTOR PAN- UP
NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES. AND YOU FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ALREADY.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH WILL WORK TO
ALLEVIATE THE HOMELESS CRISIS BY
PLANNING FUNDING AND
ACCELERATING SALTER FIRST.
PROJECTS FROM FRESNO TO SAN
DIEGO THERE'S NOT A COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS GONE
UNTOUCHED BY THE HOMELESS CRISIS
SWEEPING THE STATE SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS ON
HOMELESSNESS ALLEVIATION
INITIATIVES THROUGH FIFTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS ACROSS
FIFTEEN STATE ENTITIES. WHAT WE
HAVE BROUGHT OVERWHELMING
FINANCIAL FIRE POWER TO THE
PROBLEM DO NOT. EXCEED SOURCE IN
FIRST INTENSE OR OUTSIDE. SIMPLY
PUT THIS IS JUST NOT RIGHT THE
CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS HAS
REACHED SUCH A MAGNITUDE AND THE
SOLUTIONS WE HAVE TRIED HAVE
FAILED AT SUCH A SCALE WE NEED
AND ALL OF THE ABOVE APPROACH TO
OFFER FRESH ALTERNATIVES. AS YOU
MAY KNOW IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED THE HOUSING
FIRST ONLY MODEL FOR ALL
PROJECTS WITH STATE FUNDING
WHILE I BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
CASES WHERE HOUSING FIRST IS
NECESSARY AND VERY BENEFICIAL.
PRIORITIZING PERMANENT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION THAT WON'T BE
USABLE UNTIL THE NEXT DECADE AT
THE EXPENSE OF CREATING
OPERATING AN EXISTING SHELTERS
AND NONPROFITS WITH WRAPAROUND
SERVICES THAT CAMPUS RIPPING
INTO ACTION TODAY. IS NOT HUMANE
CALIFORNIA'S FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE ARE DIVERSE AND
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS POPULATION
IS EQUALLY DIVERSE WE MUST
PROVIDE THE PALETTE OF OPTIONS
REPRESENTS THE SAME. SOLUTIONS
ON EVERY PERSON PROGRAMS AND
SHELTERS THAT REQUIRE
PARTICIPATION IN PROGRAMMING AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES SHOULD NOT
BE EXCLUDED FROM THIS NEW ALL OF
THE ABOVE APPROACH THAT IS NOT
TO SAY THAT ALL OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTIONS HAVE
FAILED. BACK IN TWENTY NINETEEN
CARL MORE. WITH BIPARTISAN-
EXEMPTED MOTEL TELLS IN HOSTELS
FROM SEACOR IF THE PROJECT
CREATED SUPPORTIVE OR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING SB FOUR
FIFTY HELP TO ACCELERATE SHELTER
CONSTRUCTION CUT RED TAPE AND
GOT CALIFORNIA'S OFF THE STREETS
UNFORTUNATELY THAT EXEMPTION
RUNS OUT AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL WOULD
REMOVE BARRIERS TO SHELTER FIRST
PROJECTS AND ALLOW THEM TO APPLY
FOR STATE FUNDING AND ALSO
EXTEND THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR
SUPPORTIVE AND TRANSITIONAL HOW
. MESC BLEMISHES WITH TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO HAVE MICHELLE STEVE
AS A WITNESS FOR OVER TWELVE
YEARS HE RAN ST JOHN'S PROGRAM
FOR REAL CHANGE IN SACRAMENTO
AND TRANSFORMED AN ORDINARY
THIRTY DAY EMERGENCY SHELTER
INTO A ROBUST COMPREHENSIVE
EIGHTEEN MONTH THEM HELPING
HOMELESS WOMEN AND CHILDREN HE
HAS ALSO DONE RESEARCH INTO THE
EFFECTIVENESS. FIRST SHE WILL BE
ABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE BEEN SPEAK TO WHY A
BROADER APPROACH TO PROVIDE
GREATER ACCESS TO SERVICES IF
NEEDED AND HUMANE. DO WE HAVE
THE EXPERT WITNESS. YES I. LERI
TOWARDS FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WITH
. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES FOR
INVITING ME TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF RESCUE TWELVE
EIGHTY FOUR. AND THE MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS TODAY. LET THAT
TAKE A MOMENT REFER BACK TO
FIRST GRADE WHEN OUR TEACHERS
ASKED US WHAT WE WANTED TO BE
WHEN THEY GROW UP. I'M FAIRLY
CONFIDENT NONE OF THE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND RAISE THEIR
HANDS TO SAY THEY WANTED TO BE
HOMELESS. HOWEVER THIS IS THEIR
REALITY A REALITY THAT LED TO
THE NEED FOR SB TWELVE EIGHTY
FOUR. HOUSING IS A CRUCIAL PIECE
TO SOLVING HOMELESSNESS. YEAH
YOU'LL SEE FROM THE CHART IN
FRONT OF YOU CREEK COVE ED HIGH
DATA INDICATES THAT DESPITE A
33% INCREASE. IN THE NUMBER OF
HOUSING UNITS. THIS IS THE
HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA. ALMOST
DID NOT DECLINE. IN FACT WITH
THE FURY. SIXTEEN LANE CAL WOULD
THAT AS IT CALIFORNIA HAS WHEN
TELLING ME I GOT HOUSING FOR A
ONE FITS APPROACH THE- TO THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AGAIN
CREEK HELD. CALIFORNIANS AND
SHELTERED. ROSE BY FORTY SEVEN
POINT 1% DESPITE A 101% INCREASE
IN SPENDING OVER THAT PERIOD AND
RELATIVELY FAST ECONOMY. IF
ENDING HOMELESS LEN MATT OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVE
POPULAR WOULD HAVE DECREASED
GIVEN THE 333% INCREASE IN
PERMANENT HOUSING UNITS. AND
THANK CREEK LET I'M SHELTERBOX
AS I SAID BY FORTY POINT ONE
PERCENT. AND BY THIRTY THREE
POINT 8% IN THE OVERALL
POPULATION AGAIN THIS IS HOT A
HIGHER WHICH IS THE ANNUAL
RECORD THAT'S THAT REPORT DATA.
RIGHT TO THE- IN BUILDING AND
RUNNING ST JOHN'S ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST PROGRAMS
FOR WOMEN INTERRUPTED RIGHT
STRUGGLING WITH HOMELESSNESS. A
PROGRAM THAT LED THOUSANDS OF
SINGLE MOTHERS TO EMPLOYMENT
ITSELF THE SCALABILITY AND FOR
MANY TO HOMEOWNERS YEAH. THAT
HOUSING IS BUT ONE PIECE ONE
CRITICAL PIECE BUT ONE PIECE OF
A COMPLEX PUZZLE TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. OTHER CRUCIAL
PIECES INCLUDE NUMBER ONE
SERVICES THEY DRIVE MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL ILLNESS. NUMBER TWO
SERVICES TO ADDRESS SUBSTANCE DISORDER. AND NUMBER THREE
SERVICES TO ADDRESS TRAUMA
ESPECIALLY THOSE HAVING INJURED
THE PILOT. 78% OF TE MOTHERS WE
SERVED AT ST JOHN STRUGGLED WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. 70% WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS 70% WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. IN NINETEEN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE UCLA
POLICY LAB FOUND THAT AREN'T
SHELTERED HOMELESS POPULATION
FACES SIMILAR UNDERLYING ISSUES.
78% STRUGGLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND 75% WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. HOWEVER PROGRAMS LIKE
THINK JOHN PROGRAMS THAT COMBINE
HOUSING WHICH REQUIREMENTS THAT
ADDRESS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT PROPEL AN INDIVIDUAL AND A
HOMELESSNESS. THESE PROGRAMS
WERE RENDERED INELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING BECAUSE UNDER HOUSING
FIRST. OUR CONSIDER AREA. LET'S
TAKE A MOMENT TO IMAGINE RAISING
CHILDREN WITHOUT AREA. LET'S
TAKE A MOMENT TO IMAGINE THE
KINGS GAME WHERE TWO TEAMS
PLAYED ONE ANOTHER WITHOUT
BARRIERS. LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO
IMAGINE BEING OPERATED ON BY A
DOCTOR WHO GRADUATED FROM AND NO
BARRIERS MEDICAL SCHOOL. EACH
SCENARIO PRESENTS A NIGHTMARE.
SB TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR IS CRUCIAL
TO EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF TOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA TOOLBOX BEYOND THE
HOUSING FIRST TOOL TO REVERSE
MANAGE CARRYING CRACK. UNDER A
ONE TOOL SYSTEM THE ARRAY OF
OPTIONS ONCE AVAILABLE TO THOSE
STRUGGLING WITH HOMELESSNESS
HAVE BEEN ALL BUT ELIMINATED.
AND THE INNOVATION AND THE
HOMELESS SYSTEMS HAS BEEN
DECIMATED. HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
WHAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN DO TO
HELP THE HOMELESS ACHIEVE THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL I ASK YOU TO
REFLECT ON THAT FIRST GRADER
THAT HUMAN BEINGS THAT NEVER
INVENTION NEVER ENVISIONED THAT
FOR HIS OR HER LIFE. SB TWELVE
EIGHTY FOUR IT'S CRUCIAL TO
EXPANDING THE TREATMENT OPTIONS
FOR HIM OR HER AS WELL AS THE
REINSTATEMENT OF DESPERATELY
NEEDED SYSTEM INNOVATION AND
OPTIONS. THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU- NOW I WILL GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS A
MEASURE IN THIS IN THIS ROOM.
SEEN NONE. OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. MODERATOR. THE
MODERATOR CAN WE OPEN UP THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR.
WE WILL TAKE A FIVE TWO MINUTE
RECESS.
ALL RIGHT THANK EVERYBODY WE'RE
BACK FROM OUR BRIEF RECESS AND
WE WANT TO GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE
WITH OUR AGENDA ITEM NUMBER NINE
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR MASON
EIGHT. AND I. WERE LOOK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE- HEARING
ROOM A TWENTY ONE HUNDRED.
NINETY NINE OKAY UP OR MOVING ON
TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE. IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. MODERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE IN SUPPORT. PLEASE HOLD
EVERYBODY.
HEARING ROOM YES HELLO THE
SECOND TWO MAIN KERR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH A WE ARE IN A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES AGENDA ITEM FINE
AND WE ARE RIGHT TO HAVE THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC LINE AND SO.
THIS MIGHT. THE SMALL. MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP BE A
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. PLEASE
HOLD EVERYONE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE STILL
ON THE LINE- I JUST GOT A TAX
THAT THERE IS STILL A TECHNICAL
ISSUE AND THEY'RE STILL TRYING
TO. NOT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AUTHOR WITH. THREE HOURS OF
WAITING I HOPE WE DON'T LOSE THE
-
I GUESS I JUST GOT ANOTHER
MESSAGE THAT THEY CAN HEAR US
NOW. WE NEED A LITTLE TELEPHONE
MUSIC RIGHT. THE BILL. A GREAT
DAD JOKE ALL LINED UP. RIGHT ON
THE LINE- GOT IT WRONG IT'S- BUT.
WHAT WILL BE THE CHIEF.
YEAH OKAY. RIGHT NOW THEN I
THINK THE BANKING CARE ACT ABOUT
. ALSO. FOR THOSE ARE ON THE
CALL WE'VE JUST NOW WE CAN HEAR
EVERYONE.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL. JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE THE ONE
WHO.
YEAH.
YEAH. OKAY. WELL IT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO CATCH. SOMETHING OKAY
NOBODY WANTS QUESTION ARE
PRINCIPLE FORM AS WE CAN HER.
JOSH GREETING THE OPERATOR CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU OKAY PERFECT NOW PLEASE
WHICH THE MAIN CONFERENCE. THANK
YOU. HEARING BACK ON TO THE
CONFERENCE AND IT'S LIVE IN ALL
RIGHT THE CHAIRS BACK TO HEALTH. ALL RIGHT SOUNDS LIKE READY
MODERATE ARE YOU THERE. YES I AM
OKAY ALL RIGHT WE WERE IN WE
WERE ON PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY FOUR AND IF YOU CAN
PLEASE OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE HAVE A
COMMON FROM LINE THREE OH FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO HAVE SOMEONE
ON THE CALL. YES I AM THRILLED
HIGHLIGHTED OPEN. ALL THE.
WELCOME TO THE NEXT CALL. BUT WE
ARE COMING FROM MY NUMBER IS
THREE ZERO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE ZERO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN.
I'M NOT SURE WHY THREE ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
SPEAK. IF YOUR THEORY NOT
SPEAKING. MADAM CHAIR OF THE
PRINCIPAL WITNESS IN SUPPORT HAS
A CONFLICT AND IT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO LEAVE MOMENTARILY ONE
WONDER DO YOU EVER HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS THEY MIGHT DIRECTOR
FOR ART. ALSO THAT CHILD SHE
DOESN'T MISTER FLIGHT. WE WILL
WE WILL- I CAN. WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE THAT I THINK. IF WE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FOR THE
PRINCIPAL WITNESS. OKAY NOW OKAY
. THANK YOU FOR COMING IN WE
HOPE YOU MISTER FLIGHT. OKAY SO
BACK TO BE A TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE. YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND THAT WOULD
BE IN SUPPORT SIR. YES FOR THOSE
IN DEFAULT PRESS ONE ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. MODERATED
WE HAVE A TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING ON THAT LINE. I HAVE
QUEUED UP INTO COURT OKAY SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND- MOVEON AND
Q. ARE THOSE THAT ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY HERE IN PERSON IN
OPPOSITION THIS BILL PLEASE.
PLEASE COME UP. I'M I GET
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARK HISTOLOGY AND I'M A
SENIOR LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ON
COMPLICIT AT HOUSE CALIFORNIA IS
IN CALIFORNIA IS A STATEWIDE
ADVOCACY NONPROFIT THAT FOCUSED
ENDING HOME. AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
FLORIDIANS I'M IN SPEAKING WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE WE AGREED
THAT OUR STATE IS NOW ACT QUICK
OR AN OFF TO HOMEOF THIS.
ATTEMPTS TO FIND COMMITTEE TO.
ALL THE FRAMEWORK. THOMAS THIS
RESPONSE THE PROMISE OF HOUSING
IS THAT HOUSING SHOULDN'T TO BE-
EARNED INSTEAD HOUSING IS A
NECESSARY FOUND FROM PEOPLE MORE
TO MEET. CAN I MAKE AN GOALS
HOUSING FOR IS NOT ONE SIZE FITS
ALL. PRESIDENT X. ROUTE.
SEASHELL IT'S ALSO NOT HOUSING
ONLY THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL
INCLUDES TAILORED SUPPORT
SERVICES INCLUDING AND SOME
SUBSTANCE. HAVE IT OVER WITH
PLEASE REPORT DID NOT OF THE
FIRST APPROACH NUMEROUS STUDIES
THAT PRO FOLLOWING HOUSING FOR
RESULT IN BETTER HOUSE PLACE AND
RICH IT'S- WELL IT IS. MEANT TO
OUT BOMBS. FIRST PROGRAMS ARE
APPROVED. TRONIC PERHAPS TENTH
ST ELMO OR SUBSTANCE USE ISSUES
BUT CHAO WE FACE IS NOT THE
HOUSING FIRST AS A WORK IS THAT
HOW HOW NOT FOR AS THE APPROACH
OR FIVE HER VENGEANCE FOLLOWING
THIS MODEL WILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
I'M SURE IN REPORT ON WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING RATIONAL NON. SO SINCE
AND LEAVE IT WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND THE OF PROVISIONS TO UNDO
THE HOUSING FIRST PROVISIONS OF
SENATOR MITCHELL. EIGHTEEN A-
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND MOST STATES RUN
BY BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS HAVE FULLY EMBRACED
THE WHOLE PERSON AT ALL AS THE
OWNER EVIDENCE BASED.
HOMELESSNESS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOUSING FIRST AS THAT
OF PROGRAM MODEL UNDER THE
GEORGE W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION
THE FED'S ABLE TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS NATIONALLY BY TEN
PERCENT. RATES HOMELESSNESS HAVE
BEEN STEADILY INCREASING BEFORE
THEM SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
. AFTER MODEL OF TWO FOUR SAN
DECREASE AND HOMELESSNESS AMONG
VETERANS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE ARE
MANY MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT
HOUSING FIRST AND THE BIGGEST
ONE IS THAT DOES NOT WORK.
TWENTY IT IS PROVEN IN HOUSING
FOR IS THE ONLY EVIDENCE BASED
MODEL AND IT IS STRONGLY LINKED
TO DECREASE AND SUBSTANCE. AS P.
GET UR OR GET MEANINGFUL
TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE USE AND
SELL THEIR HOUSE. IT IS ONLY
WHEN THEIR HOUSE THAT THEY CAN
DO IT BEGIN TO MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS MEANINGFUL ADDRESS THEIR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
THE STATE HAS NEVER FOR MODEL
ACROSS IT AT THE END THE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES IS NOT
TO ABANDON THE MODEL THAT HAS
RESULTED IN TWO STATES AND
DOZENS OF THE- ENDING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS. FOR THESE REASONS
I URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL
UNLESS THE BILL IS AMENDED TO
STRIP THE HOUSING FIRST OPERA
FROM BILL. THANK YOU ARE SO MUCH
AND- NOW WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMON OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
ANY ADDITIONAL- IN THIS IN THIS
ROOM OKAY ARE CAN WE MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LEVINE
. IF YOU HAVE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE HAVE NOBODY
THAT HAVE QUEUED UP FOR
OPPOSITION. OKAY WHAT ARE HAVE
BEEN I HEARD FROM OP ALL
OPPOSITION AND ALL THOSE THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT I'LL OPEN IT UP
TO- COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND- MISPRICED. PLEASE
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MA'AM
SHIRTS CENTER BATES I- MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL AND
LISTENING TO THE OPPOSITE AND I
THINK THERE'S A FALSE. BINARY
CHOICE BEING. BY THE OPPOSITION
AND IT'S ONE OR THE OTHER WHEN
IT COMES TO HOUSING FIRST- BY
YOUR BILL BECAUSE IT IS FAR AS I
KNOW IT IS SILENT REGARDING%
HOUSING FIRST CERTAINLY DOESN'T
- STOP THE HOUSING FIRST WITH WE
CAN DO THIS PLUS HOUSING FIRST
IS THAT CORRECT. THE END OF B.
R. FOR SOME FUNDING ARE THAT
DON'T USE THE HOUSING FIRST
MODEL I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD
BE EXCLUDED FROM THE OP. AND THE
STATE HAVE UNDERTAKEN TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS WITH THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES AND HAVING SERVED ON
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS THAT THE REFEREE
SERVICES PART OF THE PROBE THAT
WE HAD FOR REUNIFICATION OF
FAMILIES THE A. WELL COULD BE.
GRAHAM THAT TRIP WITHOUT FOR
ENTRY IN PROGRAMS IN YOUR FROM
MISS. HOW SHE RAN THE ST JOHN'S
PROGRAM HERE SACRAMENTO AND I
WAS INCREDIBLY IMPRESSED WHEN
ARE WE HAD A HEARING ON THAT AND
THREE YOUNG WOMEN THAT CAME
FORWARD. AND SPOKE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY HAD GOALS TO MEET
WITHIN THAT PROGRAM I TO STAY
SOBER AND THAT THE WAY THEY GOT
. BRENT OUT THOSE. THEIR LIFE
SKILLS EDUCATE. SEARCH AND SO
THOSE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS OF HELPING PEOPLE ARE
OUT OF ADDICTION AND CERTAINLY I
INTO A PRODUCTIVE LIFE AND SOUL
WHY WE'RE ELIMINATING THAT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY. WE'RE COMING IN
WITH. THEIR BE A COMPETITION IT
SHOULD ALL IS BE REALLY A
CONTINUE ON A CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES THAT ARE THERE WERE-
ANY AND ALL WHO CHOOSE THE
VOLUNTARY APPROACH WHERE DOES
NOT HAVE MORE RESTRICTIONS ON
AND GO. AFTER LIKE IN IT YEAH TO
DIE PRO SOMETHING WE HAVE TO BE
IT EVERY CANNOT THINK THAT SENT
HIM TO DO.
THE ASTLEY THEY WERE GIVEN A
COUPLE CHANCES BUT KEEPING YOUR
FAMILY TOGETHER- KEEP YOUR
CHILDREN AND CERTAINLY CURBING
YOUR ADDICTION AND THINGS THE
LIFE SKILLS THAT YOU ARE. OUT OF
THAT WERE HADN'T. CRITICALLY AND
TO MAKING IT A BIGGER DANTE AND
ARE HOMELESS ISSUE ESPECIALLY
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS ADDICTION
PROBLEMS AND ALL ABOUT THAT'S
WHY I AM VERY HIGH ON THIS BILL.
AND I THINK IT'S PERTINENT THAT
. NOT AT ALL I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
COMMENTS IS IN A COMPETITION.
THAT THESE PROGRAMS DON'T HAVE
TO LIVE AND I EAT I THINK IT'S A
VERY POINT IN AND AROUND. YOU'RE
NOT YOU'RE NOT BUT YOU KNOW
WE'RE AT A POINT CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW AND YOU KNOW
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND- HERE
EVEN IT MIGHT- RAW A- EACH ISSUE
WITH HOMELESSNESS- EVERYWHERE
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW IF THE
NUMBER IS ACCURATE THAT THERE'S
A HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT. PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA AT. WILLIAM DOLLARS
IMPACT THAT THERE'S PLENTY OF
PEOPLE TO HELP AND THERE'S
PLENTY OF MONEY TO SPEND LET'S
HAVE AS MANY TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX AS WE CAN HAVE WE CAN'T
ONE SIDE IT'S ALL AND- ALLOW.
FOR THE CREATIVITY IN AS YOU
MENTIONED THE COUNTIES ARE KIND
OF THE ON THE STREET LEVEL
DEALING WITH THIS WE MESSAGE CAN
IN MY IN MY CORRECT OUT. IT AT
BETWEEN AT TWO INCORPORATED
CITIES THERE IS ABOUT A MILE
STRETCH OF ROAD IT'S
UNINCORPORATED. WELL BOTH THE
INCORPORATED CITIES HAVE. FOR
LACK OF A BETTER TERM PUSH TO
THE HOMELESS POPULATION ONTO
THIS- UNINCORPORATED. OR PORTION
OF THE ROAD AND NOW THEY THE
COUNTIES TRYING TO END THE TWO
CITIES ARE YOU'RE ALL TRYING TO
ARM WRESTLE ON WHOSE PROMISES
YOU KNOW IT'S IS PROP IS NOT TO
INCORPORATE THESE AND- THE
COUNTY OR THE COUNTIES IT'S
EVERYBODY'S PROBLEM. AND I THINK
IT JUST GOES BACK TO. THIS
COMMITTEE ALL OF US JUST LEADERS
NEED TO. ALLOW AS MUCH
CREATIVITY AS CAN BE BROUGHT TO
US TO IMPACT- THIS POPULATION
AND HAVE A POSITIVE REASON. FOR
A FRUSTRATING. THE THESE THIS
HOMELESS POPULATION THESE ARE
HUMAN BEINGS THESE ARE PEOPLE
THESE ARE SOMEBODY'S SONS AND
DAUGHTERS SOMEBODY'S BROTHER AND
SISTER. SOMEBODY MOP. AT FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO OUR ARGUE. OVER
DETAILS OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
AND NOT ALLOW THEM TO WORK I
THINK WE'RE DROPPING THE BALL
AND WE'RE COUPLE WILL NOW IN IN
OUR MIND THAT TO HAPPEN AND- WE
NEED TO ALLOW AS MUCH RESOURCE
TAKE. THERE FOR. THANK ON MY
HEALTHY TRACK- TO SURVIVE NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT WHATEVER
AND I THINK THIS MOVES IN THAT
DIRECTION SO THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY. I'M I'M ACTUALLY KIND
OF LOOKING FOR CLARITY ON THIS
ON THE BILL STILL- MORE THAN
ANYTHING I WANT TO. TWO ONE SIX
WHERE I'M AT ON ON THE SUIT THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING AND IN CENTER
JONES JUST DISCUSSING UP. THIS
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND FOR A
MOMENT. I ALSO COME FROM THE
BACKGROUND WORKING ON A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE BIG CITY CITY
COUNCIL BEFORE AND I FEEL LIKE
I'VE SCHEME. HELLO OR- I'M- OR
THOR THINGS SORT OF SORT OF
BECOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
ALONG THE WAY- I SPREE SUPPORT
HOUSING FIRST AS A PER PART OF
HOUSING STRATEGY. I'M MY
EXPERIENCE IN OUR COUNTY IS WE-
THE PASS IN AND I CULTURE THE
CAMPAIGN A NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR BOND JUST COME UP
WITH ENOUGH MONEY. SINCE THAT
DEFINITION OF HEALTH. ORDER
HOUSING FOR EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
APPLICANTS TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT
FORTY HUNDRED UNITS. THE TICKET
IN WELL. TO THIS DAY IN IN A THE
CAREER I JUST SPOKE OF GOES BACK
TWENTY YEARS- WE- BUCKET OF MY-
HIS. OF IT THIS PROBLEM IS WHEN
I FIRST WITH BILL I THOUGHT WHAT
IT WAS TRYING TO DO IS SAY DON'T
APPLY FOR PRINT OKAY. WHEN YOU
DO THAT YOUR FIRST WITH STAR.
THE ABILITY OF GETTING SHELTER
BEDS CREATED- BUT IN A POINT
INCREASE IN THE THROUGH MY STUFF
AND- WHATEVER EXIT YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN REPRESENTED TO ME IT'S
BEEN REPRESENTATIVES HOUSING
FIRST JUST NEEDS TO BE
ELIMINATED FROM. CALIFORNIA
POLICY IS A STANDARD- IN AND I
THINK IT'S- CLOSER JUST. THAT IF
. THAT'S A MISTAKE BECAUSE- IT
IS BECOME. BEGIN THE STRATEGY
FOR TRYING TO EXCEL REPURPOSE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WHETHER IT'S
- ROGER COHEN CURE LOCAL EFFORTS
LIKE IN MY COUNTY OR IN THE BAY
AREA SERVICES CANNELLA METERS OR
EFFORTS. TO THIS ONE SURE
ABSOLUTELY IF YOU HAD. TEN OR
TWELVE THOUSAND UNITS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY TODAY- THAT WE'RE
STUDIO APARTMENTS THAT HAD
WRAPAROUND SERVICES. THERE
PROBABLY IS A STRATEGY WE CAN
GET PEOPLE OUT OF CREEKS AND
RIPARIAN CORRIDORS AND UNDER OUT
FROM UNDER OVERCAST DIRECTLY
THIS YEAR TO. BUT WITHOUT FOR
THE FORTY TWO HUNDRED. WE'VE
TWENTY SIXTEEN TENURE RICIN FOR
GOOD REASON YOU DON'T BUILD
STUDIO APARTMENTS. R. O. EVEN IF
YOU HAVE THE MONEY TO IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN THAT WAY IT'S SO. IN THE
INTERIM. OUR SHELTER PROGRAM SIX
AND RIPARIAN CORRIDORS AND IF
YOU WANT TO SEE THAT ALL YOU DO
IS FLY INTO SAN JOSE
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. HELLO
NINE THE MILLION BAHT PLUS THE
CITY ITSELF HASN'T. REALLY YOUR
VEHICLE AIRPORT YOU'LL SEE.
YOU'LL SEE OUR SHELTER PROGRAM
IS CALLED THE GUADALUPE. TENCENT
TENCENT TENCENT TENCENT TENTS IN
IN SO. I THINK. THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE HERE IN MY EXPERIENCE
TO WORK. THE POLICY TO WHAT'S
HAPPENED ON THE EAST COAST FOR
EXAMPLE IN IN HAVING TROUBLE TO
NEW YORK CITY. THE PERSONALLY
VIEW WHAT THEY'RE DOING THERE
AND SOME OF THIS IS DEFINITIONAL
IT'S DEFINITIONAL TELL YOU
DEFINE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
SHELTER IN NEW YORK CITY IS.
STUDIO APARTMENTS OR DORM LIKE
FACILITIES THAT'LL HAVE
SOMETIMES TWO OR THREE
INDIVIDUALS IN IN THEM FOR
NINETY DAYS OR HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS UNTIL THE TRANSITION TO
PERMIT SUPPORTERS SEEN. THOSE IN
NEW YORK FOR YEARS THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
THEY'RE IN SHELTER. IN SO. I
RESIDENTIAL MINISTRATION GO THE
MARCHERS STARTED GET FOLKS OUT
OF THESE WAREHOUSE LIKE
FACILITIES THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
STAYING IN FOR LONGER THAN
NINETY- AND WE DO WE NEED
EMPHASIZE HOUSING FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR BERMAN
HOW. PORTION TWENTY BANCSHARES
INC AND WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY NO PURSUIT
THE HUD FUNDING AND EVERYTHING
ELSE FOR. S. TWELVE. IN I THINK
THAT'S A MISTAKE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE WAREHOUSE IN SHORT
SHELTER WE HAVE PEOPLE OUTSIDE-
WE HAVE A WE HAVE ARE HOMELESS
OUTSIDE. THERE THERE'S NOT A
PROBLEM OF GETTING THE OF.
SHELTERS INTO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THERE'S A
PROBLEM OF GETTING THEM OUT OF
HARM'S WAY RIGHT NOW WHILE WE'RE
BUILDING. HOUSING WE WERE WAY
BEHIND ON IN THIS- BROUGHT TO
SOME OTHER TO THIS SO I THINK WE
ARE BEHIND I DO THINK THIS CRAP
. PROBABLY SOMEWHAT ACCURATE IN
TERMS OF ONE GOES UP IN THE
OTHER ONE WENT DOWN. BUT I DON'T
GET IT THAT THE- ALSO WHAT I'M
CERTAIN ABOUT IT IT DOES IN
APPRECIATED CENTER JONES
STARRING THE QUESTION OFFICE
THIS IS THIS A BOTH AND OR IS
IT. YOU KNOW SAYS ASSEMBLY
TRYING TO AT LEAST THE WAY THE
BILL'S WRITTEN RIGHT NOW TRYING
TO GET RID OF. BOTH OF HOUSING
FIRST AS A PRINT. IT IN IF IT IS
THEN I CAN'T SUPPORTED I WOULD
STAY OFF THE BILL TODAY BUT I AM
ONE OF YOUR IF AT SOME POINT-
THE- OF THE AUTHORS READ BOOKS
TO THE- LISTING FOR TO. THE
FIRST HERE. YOUR WHICH WILL TAKE
HIS THINK USE THAT KERR SAID.
I'D LIKE TO THINK OF IT AS- FOR
PLAY. SO IT IS NOT. UNTIL THE
ROLE PEOPLE WHO JUST WANT OUT
THERE. TO HAVE. PROGRAM AND WE
NEED WE KNOW THAT HUMAN BEHAVIOR
BUT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEONE
TO SAY I WANT TO BE IN A
FACILITY THAT WILL THAT GOAL.
THAT I COULD. MY A LOT OF THE-
COURT. CHILDREN BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THE ABUSE OR NEGLECT SOMETIMES
IT'S BASICALLY NEGLECT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE SERIOUS ADDICTION
PROBLEMS THEN YOU'RE NOT TAKING
CARE OF YOUR CHILDREN BUT THEY
NEED TO HAVE SOME IT'S REALLY
APPROVED GEN MORE. THE FLOWER.
BUT A LOT STEEP ALL RIGHT NUMBER
OF YEARS HERE AND- IN SECOND SO
THEY REALLY THE MÀ HERE IF WE
NEED TO. A DIFFERENT SORT OF
LANGUAGE THERE TO IT OR OFFICE
DO- SPEAKER I. THE COMPONENTS OF
THE NOTHING WRONG WITH ANYONE OF
THESE SIX THE FIRST ONE THAT
SAYS YOU CAN'T HAVE MADDIE-
REQUIREMENTS IN A HOUSING OF THE
XIN YOU'RE PLACING A MOMENT OF
LET'S SAY GETTING A VOUCHER FOR
YOU CAN. IT GET THE AND THEN.
VISIONS SWAPPING LIKE MISS.
RIGHT BECAUSE IT WAS EXTREMELY-
IMPRESSIVE OF THE RECIDIVISM
WITH- OVER THE YEARS THERE WERE
PEOPLE LINED UP I THINK SHE HAD
THREE HAD AWAITING A POINT.
RECIDIVISM OF PEOPLE WHO GET
HOUSING FIRST AND THEN DON'T
KEEP THE HOUSE WHY DON'T BACK ON
THE STREET LOSE THEIR CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY ARE BACK IN THEIR
ADDICTION OR WHATEVER. THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT HAVE TO COME
HOME. UP LUCIEN AND I THINK
THAT'S BEEN MISSING AND I DO
BELIEVE CONGRESS IS ABOUT TO
SING FOR. WHAT IS BUS YOU'LL
HAVE. TO WONDER THE- AND NOT TO
DENY THEM A HOUSING FIRST
WITHOUT THE PROGRAMMATIC-
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THERE BUT NOT
TO DENY PEOPLE WHO ARE OFFERING
THAT GIVES SOME FUNDING TO
EXPAND THAT. TO YOU OUT OF OUR
EIGHT- AND I THINK OUR
TREATMENTS FOR ESPECIALLY THOSE
I THINK I'M THINKING FAMILIES IN
PARTICULAR SENATOR KIRSTEN IS
THE BECAUSE THOSE ARE. THE
SUFFERING LIVE IN THERE INTEL'S
CHILLED. THEN THE CHILDREN ARE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM BECAUSE
WITHOUT THE TRY TO GET HIM BACK
MEANWHILE ARE THE RISKS THIS
FROM IT FAILED BEING REUNITED
AND THAT AND FORTH. BEING UNITED
AND FOR. EDGE INDIVIDUAL. ABOUT
THE FOSTER PARENTS IN A- TRIALED
AND GUESTS WOULD HAVE CHILD
AFTER TWELVE YEARS OF THEIR
SCOTTISH AT SIX EIGHTEEN BECOME
IT ADDICT AND THE CHILDREN AHA
TWO CHILDREN OUT OF WEDLOCK.
MORE IF THE- WE ALL READ TO THAT
FULLER US NOT ALLOW THE FOR THAT
IS WHAT THE BILL IS SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING IT IS NOT TO. ENOUGH OF
HOUSING TO. OPPORTUNITY TO IN
THE- FULL I WOULD TELL YOU I
USED TO BE AN END- SUPERVISE AND
IT WAS REAL VERY TROUBLING TO
HAVE PROGRAMS THAT. DIGITAL'S
YOUNG TINA. TWO OR THREE
CHILDREN NO PLACE TO GO IN IN
THOSE DAYS SO DO HAVE A- HARD
FOR THE- I HAVE A PARA. I
THEY'RE STILL THAT WE HAVE LOOK
AT SO DO CENTONZE BE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. THE WONDERFUL SESSION
WITH SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL TIME
IN ENERGY. FIRST ONE IS THE-
THAT WAS AT THAT TIME THAT WAS
THE BUT HERE WE ARE NOW AND I
HAVEN'T HAD A TO SENATOR MITCH I
SHOULD PAY HOW DOES NOT. LET'S
SEE PUTTING THEIR WE HAVE THESE
WERE BOUNCER SAYS. COUNTY PER.
ALSO OUT FOR THE KIND OF THE-
CORE OF MY- YOU KNOW. MY UP
THREE THE POOR. MY CORPORATE
LANTERNS THAT LEFT TAKE A LOOK I
THINK THERE'S A DEFINITE AND YOU
KNOW KEEP THE SAME THING OVER
AND OVER EXPECTING DIFFERENT
RESULTS DO WE GET CAUGHT UP
BECAUSE WE GET MARRIED TO THE
ALL WAY AND- WELL. BECAUSE
THAT'S CORRECT IS ABOUT ALL
REACT TO THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND
SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL WITH HOUSING FIRST
ONLY IN SUMMER GOING TO VERY
SUCCESSFUL IF WE HAVE HOUSING.
AND ENOUGH THAT. TO ENSURE THAT
THE WHAT IT IS- RELATING AND I'M
DOUBTS THE OF. THE BEST TIME
ALLEN HAPPY TO NOT TAKE A VOTE
TODAY TAKE IT BACK AND YOU KNOW
WORKS SOME AND TALK TO YOU-
CENTRIC COURTESY BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'VE BEEN THERE AND YOU KIND
OF DESCRIBE FROM ABOUT THE GAP
THAT MAY BE THE- FIFTH. EIGHT
THROUGH THE CHURCH LET ME JUST
SAY THAT IS PROBABLY NOT FOR ME
TO DO- AND- IT WOULD HAVE TO.
YOU KNOW REFER. YOU KNOW A
CINNAMON WELL ON MY PART BACK TO
THE JUROR IN TERMS OF. OF THIS I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE VOTES ON THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I AM AT LEAST
FOR MY PART I WOULD SAY THIS. IT
AGAIN I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE TO
CRITICIZE HOUSING FIRST BILL
YEARS WHATEVER THEY MAY BE IF
BECAUSE HAD TREMENDOUS SUCCESSES
IN HIM YOU KNOW I'VE AS I SAID
IN MY OPINION IS IT'S WORTH
INVESTING IN IT'S IN MY COUNTY
IT'S NOT BURKE. WITH FISH ISSUE
OF DURING. TODAY IS HERE TWO TWO
TAKE A BOTH AND I THINK THAT
THAT WITH REGARD TO JONES IS
COMMENTS WELL WOULD SAY AS A
COURTESY TO- FOR MY PART AS TO
WHAT I'M CENTER HERE TO DO TO
ALLOW THE UPPER. TO AMENDED MADE
CLEAR GOING FORWARD- YOU KNOW I
WOULD I WOULD I WOULD CAST AN
AYE VOTE TODAY BUT IT'S ENOUGH
NOT TO SEVEN TO A MEAN SPIRITED
ALL ABOUT THIS BUT IT THE TO
KNOW. WHERE IT IS IN THE- WHAT'S
GOING. FOR YOU. NEED TO HOUSING
FOR. THE NIGHT AT A- NOBLE- BUT
AN ANALYSIS THAT COMES INSTANCE
THIS MAY HOUSING ALONE IN A-
DIRECTS THE STATE AUGMENT HIS
EFFORTS ARE ON A SHORT TERM
SHALL IN THE MEAN- I'M ALL THAT
SO. OF LEAVE IT AT THAT AND TURN
IT BACK OVER THE- OR VERY QUICK
RESPONSE I DON'T THINK WE THIS A
CAR AND IF OF HOW FOR. TWO HOME
. WHICH AND I THINK WHEN YOU
LOOK AT A CHART. ARE YOU COULD
TAKE THAT AS WITH WHAT WOULD IT
SAYING IT'S NOT YOU KNOW WE ALL
KNOW THAT SO VERY VERY COMPLEX
PROBLEM. BECAUSE ALL DIVERT BE
THAT'S- OUTSIDE THEIR WITH OUR-
POPULATION. STATES SO TO. PUT
YOU KNOW YOUR CONCERN ON THAT TO
REST. THANK YOU AND- THE SURVEY
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND- AS AS A SOCIAL
WORKER HAVING BEEN ON THE FRONT
LINES. I DID HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- FOR- COOLEY. HOUSING
UP YEAH ACTUALLY. SO YOU HEARD
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION GOING ON-
AND I KNOW YOU PRESENTED AND-
GARCIA WAS POLISHED. BY THE AND
TELL YEAH HOUSING FIRST- AND-
THERE ALWAYS SEEMS TO BE SOME
IMPLICATION THAT UNDER HOUSING
FIRST YOU CAN ACTUALLY BEAT
STRUCTURE AND- THEN AND SELF.
FOR PEOPLE OR THEIR CELL.
PERHAPS MAYBE ADDRESS SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
ABOUT- WELL FIRST OF ALL TO YOU
AND A USER TOUCHED ON THIS BUT-
TO WHAT THE- BASED. HOUSING STE
AND- ALSO- TO BE CLEAR ABOUT.
WHAT WHAT IS AND ISN'T HOUSING
FIRST SO BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S
A SENSE THAT WHILE HOUSING FIRST
MEANS WE CAN SIMPLY GIVE SOMEONE
AND CAN'T PUT. YES FINAL- IT L.
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- THAT ALSO WHEN I. WAS A
PROGRAM SUCCESS OR NOT I YEAH I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT SAY WELL
WHAT'S THE BEGINNING POPULATION.
CAPTAIN ANYMORE IT'S LIKE WELL
ACTUALLY NO YOU GUYS DON'T SEEM
POPULATION SO WE HAVE SOME
PEOPLE STUCK IN THE STREET
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T KEEP IT
WHATEVER DAYS OUT THAT DOESN'T
THAT'S A SUCCESS RATE. WHAT
YOU'RE A SIX. YOU CAN UPLOAD THE
EVIDENCE AND ALSO THE OUTCOMES
OF HOUSING FIRST VERSES THE OP
YOU KNOWWHAT WE USED TO DO I
GUESS- AND THEN- MAYBE TO TALK
ABOUT YEAH WELL. AT THE TOP. ME
IS THAT RIGHT. WE HAVE PROGRAM
THAT SAY LOOKING PROVIDES ITSELF
THIS THAT ACTUALLY SOME WE CAN'T
IN HOUSING FIRST THE CASE SOME
OF THOSE THINGS. I WILL DO MY
BEST- I THINK. YOU KNOW THE WAY
THAT WE THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
DRIVING OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN THE STATE IS REALLY AND WHAT
THE EVIDENCE SHOWS WAS AROUND
HAPPEN. SO I BECAME. I'M NOT
THEMED. PERIOD OF THE CHART SHOW
LISTENERS GO UP LIKE WHAT'S HALF
WITH AVERAGE RENTAL COSTS DURING
THAT TIME AND WHAT HAPPENED.
WAIT IN INCOME DURING THAT TIME
IS NOT INCREASING AT THE SAME
RATE AS THE INCREASE IN HOUSING.
THE ONLY THING ABOUT THE- IN
HOMELESSNESS. AND HOUSING HEALTH
THAT'S REALLY SORT OF NORTH. IS
THAT EVIDENCE SHOWS ACROSS THE-
THAT. IN CHRIST THE BEST. A CALL
. I'M COME HOUSING. PROGRAM IN
HOUSING COSTS. HOUSING THE PRO
CHOICE- OUR STATE DE FUND AGENCY
SHELTER. THERE REQUIRE. UNDER
SORT OF IN. WITH HOUSING FOR LAW
EMERGE SHELTER HAVE FOLLOW LOW
BAY. GUY. AND I. CAN IN THE
PROGRAM. AT AS WITH WITNESS
SPOKE ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE SORT
OF WRAP AROUND GOAL SETTING SO
YOU ST- THERE CAN BE SUBSTANCE
USE TE. FOR PER. AT THAT SOMEONE
CAN'T BE KICKED OF THAT HOUSING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T PART OR IF
THEY REALLY RIGHT RELY THE PART
OF RIGHT THREE AND I WHAT IF
SOME CAN PROVE THAT. MORE LIKE
THE- IF THEY YOU KNOW REMOVED.
FOR A FAMILY TO SORT OF SEE THAT
THE FOR THEIR RECOVERY FOR THEIR
HOUSING OUTCOME DOZEN GET BETTER
BIKE OUT OF A PROGRAM IF THEY
DON'T PARTICIPATE IN SURVEY. IF
THEY ARE- INDICATE USE LAPSED.
THE NATIONAL LINE TO END
HOMELESS- RATHER THAN SPEAK TO
SPECIFIC STUDIES THOUGH I THINK
IN OUR OPPOSITION LETTER WE
REFER TO A COUPLE OF. UP BUT
INVOLVED. IS WHAT FAIL PUTS
ABOUT THE STATE THAT SOME THAT
FOR MODEL A AGAIN REALLY AT ITS
CORE IS HOW IS THE- OF. LAYING
OF. COMES OF ALL DIFFERENT
THINGS AND- THE FIRST BUT IT
DOESN'T IT'S NOT THE ONLY PEACE
AND PEOPLE WERE NEEDED TO SERVE
ON TOP THAT. GAIL ON THE SCALE
ARE STILL IS THAT IMPORTANT
FIRST MODEL. AND YOU KNOW ON THE
OTHER SIDE- STUDIES THAT DON'T
SUPPORT THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL
AND THE SCALE OF. SO IT'S ON.
HOUSING FOR SO THERE'S REALLY
EVIDENCE FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
SUBSTANCE USERS FOR SERIOUS AND
PERSISTENT MENTAL ILLNESS THE
FAMILIES THAT THE HOUSING FIRST
MODEL- HAVE BETTER OUT IT.
PASSED AROUND. AROUND TYPES.
HERBAL LIKE HOW EDUCATION MENTAL
ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS-
YOU HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS IN
THERE SO THERE'S ANY THAT I CAN
BUT I KNOW IT'S ON THAT I. YEAH
THE- SO WE HEARD ABOUT HOUSING
FIRST PLUS BUT WHAT DOES THE
PLUS IT'S A HOT HOT SO I GUESS
YOU KNOW- SO IT WAS IMPLIED THAT
IF YOU'RE A HOUSING FIRST MODEL
YOU CAN'T DO CLASS THERE'S TELL
THE FIRST. CLOSE THE ROOM. THANK
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN SERVICES- MORE
BECAUSE THEY RELAPSE YOU KNOW
IDEALLY THERE COULD BE A CHOICE
AND IF THERE TRULY WAS A CHOICE
BETWEEN A PRO RECORD SOBRE ONE
THAT DIDN'T. PERSON RELAPSE THEY
WERE IN TWO TO BE PLACED IN
ANOTHER HARM REDUCTION MODEL-
YOU KNOW THAT COULD BE MAYBE
EVAN. A SORT OF HIGH HOUSING
FIRST. BUT I THINK AS OF RIGHT
NOW- YOU KNOW OUR STATE HAS A
CONTINUUM OF OPTIONS WE HAVE
SHELTERS HAVE SANCTION. YES WE
PERMIT PORT OF HOUSING WE HAVE
RENTAL SUBSIDY WITH SOME
WRAPAROUND. WE REALLY DO HAVE A
LOT OF OPTIONS BUT THE PRACTICE
OF THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL IS
THAT WE SHOULDN'T TAKE PEOPLE
OUT. ONCE THAN IT IT SAID IN.
ALL OF SHELTER OR IN HOUSING
SHOULD BE SEEKING HELP ME.
MS THAT ESSENTIALLY DON'T ADOPT
THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY MEANS REMOVING I
FROM I UNDERSTAND THIS. THAT
REMOVE SOME IF THEY DON'T FOLLOW
SO MILLARD YOU CAN START
STRUCTURE YOU CAN SAY YOU HAVE
CONSERVE IT WOULD PICK ONE CONST
ROUTE. RIGHT BASICALLY SYING
WE'RE TAKING YOUR DROWNED STREET
IT'S- SO- WOULD IN YOUR BILL IF
SOMEONE DECIDED TO YOU KNOW WE
SAY WELL THERE'S A PROGRAM AND
YOU GO IN THERE THAT LEAVES ALL
THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY. REMOVE
SOLDIERS- REMOVE THEM FROM THAT
PROGRAM THEY WOULD HAVE TO FIND
THEM ANOTHER SHELTER CAN'T JUST
SIMPLY COME OUT ONTO THE STREET
RIGHT LIKE OH WELL YOU DO THIS
OR- RELATED. OR WHATEVER WE'RE
GONNA CHARGE YOU THAT YOU
ACTUALLY TO HAVE THE PERSON I
MEAN IDEALLY I MEAN THAT THE
DIRT SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE BASICALLY CHARGE OUT ON
TO THE- BUT- STRUCTURE WHATEVER
THAT. MIGHT ALERT IF YOU'RE
EATING A TAKE SOMEONE IN YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR BEING SURE
THAT THEY- CONTINUE TO SHELTER
INSPECTION. DO YOU END UP
REMOVING THE SHELF FROM THE-
PHILIP IS THAT SOMETHING. CHOIR
FOR HI YES DOCTOR AYE BELIEVE
THAT THE PRO THAT ARE STRUCTURE
THAT WAY DO YOU HAVE THEIR OWN
RULES A- YOU GET ANSWERS SURE
YOU KNOW EXACTLY I BELIEVE IT
NOW MISTY THANK IN THE IN TOWN.
ON THE WAY. OUT OF THE PICTURE.
YEAH YOU FELT YOUR THREE TO THE
IT'S ARE YOU IS THAT IT'S
PROGRAM THEN IF THEY SAY WELL
OKAY YOU FEELS THREE SAN WERE
GOING TO MOVE FROM OUR PER. IS
THAT PROGRAM I'LL TO FIND THEM.
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE OH OKAY WE'LL
FIND YOU A TEMPORARY BED
SOMEWHERE AND THEN NOW WE JUST
ABANDON YOU THEIR CELL NUMBERS
OR SOME OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE
TO BUT IF YOU'RE NOT TO TAKE A
SHOT AT THAT TO HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE DO THE STATE'S JOB. IT JUST
. THREE BE ON THE THESE THAT DO
BY THE WATER SO LIVING HOMES AND
RESIDENTS TREATMENT FACILITIES
THAT'S WHERE ONE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THERE WITH ADDICTION IN
. FULL CAME OUT PRESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES BECAUSE
THEY DID VIOLATE YOU KNOW
STAYING SOBER OR NOT YOU KNOW
SHOOTING UP OR NOT BRING DRUGS
INTO FACILITY THE WORKING ABOUT
NEED I THINK DONT. M. AND YET
THERE REFER TO THAT OVER AND
THERE AT THE ACTUALLY WE CAN YOU
THEY ACTUALLY SIGN IN FULL WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT VOLUNTEER IT'S A
BOB AND IS THE COMMITMENT LETTER
HELLO TERRY ENTRANCE AND
BECOMING THE PROGRAM AND I THINK
IT. I THINK THEY'RE- A BELIEVE-
BUT I GUESS THE THAT THE BIGGEST
FOR ME. IT WOULD THERE BE AN
OBLIGATION FOR THE FUNDING RIGHT
SO WHICHEVER YEAH AT YOU COULD
BELIEVE THE PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
TO ASSURE. THE FULL PROGRAM.
THAT COULD JUST THIS CHARGE SO
OUT INTO THIS YOU KNOW TODAY
WOULD HAVE TO. HAVE SOME SORT OF
SHELTER THAT FLOW GRAHAM WOULD
HAVE TO GO TO BUT YOU CAN'T
THOSE DETAILED THEIR DRUG YOU
CAN'T JUST SIMPLY OKAY WELL YOU
FAILED OUT HERE. YOU WEIRD THAT
THAT PROGRAM. ARE IN ANOTHER
PLACE FOR THAT PERSON TO LIVE
NOT THE STREET OR THE- STRAIGHT
. NOTIFICATION CONTINUES TO- IF
IT'S NOT IN THE OFFICE HAD AIR
FRANCE ELSE AND YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THEY WERE RECEIVING STATE
FUNDS THAT WOULD BE A
REQUIREMENT OF THE PROGRAM
CORRECT. I DON'T JUST. PROGRAMS
LIKE THAT I AM HOMELESS LAND
HOUSING OF FIRST PLUS AND THEN
SOMEHOW THEY DON'T AGREE TO THE
CONTRACT THAT THAT KEEP THEY
CAME IN. PUBLIC JIM WOOD BE AND
HOW. IT WILL HAPPEN IS A
VOLUNTARY. WELL AND THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE THE ONLY GRAHAM ATTY
PROGRAMMATIC REQUIREMENTS ARE
LISTED HERE IN. WHAT HOW FIRST.
BUYERS AND OF ITS COMPONENTS WE
DO OF PROGRAMS OUT THERE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY WERE HAVE SOME
REQUIREMENTS BOB BLACK WITH A
HOUSING PLUS THEY HAVE TO FLY
WITH HOUSING FOR- BUT THERE A
LOT. WAY WITH THE REST OF STATE
FUNDS AN ART. STOCK HAS SENATOR
CORTESE WAS SITTING WE'RE GONNA
LOSE THEM- IF. EATING THIS VERY.
HOUSING FIRST BECAUSE I WANT TO
SET MY OWN GOALS I WANT TO DO MY
OWN THING THAT THERE MIGHT BE.
SLIGHTLY ME I WANT IN THIS. THAT
IS NEEDED DO CERTAIN THINGS
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW I MAKE
PROGRESS WITH MY LIMB SEE AN- 4%
THE MENTAL ISSUES OR- WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THOSE ARE HOMELESS
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMY THOSE
PEOPLE BE IT HOUSING FIRST AND
BELIEVE THE START OF THAT MANY
UP. OUR SYSTEM TO LAW THEIR-
TENSION THROUGHOUT IN THE ARE
THEY DON'T SING FIRST BUT THE
EIGHT TO FIVE IN FORTY FIVE THAT
HAVE SUBS THE BUTTE IT IS HELLO
WHILE THE USE. I NEED THIS WORST
. YEAH I DON'T THINK NOT FUN
BROWN'S THAT'LL MAKE THE OFFER
TO FOR. ACTUALLY BACK ON THE
RIGHT TRACK AND ALSO NEED IN
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE A- THAT THE
EXCEED THING IN OUR HOUSE FOR.
SENSIBLE BROWN'S. BY THEM THAT
OFFER TO WE CONSTRUCT THIS BILL
SO GIVE THAT BECAUSE I WELL YOU
MIGHT. WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
ELIMINATE HOUSING BECAUSE IT IS
REAL GOOD FOR A STATEMENT ABOUT
POP. THAT BECAUSE CONNIE SING. I
MAKE WILL. THAT'S OUR PERCENT.
THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE BEER
PROBLEMS ANY TREATMENT AFTER IT
THEY NEED TREATMENT K. WE FOR
SOME THEIR ONE NOW TALKING ABOUT
THE CAL CARE COURT THAT THE
GOVERNOR HE ENTERED ALL OF THAT
WAS THIRTEEN TOGETHER THIS IS TO
BE A COUPLE THAT THIS WILL BE A
CA OF THAT. AND I. WHERE DID HE
COME. CONCERT AND EVERY SHAPE
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I AM I AM
CONCERNED THAT THAT THERE'S AND
YOU KNOW. I WOULD LIKE TO SEIZE.
FOR THE REVOLUTION- I EIGHT
THIRTY I WOULD LIKE CEDARS
OBLIGATION FOR SHELTER RIGHT SO
THAT MEANS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET THE SITUATION WHERE. SAYS
YEAH. SO IT. ONE WITH THE ISSUES. THREE THREE. I DID DAY
TREATMENT BUT ALTHOUGH IT'S TO
DELIVER WHEN THEY'RE NOTTHEY
DON'T HAVE A OKAY. I MEAN THIS
AGAIN IS THIS IS THIS. IT'S THE
RIVER AND IT'S REALLY HARD WHEN
I SOMEONE IS UNDER HOUSING OR OR
ORDER HOUSE ACTUALLY GET THEM
TREATMENT GET THE SERVICES SO
MANY. PROGRAM REQUIRED. FOR
THINGS LIKE WHAT'S YOUR ADDRESS-
THEY DON'T HAVE AN ADDRESS LIKE
SO WE SUPPOSED TO GET THE PEOPLE
OUT OF THE- ATTORNEY- YOU KNOW.
AT THAT. THIS POINT- I IT'S
GOING OFF TO THE PLAN INTERESTED
IN IS OF A- AND I THINK YOU'LL
WAS I THINK I WE ARE. ROBUST
THIS- I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
DATA. ON HOUSING FIRST AND I
REMEMBER YOU KNOW WORK WITH
HOLLY MICH. WITH CENTER ON ON
THE SO I WOULD OF- BUT IF THE IS
THE OF ALSO I HOPE.
AND HOPEFULLY IF. THAT THOSE
THINGS ARE MORE CLEAR FIGHT AND
CORPORATION TO DELIGHT YOU KNOW
BUT- HOPEFULLY THAT I. AND ON
THE FLOOR SO IF. THANK YOU SIR
PAN AM SENATOR BATES AYE AYE.
WANT TO JUST MAKE A COMMENT
BEFORE WE PROCEED I EARLIER
MESSED UP. YOU I SPOKE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT AT THE PRESIDENT
SUMMIT ON DEMOCRACY AND I'M JUST
GONNA REPEAT IT JUST A FEW LINES
AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK IT'S- KIND
OF IN THE WHAT. THE AND HIS
BECAUSE IS WE ALL KNOW THAT IT
WORKS BEST WITH CONSENSUS AND
COOPERATION WHEN PEOPLE PARTIES
THAT MIGHT HAVE OPPOSING VIEWS
SIT DOWN OF FIVE WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER BE INTO. BAPST TO ONLY
SHOOT BUT THE BEST WAY TO HIM
BUT AND HE BIG. AND SOFTECH
PROBLEMS AND THAT'S ALL UP TO US
TO PROVE THAT. SO I KNOW. I
EIGHT. I THINK THAT BUT I'M HERE
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS IT
OBVIOUSLY IF IT'S TRYING TO GET
RID OF HOUSING FIRST I WOULDN'T.
I WOULDN'T BE SUPPORTING I WON'T
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT- THAT AT
LEAST THAT'S NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO CALM. PUSH IN THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION MAKE THAT-
WE ALL WANT THE SAME THING I
THINK OF IT BUT WE HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER TO KIND OF FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S MISSING AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE DATA. SLEE IS HOW.
THERE IT. I'M GONNA TAKE YOUR
WORD FOR INSTANCE AND IT
KNOWLEDGE AND SAY THAT IT IS
WORKING ON IT BUT WHAT I'M ALSO
SAY IS THAT. THE ENTIRE STATE OF
. ALSO FEEL. THAT SOMETHING IS
NOT WORKING RIGHT BECAUSE- NOT
BECAUSE OF THE DATA. BUT BECAUSE
OF WHAT THEY'RE SEEN OUT IN
INDUSTRY. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THAT'S- LIKE THIS IS THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE RIGHT
THIS BILL WERE WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE LOOKING OUT FOR WE ARE
LOOKING OUT FOR VULNERABLE COULD
YOU COMMUNITIES AND SOMETIMES WE
HAVE TO. CONNETQUOT THAT FRAME.
AT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO HELP
ALL THE WILL DOUBLE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THE HELP. AND YOU KNOW
I KIND OF SEE IT AS WHAT WOULD
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE ONLY
HAD. YOU KNOW CALFRESH. WHAT
WOULD THAT MEAN FOR. YOU KNOW
ALL THE ALL THE OTHER PROGRAMS
AROUND FOOD TO HELP. YOUR
PROVIDE FOOD FOR TWO TO TWO
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED IT IT'S
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST DIFFERENT.
THERE'S EVERY STORY IS DIFFERENT
EVERY PERSON HAS A DIFFERENT
SHOULD BE KILLED A STORY TO TELL
DIFFERENT ISSUE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGE IN IN FRONT OF THEM.
ARE WE ALL COME FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND DIFFERENT
REASONS FOR WHY WE CHOSE TO COME
TO THE STATE SENATE I THINK WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO FIND OUT
TO WORK TOGETHER TO FIND OUT
WHAT WHAT IS MISSING. AND I
THINK THAT I. ON THIS MEASURE
WAS TO ALLOW THE CONVERSATION TO
MOVE FORWARD. TWO TWO TWO COULD
HAVE- THE GROUP YOUR GROUPS COME
TOGETHER AND WORK WITH YOUR
OFFICE AND HAVE CONVERSATIONS I
THINK WE'VE HAD AN AMAZING
CONVERSATION TODAY AROUND HERE
YOUR BILL HERE TODAY THAT- WE
PROBABLY. WOULDN'T HAVE
OTHERWISE AND SO. WE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY- AND THEN YOU
MOVE FORWARD. THE VOTE STARTED
HERE BUT- BUT IF ANYTHING
CHANGES WERE. THE HOW THE FIRST
COMPONENT IS TRYING TO YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET RID. AT ODDS ALL
WILL- AND I WILL TAKE YOU KNOW I
WILL NOT IT WILL BE ON THE ROAD.
MAKING THEM AT THE THAT IS. NOT
MY INTENT I JUST- WHEN I WAS BOB
PRESENTING THE LAST BILL IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND I HAVE THOSE
THREE YOUNG LADY SITTING THERE I
GOT A LUMP IN MY THROAT. TO
THEIR STORE SAID. HOW TO
DISPLACING JOHN. THE BIG PUT
THEIR LIVES. AND GET THEIR
CHILDREN BACK. THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT SHOULD WE REALLY
NEED TO PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY- AND IF THIS GETS US
THERE- THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT IT
HOUSING FIRST. LIKE I SAID.
PEOPLE THAT FROM. LEAGUE RIGHT
PAT. OF THAT HOUSING FIRST PLUS.
SOMETHING ABOUT SO WE SHOULDN'T
TELL. YOU KNOW NOT. YOU KNOW
HAVE ON THE ON THE MENU. THANK
YOU SO MAYBE THAT'S MY CLOTHES.
CHINA THANK YOU CENTER BASED
HELP I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL YEAH I'LL MAKE THE
MOTION AND THEN JUST TO KINDA
MAYBE GIVE A- LEVEL OF COMFORT
TO THE COMMITTEE- CENTER BATES
MYSELF AND SKINNER CALM WATER
ALSO NUMBER PROBES. WHICH I
UNDERSTAND THE BILL GOES UP
RATIONS NEXT- FROM HERE FROM
THIS COMMITTEES AFFECT. NOT
BECAUSE HOUSING WAS THE HOUSING
OKAY SO WELL IF IT GETS TO HOUSE
YOUR OF HOUSING SO I'LL HAVE TO
GO. A THERE WE GO. SO MAYBE
GETTING GETTING THE- MORE
COMPELLING. FOR JUST LET
EVERYBODY KNOW WILL HAVE A T.
EFFORT ON THIS TO MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW WE'RE COMPLYING WITH YOU
KNOW WHAT. PEOPLE ARE SAYING AND
I THINK. I THINK WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE ON US SO MAKE THE
MOTION FOR THE BILL THANK YOU
THE PAST. THANK YOU OUR
CONSULTANTS YOU ARE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. YOU PATH BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. FOR DATA I RICARDO I.
JONES JONES I COULD HAVE. BUT AS
THE I. FROM OTHER. IN FANS. THE
VOTE IS THREE ZERO. OKAY THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS AND WHAT UP NEXT
WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM- I'M SORRY
LIVE. WE IN THE VOTE IS. THREE
ZERO THREE THREE THE VOTE WAS
THREE ZERO AND WILL BE A PLACE
THAT- BILL ON COLD WE JUST HAVE
KAMLAGER. WHICH IS NOT COMING UP
OKAY MORE AT THIRTY. THE BILL IS
A THREE ZERO IN THE BILL IS OUT
WELL THANK YOU. NO OF. OKAY NOW
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
AGENDA ITEM TENTS IN THE BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE PATROL BOAT.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SENATE PEOPLE TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE TITLE FIVE ENTITLED
TWENTY TWO OF THE EDUCATION CODE
CREATED STANDARDIZED EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR TEACHERS IN
OPERATING CLASSROOMS FOR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. THEY
ALSO CREATED A REQUIREMENT OF
FOR ALL TEACHERS EARN TWELVE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION UNITS
AT THE STATE LEVEL. IT REPORT
HOWEVER. TEACHERS TO IN THE ANY
JOB WORKING ALONE OR INCREASE
CAMP. EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
CREDITS CAN BE COSTLY INCLUDE
ACTIVITIES LIKE DIAGRAM YOUR
FIRST PRESCHOOL CLASSROOM AND
VARIOUS OTHER PROJECTS WITH THE
OBJECTIVE OF PREPARING A TEACHER
TO EFFECTIVELY OPERATE A
STANDARD PRESCHOOL ENVIRONMENT
WHILE THESE CLUBS PROVIDE VERY
SENSIBLE EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS THERE CONGRUENT
CORPORATE OF ADMINISTRATOR
OUTSIDE RECREATION PROGRAM.
OUTSIDE RECOUP. NO WITH PEACE
BRING VERY SICK TO PRESCHOOL IN
ADDITION TO THEIR TRADITIONAL
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMMING CALIFORNIA
HAS ALREADY RECOGNIZE THE HIRING
AND STAFFING CHALLENGES THAT
RESULTED FROM THE APPLICATION OF
TEACHER CREDENTIALING STANDARDS
TO THE POSITION OF PARTS OF
COACHES THANK. JENNIFER CREATION
RAMPS BUT DID NOT EXTEND THE
EXEMPTION TO PRIVATE PROGRAMS SB
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE WILL SIMPLY
EXPAND THE EXTENSION FOR
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS AS
SPECIFIED HEALTH AND SAFETY
REPUBLIC RECREATE PROGRAM TO
ALSO APPLY PER WEEK CHEN PROGRAM
. THIS WILL CREE PARITY BETWEEN
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT GREAT WORK
GOING ON IN OUR SCHOOLS. I HAVE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
JOBIN VARKEY WITH SOCCER SHOT O.
C. AND LEYVA JERUSALEM. AND MORE
TEACHER. YOU CAN WE OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR OUR EXPERT WITNESS.
FINES ARE OPEN. DO WE HAVE
JOVENTUT. YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
PROCEED OKAY WHO. THE LONG WAIT
FOR MY MICROPHONE NOT WORKING
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
OF MANY CHILDREN ARE KEY I OWN A
FAMILY RUN PRIVATE RECREATION
PROGRAM WHAT A CHALLENGE OVER
THE BIGGEST SHOP WE AFFECT OUR
BUSINESS ON A TECHNICAL BUT
IMPACT MORE. I'M GOING TO
REQUIREMENTS. FULL TIME BC
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS TO DO A PART
TIME JOB COACHING CLASSES DIDN'T
MADE EVEN MORE CHALLENGING
MEDICAL CRISIS AND ITS NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THE AVAILABLE TEACHER
WORKFORCE WE UNDERSTAND THIS OF
THE INTENTION PEDALS FIVE IN TWO
PROMOTE. FIFTY EDUCATE. YOUR
RESPONSE LET YOU ACROSS CULTURAL
. THIS STANDARDIZATION HELPS
ENSURE THAT ALL ARE FOR TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THE MATTER
WHICH CRITICAL THE TENT. THE
QUESTION BEGIN ASKING IS WHY
APART TIME COACH WORKING FOR
PRIVATE RIGHT PRO- ONLY ON
CAMPUS FOR THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY
MINUTES PER WEEK. IS REQUIRED TO
MAKE THIS THING THAT YOU CAN
CENTER AS A FOR PRIEST HE- THE
STATE. CHAU CHALLENGING IT WAS
TO STOP THEIR OWN RECREATION
PROGRAMS YOU CERTIFICATES
TEACHER SO ST CATHOLIC THEM
FURTHER POP RECORD PRO EMPLOYEE
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE EXEMPTION
THAT ARE BEEN TO AND FOR PUBLIC
PROGRAM THE- ALL RIGHT. PROGRAM
PLEASE THAT WELL BOUNCE. THE
PUBLIC IMPACT MARCH. WITH THE
STATE IN TEN OF TELLS TWENTY. TO
PROMOTE AND PROTECT AND SAFETY
OF CHILDREN WE WILL THAT EXPAND
THE EXEMPTION LOOKS ACCESS TO
PROGRAMS MARCH OF. IN A WAY THAT
DELIVERS STATE GOALS OF THE TIE.
DOCUMENTS THREE IT IS. THE AND-
BENEFITS ARE VICE THE YOUNG AGE
ADDITIONALLY MANY CHILDREN. ARE
AWARE OF THE PHYSICAL. OF YOUR
KID PLAY. MANY STARTED MANY
PARENTS ALREADY AWARE OF
PHYSICAL. AND HOW THE KIDS
SPORTS. A RECENT STUDY BY
CLEVELAND ALL SHOWS THANK. FOR
ACTUALLY YOU. CAN NINETY WELL
WHICH IS THE PORT IN THIS PORT
AND FIND IT. ANY NEW DENTURE
INCLUDE BOOK PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
RECREATION PROGRAMS. SHOULD BE
TOWARDS THE END. DESIRE BY THE
TWENTY. OKAY HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF. EQUIPMENT EMOTIONALLY AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. DO WE HAVE THE NEXT
WITNESS ON THE CALL. BLINDER THE
WITNESSES ARE OPEN YOU MAKE AND
YOU. DO WE HAVE THE EXPERT
WITNESS ON THE CALL. OKAY I
DON'T THINK MAYBE THEY'RE NOT ON
THE CALL- SHE SAID SHE DIDN'T
HAVE ANY ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
TALKING. OKAY. GIVE US JUST ONE
QUICK SECOND. OKAY I THINK WE
CAN HEAR YOU. ARE YOU THERE. FOR
LAYLA. GIVE US JUST ONE SECOND
ONCE AGAIN. WHAT DO WE HAVE
LEGAL ON THE CALL. I'M ON THE
CALL ON THE CALL AND I NEEDED
OKAY THERE YOU ARE OKAY. PLEASE
PROCEED. MY NAME IS LAYLA
JERUSALEM AND I'M A PARENT OF
FOUR KIDS IN L. A. COUNTY AS A
FORMER TEACHER IN A LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY I PROPER AND-
PROMINENTLY OF COLOR ARE
EXCESSIVELY AFFECTED BY LACK. IN
SCHOOL IN RICHMOND AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM. THANKS THAT
STUDENTS FIND OUT TIME WITH THAT
EIGHT HOURS AND STREET CRIME
BUILDING UP PROJECTION. THE
DANGER COULD WEIGH WE ALL KNOW I
AM ASKING YOU TODAY THE
ELIMINATE THE BARRIERS AND FOR
APPROACH THANK YOU GREAT THANK
GOD BETWEEN WHAT KIND AND HOW
TIME FOR. PROGRAM A DIRECT
IMPACT ON HOW YOUNG THE DALLAS.
FOR EXAMPLE ACTIVITIES
UNDERGROUND. HE.
PART OF THE CORE CURRICULUM AND
PROGRAMS CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
ALL CHILDREN INCLUDING THOSE
IMPROPER LIKE MINE SHOULD BE
PROVIDED THAT OPPORTUNITY I
SCHOOL. I WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN
THAT WHEN THERE ISN'T A PUBLIC
ORGANIZATION MANPOWER PROVIDER
PROGRAM. THIS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT. ALL YOU. HI
THIS. WHETHER THEY'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT WE WANT OUR KIDS HAVE.
MATTER MENTAL HEALTH AND VITAL.
I DON'T MAKE LIFE. YOU AND NOW
MAYBE ABOUT. BEST PART YOGA.
DOCTORS NOT HERE. FAMILIES WHAT. THREE FIVE. RIGHT ANY
ORGANIZATION. IN A ERA EXACTLY
BE THE SHORTAGE OF CARGO CITING
YOU DEPRIVATION FOR ABOUT I
THINK WE ABSENT ALL PROVIDE YOU
ARE THAT GAP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ARE YOUR TESTIMONY AT A KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY FOR OTHER THAT ARE
ON THE CALL TO MEET THEIR LINE
BECAUSE WE HEAR BACK AS FAR. A
POP THE BUT- ONCE AGAIN THANK TO
MONIQUE. I POINT OUT THAT THIS
DOES BY FOR. WITH THAT WE WILL-
FOR WITH PUBLIC CONFIDENCE OF
THIS MEASURE NAME ORGANIZATION
IN YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL AND
WILL BEGIN HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE. AND IN SUPPORT FINAN OKAY
WILL MOVE- TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN SUPPORT.
OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY NINE. YOUR
SUPPORT OF F. T. TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE IT IS ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER THREE OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI ASHLEY FOX. EIGHT
IN SUPPORT OF THE L. OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. CHECK THE VOCAL
LINE NUMBER THREE OH THREE
PLAGUED BY HAD.
I NEVER THRILLED THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. W. PARKS ALAN OF THE
CHILD PRINCIPLE OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THEY WERE
BOTH A LINE OF OUR COMMUNITY I
HAD. HI MY NAME IS NEITHER
MCCARRICK TO FOREIGN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORTING
THIS BILL THANKS THANK YOU. THE
CALLER. AFTER VOTER MY NUMBER
THREE FOURTEEN PEOPLE HAD.
SEKULA SPIRO STRONG SUPPORTER
THIS COMMONSENSE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. WITH A VOTE TO HEAR WITH
A VOTE TO LINE NUMBER THREE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MARIE BISHARA AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER THREE
THIRTEEN YES THEY- LET'S GO. WE
WHERE'S YOUR MOM HELLO YES YOU
CAN YOU CAN. GO NEXT. YEAR SEE.
I DON'T THINK I GOT IT NEEDED
HERE. WE WILL BOOK MY NUMBER
THREE THIRTEEN YEAR OPEN. LEANER
FISH ARE IN SUPPORT. YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY THEY DROPPED OUT AND
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT WILL MOVE
ON TO THE LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITE BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RECORD OF. ON PUBLIC COMMENT AND
- I IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMON IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THE NON. DO WE HAVE-
ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE IN OPPOSITION THIS
CALL. ARE NOT PRESENTED AS WELL
NINE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. NINE
ONE NINE ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY IN QUEUE FOR A POSITION
. OKAY WELL THANK YOU FOR HAVING
HER FROM ALL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER
PAN YEAH THE JUST A CIRCLE BY.
THE WORK ON THE BILL FOR
SUPPORTED EDUCATION. TAKING
AMENDMENTS AND SAFETY SITES OF
THE HAPPEN OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH BYE
CENTER PANET TO KEEP. I WANTED
TO ASK- CENTER PANTS BECAUSE WE
HEARD THE BILL BEFORE AN I KNOW
SOME WORK WAS DONE TO DEAL WITH
. OKAY THANK YOU. FOR THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FOR. OKAY SO WE HAVE THE OUR
MOTION MISTER PAN AND WOULD YOU
LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. A
STANDARDS I THINK I THINK I'M
JUST GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU OKAY WILL
HAVE. CONTROL TO KEEP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS THE
BASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
HURTADO I FIR TITLE I JONES HI.
JONES I COULD AS A- OF THE I.
KAMLAGER IN HI THEN. WHAT IS
FOUR ZERO RIGHT THANK YOU THE
VOTE WAS FOUR ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT- I KNOW UP NEXT WE HAVE
SENATOR CORTEZ E. S. B. TWO
FORTY ONE BUT PRIOR TO THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE TAKE UP THE
CALENDAR BEFORE WE LOSE ANYBODY
OUT OF. SO CONTROL PLEASE THE
ROLL ON THANK CALENDAR. YEAH THE
ONLY MEASURE ON CONSENT IS SB
NINE FIFTY BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
. SENATOR HER DATA. I HURTADO I
JONES I JONES I COURTESY. PART
OF THE I KAMARG HER. ALL RIGHT
THEN HI THERE IS FOUR ZERO. THE
VOTE WAS FOUR ZERO AND THAT BILL
THAT CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
OKAY SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M SURE
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I'M
HERE PERCENT SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE THE CALIFORNIA SORE AS IN S.
O. A. R. GUARANTEED INCOME
PROGRAM APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S K.
TWELVE SCHOOL SYSTEM ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS A
NUMBER THAT HAS INCREASED BY
OVER 40% THE PAST DECADE IT IS
WHAT THE HIGHER DUE TO COLD AND
- SIX. THE STUDENTS BY UTILIZING
FUNDS FROM THE MCKINNEY VENTO
ACT THE KEY LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
FOR STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. HOWEVER THE LAW
ONLY APPLIES TO CURRENTLY
ENROLLED STUDENTS MEANING THAT A
STUDENT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WILL ONLY RECEIVE
SUPPORT UP UNTIL THEY GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL THE LACK OF
SUPPORT AVAILABLE TO YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS POST
GRADUATION SIGNIFICANTLY HINDERS
THEIR ABILITY TO PURSUE
EDUCATIONAL CAREER AMBITIONS.
WELL FEDERAL BY THE TO FIND
EIGHTY SIX BRING ALMOST AS SOON
YOU'RE IN ROLE IN COLLEGE. THAT
AID DOES NOT BECOME AVAILABLE
UNTIL SUIT INSTEAD HE CALLED
FOR. AS A RESULT- MANY OF THESE
YOUTH BECOME SUBJECT PHENOMENON
KNOWN AS SUMMER MELT THE
SCENARIO I JUST DESCRIBED WHICH
SCHOOLS TO ACCEPTED IN ORIGIN
AND TUNE. IT'LL DO NOT. THOMAS
FONG COMES. YES RESOURCE SYSTEM
THE TRIP FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO
CALL. IN FALL. THE STUDENTS
OFTEN BECOME STICKER SHOCK WHEN
THEY LEARNED OF THE UP FRONT
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH ATTENDING
COLLEGE THAT MUST BE PAID FOR
THE FINANCIALLY KICKS IN SUCH AS
THEIR SUMMER ORIENTATION FEE
HOUSING DEPOSIT OR PARKING PASS.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE NEED TO
STEP TOWARD TO OUR MOST FOR
STUDENTS DURING THE BRIDGE
BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
AND POST SECONDARY EDUCATION OR
EMPLOYMENT SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
THIS IS. INCOME GROUND. OF TIME
IT IS. PROVIDE US IS. THIS TO
THE BILL DEFINES KNOWS OF A
PARTY AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
ENROLLED IN THE TWELFTH GRADE.
MEETS THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESSNESS ACCORDING TO THE
MCKINNEY VENTO ACT IT WAS
COMPLETED IF THE OFFICER OR
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT APPLICATION
. AND I SHOULD KNOW THAT
PETITIONS- OR UNDERSTATE LAW
CURRENTLY DISTRIBUTED TO ALL
TWELFTH GRADE STUDENTS. THE
PROGRAM WILL. ASSEMBLY FIFTEEN
YOUTH EXPERTISE IN ALMOST A
STATE WIDE BEGINNING ON APRIL
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THROUGH AUGUST FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND ONE EIGHTH THE
SIZE IT'S A FIVE MONTH UP
PRESCRIBE PROGRAM. BILL DIRECTS
YOU MISTER CAN TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION THE PROGRAM TO LEARN
HOW THIS FORM SUPPORT MRS YOU
EXT TO HOLD THE NEXT EGG. PROP
DURING THE TAP ONE AS THEY SEE
FIT WHETHER THEY BE THE WAR OF
HER RICH I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHETHER IT MEANS A
ROOM A WARM COAT OF FOOD ON THE
TABLE OR ALL THE ABOVE SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WILL QUIT
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WITH THE POTENTIAL RESOURCES TO
THE PAST TOWARDS STABILITY. IN
THE WHOLE YES. THANK OF THE
CHEROKEE FOR. WITH ME ON THE
BILL- IN HERE TO TESTIFY OVER
THE PHONE TODAY IS TERRY ALL THE
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR OF
THE ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE CRISTINA
TAURUS HERE TO TESTIFY OVER THE
PHONE SHE'S A YOUTH ADVOCATE
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH. IN A CURRENT STUDENT AT
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE. WITH THAT
SAID I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
THE EXPERT WITNESS ON THE CALL.
YES OKAY RECEIVED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TERRY ONLY
WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION PROUD SPONSOR OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE I FIRST LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR CORTEZ THE FOR
AUTHORING THE SPELL AND HIS
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
HELP HAS A RESOURCE. CAN START.
RIGHT FOR COUNTING THE DAYS OF
THE YEAR MAKING PLANS FOR LIFE
AFTER FOR THE FUTURE HE THINK
BACK ON THAT MAYBE YOU REMEMBER
A MIX THE AND NERVOUSNESS LIKE I
DO SPEAKING ABOUT THE FREEDOM
AND THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
AWAITED ME THE- SENIOR. I DON'T
HAVE A STABLE ADDRESS REPLACE TO
CALL HOME THERE WONDER HOW DO I
ACTUALLY AFFORD THE FUTURE I'D
HOPED AND PLANNED FOR BUT
THEY'RE HEADED FOR COLLEGE OR A
CAREER HE'S EXPENSES COULD BE
INSURMOUNTABLE BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS ENTERING A WELCOME
RESOURCE. PART NOT. YEAH WRITING
A SHORT FIVE MONTHS GUARANTEED
INCOME TO GRAD SENIOR DURING THE
FROM SCHOOL BUT PUTTING YOUNG
ADULTS UNDER BUT AS THEY GO OUT
INTO THE WORLD WE CAN ACTUALLY
DISRUPT THE CYCLE OF POVERTY.
THREE THIS IS A GUARANTEED
INCOME IS SIMPLE THE RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT CASH IS INCREDIBLY
EFFECTIVE. JUST WORK. GIVEN
MONEY WITH NO STRINGS ATTACHED
MEANS PEOPLE CAN ADDRESS THEIR
OWN PARTICULAR NEEDS. THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT PEOPLE DO WHEN THEY
HAVE THE CHANCE. GROUNDBREAKING
STOCKTON ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT
DEMONSTRATION GUARANTEED INCOME
PROJECT SHOWED PRECISELY THIS.
AS ANOTHER CASH PILOTS AND
EXPAND THE CHILD TAX CREDIT LAST
YEAR. PEOPLE SPEND MONEY ON
THEIR NEEDS LIKE FOR. IF
HOUSEHOLD EXPENSES PAYING OFF
DEBT. PAYMENTS REDUCED INTO
VOLATILE AND HOW WITH ON.
EXPENSES ARISE. REGULAR CASH
PAYMENTS LEAD TO INCREASE FOOD
SECURITY LESS STRESS ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION GREATER ABILITY TO
PAY BILLS ON TIME AND ACTUALLY
MORE FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT.
DIRECT CASH IS SPENT FORMATIVE
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO BECOME
ECONOMICALLY STABLE AND EVEN GET
AHEAD WE CAN DO THE SAME THING
RIGHT NOW FOR CALIFORNIA COME
WITH YOU. GIVING THEM A SENSE OF
RELIEF AGENCY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHART A BETTER
FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES I THANK
YOU AND URGE THOSE. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE TO NOT A WITNESS ON THE
CALL. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE A IS
A LINE OPEN FOR THE WITNESS.
WINDS ARE OPEN. I GET THAT DO WE
HAVE THE NEXT EXPERT WITNESS ON
THE CALL. SHOULD BE CRISTINA
TORRES IF SHE'S AVAILABLE MAYBE
SHE'S CHRIS IS CHRISTINA ON THE
CALL- LET'S SEE HERE CRISTINA
FLORES LOOKS LIKE HAS DROPPED
OUT THE LINE THAT I SHOW HERE.
OKAY WHAT DID SHE IF SHE JOINS
US A DOLLAR THAT DOWN THE ROAD
ALL- I WILL GIVE HER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK UP BUT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND- WHEN THIS.
BROOM AND OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. NO OKAY- NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AT EIGHT THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE IT IS ONE NINE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. AND WE'VE OVERCOME
MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTY NINE.
HELLO AGAIN ANY MY YOUNG WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER
THREE SEVENTEEN BY NUMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. GOOD EVENING CAMERA
FOR PREVENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IN MY
APOLOGIES FOR GETTING AND I
LITERALLY THANK YOU NO WORRIES
THANK YOU OUR NEXT CALLER. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE TWENTY
THINK THEY THOUGHT HAD. BY
NUMBER THREE TWENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISTINE SEAN PAUL
THE CIRCUIT CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GRACE AND CAL POLY IN CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT SB ONE THREE
FOUR ONE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
WE HAVE ONE NUMBER THREE ELEVEN
AND LINE NUMBER THREE ELEVEN.
GOOD EVENING JERRY CALL WITH
NURSE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. MESSENGER
OKAY WELL THANK YOU I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM. NOT ALL FULLY ALL
FOOTBALL SUPPORT WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE FORWARD TO- ANY LEAD
WHAT IS. HI IS THIS. THIS IS
CHRISTINA. OKAY HI CRISTINA YEAH
A FEEL FREE TO BEGIN YOU GOT TWO
MINUTES. YEAH I. ABOUT THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CLEARED
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA TOWARDS AND
I AM A FORMER FOSTER I CAN
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE WELL I
WOULDN'T CALL I HAD BECAME
HOMELESS AND I ALSO HAD MY
DAUGHTER CHOOSE THERE WAS EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE COOL ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED THEY DO NOT THINK
ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE OR WERE THEY
GOING TO. RELATE ANY JUST LIKE I
DID. I THINK THAT WAS
UNFORTUNATELY I OTHER NEED AS
WELL. THIS PROGRAM. SLASH WHICH
IS AS B. THIRTEEN FORTY. WHAT
HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE TO ME WHEN I
WAS HOMER I WOULD HAVE USED THE
MONEY TO HELP PAY FOR ONE A BABY
SITTER BUT YOU. AND ALSO THROUGH
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS HOMELESS I
WASN'T ABLE TO GET THAT. NOT ALL
YOU HAVE THE ALL. THE HOT THE
HELP THAT THEY NEED. TO KNOW
WHAT I DID. AND THE PROGRAM WILL
BE ABLE TO HELP THE IF YOU NEED
IT. AND I. I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THANK FOR YOUR TIME AND I ASK
FOR YOUR ZIP FOR THE PROGRAM
SLASH BILL THEY YOU. THANKS
THANK YOU CRISTINA NOW WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL THOSE WITNESS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE WILL MOVE. TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY KNOWN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BUT- WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT. IT FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE IN THIS ROOM. SIXTEEN
NINE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION IT IS ONE NINE
ZERO. OPPOSITION ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. WE DO NOT SHOW
ANYBODY AND YOU FOR OPPOSITION
THAT INSURERS THANK. I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM ALL OF ALL OPPOSITION
OR NOT BUT NO OPPOSITION WE
WILL- TAKE A COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. THE CENTER PLANS YES THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE OF
FOR RAINS BEFORE AND I KNOW
WE'VE HEARD AND EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AS WELL- I GUESS. AND
I KNOW THAT WHAT THAT TIME. I
KNOW YOU ARE STILL WORKING OUT
SOME ELEMENTS ON THE BILL AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE STILL
CONTINUE CONVERSATION. HELPFUL
OW MUCH AND SO FORTH UP. THE
CONTINUE MAYBE TOUCH ON JUST
WHAT WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- IN TERMS OF- I MEAN WE
COULD. GET SOMEONE JUST LIKE UP.
NOT ATM CARD BUT I MEAN AT THE
BEAUTY ATV T. CARD BUT- I WAS
WONDERING DIVERT WHAT THEIR
THOUGHTS THAT- THE END THIS IS
NOT TO BE A BARRIER- BUT-
DEPRIVED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR.
YOUTH- THIS ARE GETTING. THIS
EIGHTY TIED YOU KNOW GET SOME
FINANCIAL LITERACY OPPORTUNITIES
AND ALSO THE. YEAH I NEED TO GET
. THE WAY EMBEDS IF THERE IF
THERE IS SUCH AS A PARTNER BANKS
YOU CAN FOR LIKE ESSENTIALLY NO
FEAR SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY NEED
ALL THAT MY FROM SO SERVE AS A
PART OF A LIFE SKILLS TYPE THING
SO THE SOMETHING YOU'RE YOU'RE
CONSIDERING AND DOING IS A WAY
TO IN ADDITION TO THE MONEY HOW
YOU HANDLE MONEY RIGHT. BUSH IS
VERY MUCH IN IT WITH THE- THAT
WE'VE HAD. YOU KNOW AS SORT
SHORT AS IT'S BEEN. THE MOST
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND EVEN THE
LEGISLATURE IN WHICH IS STANDING
UP LAST YEAR'S PROGRAM- ON THE-
OF FOSTER IN PREGNANT WOMEN- UPI
OR OR GUARANTEED INCOME. IN THAT
IN THAT CASE IS BEING
ADMINISTERED THROUGH- DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES THIS. OF THE
DISCUSSIONS US FOR. PRODUCTIVE
BEEN WITH BOTH OF THE PARCEL
SERVICES AND CALIFORNIA PARDON
EDUCATION. BT CARD IS BEEN PU
OUT THERE FOR OBVIOUS REASONS
IT'S LIKELY BECAUSE HE'S OUR WAS
MICKEY MANTLE FAMILIES THAT
THERE. THERE'S SOME FAMILIARITY
WITH THAT- TOOL- BUT IT MAY
STILL WORK IN CONJUNCTION WITH-
WITH CITY ADMINISTRATION TO WERE
JUST TRYING TO PUSH THAT OUT. OF
THE PIECE THAT YOU'RE MENTIONING
I THINK IS CRITICAL- THE BILL.
HAS PROVISIONS IN IT. BECAUSE OF. I'M NOT. GOOD FIGHT OF NATION
AND IN OTHER WORDS TO MAKE IN
KIND CONTRIBUTION TO THE PROGRAM
YEAH I THINK THAT WHERE THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS IN FINANCIAL
LITERACY BUT ALSO WRITTEN. EVEN
IN IN MORE CONCRETE AREAS LIKE.
SEE THE LEVEL OF WHERE THIS KIND
OF A PROGRAM IS FROM PILOTED
CREDIT UNIONS FOR EXAMPLE
WITHOUT NAMING ANYONE
SPECIFICALLY- STEPPING UP
STEPPING FORWARD AND SAYING YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO HELP IN BOTH
AREAS BUT TERMS OF FINANCIAL BUT
- THAT- THERE'S- BILLABLE- S. C.
IN IF WITH IF THE PROGRAM
MINISTRATIONS GOING TO USE-
ELECTRONIC TRAVEL OR OR DEBIT
CARD TO MAKE SURE THAT. ALL THE
PROTECTIONS. THE CARDS ETCETERA
ETCETERA- JUST SORT OF NOWADAYS
BUILT INTO TO THOSE INSTRUMENTS
SO- ALL THAT IS CRITICAL- AS WE
MOVE ALONG WE- YOU KNOW TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN PUT. CORPORATELY
PUT IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS YOU
KNOW IN A IN A LEGISLATIVE BILL
HAPPY TO DO THAT- HAPPY YOU KNOW
TRYING TO BE PRESCRIPTIVE ABOUT.
HOW THE MONEY'S ACTUALLY USED AS
FOR THE PHILOSOPHICAL REASONS
THAT YOU HEARD IN THE TESTIMONY
TODAY THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T
BE PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF.
PATIENT DETAILS OF THE BANKING
AND SECURE TRANSACTIONS NO AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND AGAIN NOTE
THAT SO THE NET TRIPLANE
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE FUNDS BUT
ALSO BECAUSE THIS IS YOU SAID
THE TARGET POPULATION OF THE
SENIORS WHO HOPEFULLY WE DON'T
HAVE A MELT THE GOAT SERRA AND
THEN MAYBE EVEN IN MY IN RIGHT
SO THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE
WANT TO GIVE THEM THE
INSTRUMENTS NON THEM ITSELF
HERE'S AN IF NEEDED WHATEVER BUT
ALSO THE TOOL. WHAT MONEY THEY
THEM-
TRANSIT WHO ARE BETTER OFF THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ESSENTIALLY
HOPEFULLY ZERO COST BUT YOU KNOW
THROUGH. I THINK YOU AGAIN
FURTHER ENHANCE. YOUR PROGRAM
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES WERE
BECAUSE ACTUALLY THE HOPE IS
THAT THEY BECOME SCUTTLED
ACTUALLY MAKE MORE MONEY RIGHT
SO WHAT WE IN THE- AND I COULD.
START AND SO FAR THROUGH THE
CASE AND SO FORTH THAT THEY CAN
DO THAT WILL REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TO DO I KNOW THERE'S
STILL SOME DETAILS TO WORK OUT
IN. WITH THE GIVE. I DON'T ANY
OF ANY QUESTIONS BUT THERE'S A
MOTION. ON THIS MEASURE AND JOB.
CENTRE QUARTERS HE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND APPRECIATE THE
WITNESSES- MAKE MISSILES
AVAILABLE AT THE LATE HOUR
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
TO THE COMMITTEE THE STAFF. TEAM
SO WELL SO CLOSELY WITH US- AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
. THANK YOU. THINK TAKING. THE
SENATE PANEL. THE MOTION COULD
MOVE PLEASE CALL ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FOR THE
RIVER REAR TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HURTADO I FIR
TITLE I JONES. BUT AS A OCCURRED
AS THE- PAN HI CAN I. THAT IS
THREE ZERO ALL RIGHT WE WILL
PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL TO ALLOW
. ALL MY- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE. AND UP NEXT WE HAVE-
SENATE BILL 1353% OVER WILK. I
BELIEVE MISTER. OUR VICE CHAIR
WILL BE. PRESENTING YOUR- OF
COURSE.
THREE MEN SHARE LIKE ALL OF US I
THINK AMONG MULTIPLE COMMITTEES
TODAY AND- COVERING I'M GETTING
ALL MY STEPS IN TODAY I THINK AS
A ALL OF US ARE. I TODAY I
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
REPORTING BY THE STATE AND
LOCALITIES ON HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAM EXPENDITURES AND
OUTCOMES THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REPORTS TO
CALIFORNIA ENTRY ACCOUNT THE
CIVIC INFORMATION. OUR MISSION
AS WELL. BUT OUR HOPE IS PRO FOR
THE JURORS BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE HOMELESS
POPULATION INFORMATION TO BE
PROVIDED WILL INCLUDE DATA SUCH
AS AGE GENDER CRIMINAL JUSTICE
HISTORY STATUS OF SHELTER FOR
DEATHS OF HOMELESS PERSONS
FOSTER YOUTH. HOW THEY TO BE
LESS WHAT RESIDED PRIOR TO BEING
HOMELESS AND THE LENGTH OF TIME
OF BEING HOMELESS. FOR
EXPENDITURE INFORMATION LOCAL
AGENCIES MUST PROVIDE EITHER ONE
INFORMATION TO STATE THAT THEY
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION. THREE STE THE
PROVIDING. TO DO BURDEN WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
AN ESTIMATE FOR HOW MUCH IT
WOULD COST FOR THEM TO OBTAIN
THAT INFORMATION. THE COUNCIL
COLLECTED INFORMATION THANK AND
DATA DRIVEN ASSESSMENT REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND- NINE BY.
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX. MEMBERS
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN RECENT
YEARS IN OUR UNDERSTANDING THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION AND I
THINK WE EVEN. EARLIER I
RECENTLY LAUNCHED HOMES DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM H. T. I. S.
WHICH GATHERS INFORMATION ABOUT
HOMELESS PERSONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND POSTS ON ITS WEBSITE
AS A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT THE INFORMATION IS STILL
LACKING. IN INFORMATION IS
LIMITED UNFORTUNATELY PROGRESS
IS MAKING IN THE REDUCTION OF
THE HOME COPULATE. FROM FROM TO
NINETY EIGHT TWENTY WE SITES
POINT 8% INCREASE. FROM TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
SAW A 7% INCREASE IN THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. THIS BILL
IS A STEP FURTHER INTO THE
DIRECTION THAT OTHER STATES A-
YOUR LIVE. IN TEN. HOMELESS
DESPITE IN THE- FROM FUNDING
SOURCE TRY SUCCESSFUL PROJECTS
WHICH WILL FOCUS GREATER EFFORTS
THIS BILL WAS INSPIRED BY THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
TWO STATE OPS LAST YEAR STATE
REPORTS TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE
SIXTEEN FOUND THAT THE STATE
DOES NOT REPORT OUTCOME MEASURES
THAT DESCRIBE WHETHER ITS
ACTIONS WERE LIVING REDUCE THE
NOT VIDEO. OUR HOME RIGHT RIGHT
THIS QUOTE. TWENTY YEAH WELL.
LET'S THE LARGEST SHOULD REQUIRE
THE COUNCIL IN COLLABORATION
WITH ALL STATE AGENCIES THAT
ADMINISTER EIGHT AND FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS COLLECT
AND TRACK FUNDING DATA ON ALL
FEDERAL AND STATE DID HOPE WAS
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE NXP EACH YEAR THE
TYPES OF A FUNDED TYPES INTO.
REIST MEMBERS AUTHOR WILL
RECOVER FROM AN INJURY HE X.
THAT HE IS HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO A OR CAN. YOU
PUT EFFORTS. RISING FROM
COLLECTION OF SENSITIVE
INFORMATION IS OFFICES HAD
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS WHO OVER
THE LAST WEEK SUBMITTED LETTERS
OF OPPOSITION WITH ME THIS
MORNING BY NEUTRAL I WITNESSED
MONIES OF THE SENIOR EDITOR WITH
THE STATE- IS OFFICE INCREASE
WILL. THE FOR. TO REFERENCE THE
REPORT. THE LAST YEAR IN
CERTAINLY WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY FOR CENTER WORKS
BILL. I'M SORRY- TO HAVE THE
FIRST ONE IS ON THE LINE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS CHRIS
PATEL. I'M A SENIOR AUDITOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. THE STATE AUDITOR DID
NOT TAKE A POSITION ON THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATION BUT SENATOR
BILL SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
WOULD ADDRESS THE CONCERNS COULD
BE IDENTIFIED. IN ANOTHER WOULD
BE DONE HOMELESSNESS IN FEBRUARY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BE ABLE TO
PRODUCT FOR THE STATE LACKED
BEAT UP ON HOMELESSNESS SERVICES
TO DETERMINE WHETHER IT IS
EFFECTIVE YOU CRAFTING
HOMELESSNESS. AT THE TIME OF
OVER AUDIT CALIFORNIA DID NOT
HAVE THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM TO
COLLECT DATA ON LOCAL OR
STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. THE LOCAL
CONTINUUM CONTINUUM OF CARE
COLLECT THESE DATA. FROM
HOMELESSNESS SERVICE PROVIDERS
BUT WE DO NOT. GET AT THE STATE
WHERE. THANK YOU. FOR TO FIFTY
FIVE WHEN CALLED THE HOME DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM OR YEAH I.
BUT WE FIRE THAT THE STATE
EFFORTS TO COLLECT DATA MAYBE LA
. PHYSICALLY ACCORDING TO THE
HOME COORDINATING AND FINANCE
COUNCIL IS NOW CO THE ENTRY
COUNCIL ON. THE STATE EACH YEAR
IT'S BROKE DATA FROM THE- MY
INFORMATION SYSTEM OR HM I HAVE
. WHICH IS A OF THAT LOW COMPETE
CONTINUE OF CARE USE.
CONTINUUM'S OKAY COOLEY OVER
SERVICE PRO. INCLUDE THE NUMBER
AND CAN. OF HOME INDIVIDUAL THAT
THE SERVICE PROVIDER AT. AND THE
TYPE OF SERVICESTHEY PROVIDE
AMONG OTHER DATA. HOWEVER ONLY
THOSE NUMBERS BORDERS RECEIVE
FEDERAL FUEL PROGRAM GRANT I
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THESE DATA
AT THE CONDITION OF THE GRANT.
ALL OF THE PROVIDERS THAT WORK
WITH COMPETING STUFF HERE ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO PROVIDE ANY. IN
THE- STATE AGENCIES ALSO
ADMINISTER MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE BENEFITS AND
SERVICES TO PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. BUT THEY GENERALLY
DO NOT REQUIRE SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO ENTER DATA ABOUT THESE
PROGRAMS INTO THE LOCAL HM. AS A
RESULT IN. IN MY SYSTEM FOR THE
PRIMARY SOURCE OF DATA THE AVI
FOR DOUBLE BACK COMPREHENSIVE
DATA REGARDING HOMELESSNESS
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS. IN
ADDITION TO OF THAT COURT OVER
OFFICE ALSO ISSUED ANOTHER
REPORT IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IN THAT REPORT WE
SPECIFICALLY RAISED THE CONCERN
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT HAVE
NOT COLLECTED IN. OR RECORDED
DATA USING OUTCOME MEASURES FOR
ANY OF ITS HOMELESS PROGRAMS. WE
BELIEVE THAT MEASURING OUTCOMES
IS CRITICAL NOT ONLY FOR
UNDERSTANDING HOW WELL THE STATE
SPENDING. THE THING FONG BUT
ALSO TO INFORM FUTURE EFFORTS TO
COMBAT HOMELESSNESS. THAT
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
. THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR AND NOW
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. A BILL WITH
WITNESSES HERE IN TWENTY ROUTE
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. THE NINE
WILL MOVE TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT IT IS ONE SEVEN ZERO. THAT IS THE FOUR ONE NINE ZERO
. WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY KILLING
UP MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
HAVE BEEN HEARD FROM ALL THOSE
IN SUPPORT WILL- MOVE IN WILL
MOVE TO OUR OPPOSITION AND SO WE
HAVE I ONE WITNESS OPPOSITION TO
THIS. MEASURE WILL. FIFTY THIRD
CAN YOU PLEASE COME ON UP.
AFTERNOON JEREMY MEMBERS- SHARE
REPORT WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL- WITH SB THIRTEEN FIFTY A
FIFTY THREE WE SURE GOAL BACKING
AND REPORTING DATA AND STATE-
FUNDING AND OUTCOMES WE
APPRECIATE THE OTHERS AND IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE JUST
YESTERDAY AND- TWO HUNDRED BUT
THERE. IT'S WORTH COMING LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING OUT- ARE
STRONGEST IS THAT THE- IN THE
VERSION OF THE BILL ARE JUST NOT
ATTAINABLE. TO GATHER A YEAR
OVER YEAR ANALYSIS FOR EXAMPLE
OF CHANGES IN OUR STATE'S
POPULAR FROM. TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE ALL
FORTY FOUR OF OUR HOMELESS
CONTINUES OF CARE TO DO WELL
HOMELESS- COUNT FOR BOTH YEARS.
AND HAD CURRENTLY REQUIRES THAT
COUNT TO BE DONE ONLY EVERY
OTHER YEAR AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THESE COUNTS ARE EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED AND VERY COSTLY- TO
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- THEY ARE
HUGELY EXPENSIVE AND REQUIRE
THOUSANDS OF ALL YOUR LITERALLY
GO OUT ON THE STREETS. UNDER HOT
REYES AND TO LOOK INTO CARS TO
COUNT. EARLY COUNT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WELL
WE SHARE THE AUTHOR'S DESPAIRED
. GAME GREATER PERCENT PLUMAS IS
IN DATA WE DO NOT THINK THE
BILL'S AVENUES OF PURSUING THE
STATOR. FOR IS. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CA TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO
BANKS IN THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. HE'S COMING OFF YEAH HI
MARCUS ALL THE SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ON
HOMELESSNESS OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA- ECHO MANY OF
SHARON'S COMMENTS ABOUT THE
BILL- YOU KNOW FELT IT
ENCOURAGED BY THE AMENDMENTS BUT
OF IN ADDITION TO WISH WHAT MISS
REPORT MENTIONED. ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE PRIVACY ISSUES
THAT MAY COME UP WITH SOME OF
THE DATA POINTS THAT WILL IT BE
COLLECTED BY THIS BILL BUT ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE WITH SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL OUR
WITNESSES- THAT LOOKED FOR IT
COMMENT ON. IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL HAD THROUGH NOW OKAY
MOVING ON TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
OPPOSITION. S. B. FIFTY THREE.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ONE THREE FIVE THREE ONE HUNDRED
ALL. ONCE AGAIN ABOUT THE VISION
ONE NINE ZERO. AND I DO NOT
THINK ANYBODY QUEUING UP FOR
OPPOSITION MEDICARE OKAY HAVE
YOU HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ARE WE WILL BRING IT
BACK WILL PROTECT THE DISCUSSION
AND I KNOW THAT CENTER PATENT
PLEASE. READ IT IS THE-
REPRESENT FOR THE ALL. BUILDING
MISTER PATEL SERVICE FINALLY I'M
STILL HERE- HI YES THANK YOU- I
HA DID HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU
YOU I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
LISTENING TO THE UP TO THE-
HOUSE ISABEL OF QUITE AN
EXTENSIVE- AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
THAT IS GOING TO BE COLLECTED
AND I THINK WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
A WITNESS AND I GUESS THE
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY KILLED A
LOT OF DATA MYSELF AS A VISIT- I
CAN IN IS THAT. IT'S GOOD WELL
IT'S GONNA BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET BACK DATA AND- AND THEN
THERE'S OF COURSE THE PRIVACY
ISSUES SO FAR BUT DID THIS ONE
DAUGHTER'S OFFICE IN YOUR REPORT
AND I APPRECIATE YOU KNOW YOU
TESTIFIED I KNOW YOU CAN TAKE A
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT YOU
SAID WE DEFINITELY AND I. AGREE
NEED MORE. IT IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT THIS. BILL HOW THIS
LINE UP WITH THE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDS AND DID THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AS YOU LOOK AT. THE
FEASIBILITY OF COLLECTING. THIS
LEVEL DATA FROM ESSENTIALLY A
POPULATION THAT. YOU KNOW IS I
MEAN. UNDER HOMELESS STREET KIND
OF AN EIGHT. IT DID. THAT'S WHAT
. COUNTS AS- CENTER SO DO YOU IN
FOR. ABOUT LIKE. THEIR YOU KNOW
- PREGNANCY RATES AND- JAIL TIME
AND- AND SO FORTH AND THE VET
FAILED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS
AND SO FORTH. I MEAN YOU HAVE TO
INTERVIEW EACH ONE OF THEM
IDENTIFY. WHO THEY ARE YOU COULD
TRY IT. I MEAN WAS THERE SOME
ASSESSMENT. WENT FROM THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ABOUT. HI YOU
KNOW THE FEASIBILITY OF. BEING.
THAT'S WHAT THE HONORS OFFICE
CALLING FOR. NO CLUE CREDIT WE
DID NOT LOOK AT IT IN IN THAT
LEVEL OF THE OKAY WHAT WE DID
LOOK AT IT IS YOU KNOW THE TYPE
OF DATA THAT'S BEING COLLECTED
RIGHT NOW IN THE AGING SYSTEM
WHICH IS AGAIN THE SYSTEM THAT
THAT THE TO CONTINUE. USE OKAY
AND SO IT WOULD FOCUS ON IT DATA
DOES STATE HAVE ACCESS TO AND
WHAT DOES IT DO WITH IT AND SO
WE FOUND THAT THE STATE
CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE. ACCESS
TO SPEAK BY THE THAT- WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO OUR CALIFORNIA AND
EVEN WITH ITS NEW EFFORT WITH
THE AC I ACTUALLY FOUND THAT-
THERE WILL. FIRST WHO. PROVIDE
SERVICES TO. TUESDAY TO DOES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. BUT
THEY'RE NOT. IN DATA. TO YOU THE
- H. I AT. BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT.
EITHER BY THE GOVERNMENT OR
LOCAL THE- OKAY. YOU CAN BE
RECEIVING AND SO EVEN IF THE
STATE WAS GETTING THE DATA THE
IT WOULD STILL BE MISSING OUT ON
THE OKAY THAT WOULD THE EXTENT
OF WHAT WE LOOK AT OKAY SO
REALLY WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AND
YOU'RE IN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT
WAS ACTUALLY. DIFFERENT THIS FOR
PROVIDING ASSIST TO HOME
INDIVIDUALS OR FAMILIES THERE'S
THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
PULL THAT THE- STAY. FARM
COLLAPSED AND THAT PERHAPS YOU
DO A BETTER JOB OF COOL. THAT
DATA AND HAVING COMPILED AT FOR
THE STATE THIS IS THE IT DESSERT
ACCURATE. BUT NOT EXACTLY OKAY
ALL RIGHT- OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT- AND- SO I
GUESS- AND CENTER JOE THEY
REALIZE YOU'RE PRESENTING AND
OTHER MEMBERS BILL. ME I DO.
WHAT SIR WHAT'S TRYING TO DO I
GUESS MY CONCERN AND I HAVE TO
ADMIT I SHARE SOME THE CONCERNS
OF THE- OF THE OF. THAT THE
LEAST THE PATIENT HIMSELF SENSES
. IT WOULD BE GREAT TO HAVE A I
MEAN I'D LOVE TO HAVE IT BUT I
AND NOT SURE HOW TO LIST IT IS
TO GET THAT LEVEL ESPECIALLY
WHILE STILL PROTECTING. THE C.
AND I THINK IF IT WAS MORE
FOCUSED ON WHAT THE AUTHOR
TALKED ABOUT WHICH IS THAT OKAY
THERE'S SOME DATA THAT WE CAN
GET FROM SERVICE PROVIDERS
ETCETERA. BY THE WAY ONE THAT
YOU CAN USE THAT FIFTY. YEAH
THEN SIX SERVICES AT THE- LOTS
OF REASONS AND SO FORTH. THAT
YOU'LL DO A BETTER JOB OF IF THE
STATE YOU KNOW LOCALS PASSING ON
DATA CENTER- THAT IT WAS MORE
NARROW TO THAT THAT WOULD MAKE
MORE SENSE TO ME- I'M I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED THAT. WE HAVE A
WHOLE LIST OF RECALL OR DATA
THAT I THINK WOULD BE REALLY
DIFFICULT TO GET AND FRANKLY
EVEN IF THEY TRIED TO COLLECT
IT. MAY NOT BE TERRIBLY ACCURATE
BECAUSE UNLESS. IN TERMS OF. BUT
TAKE ACTUALLY GET NOW. DATA UP
WITH THAT- YEAH I GUESS I WOULD
HOPE WE CAN PASS THAT ON TO THE
AUTO- AND- WELL IT LOOKS TO
SEEING THEIR EVOLUTION OF THIS
BILL- IN IN THAT DIRECTION
ALTHOUGH AND AGAIN HAPPY TO HEAR
BACK FROM THE ALL OF THE- OTHER
IDEAS WE DIDN'T HEAR ON TERMS OF
HOW TO GET THE STATE IN A WAY
THAT IT. OVERLY IT WOULD STILL.
A YEAR AT PRESENTATION OF THE
BILL THANK YOU S. R. PAN AND
JUST TO RESPOND BRIEFLY- OUR
SERVER OF SUCH LITERATURE IS
HERE- TAKING NOTES IN AND FOR
THE SENATE CENTERS ACTUALLY ON
HIS WAY UP TO SACRAMENTO IN A
WEEK- HE IS. I THINK ACTUALLY I
WAS ENCOURAGED BY THE COPS- I
WOULDN'T EVEN CALL IT OPPOSITION
AT THIS POINT TIME IT'S LIKE-
THE AUTHOR AND THE AND THE-
INTEREST SIR. ARE HAVING A
POSITIVE DIALOGUE- IT IS I
CENTER WILTED WHAT MANAGED TO
SHARE THAT HE IS CONTINUING TO
WORK HE REALIZES THERE'S ROBOT.
AB AND THERE ARE LOTS OF IT- AT
. TWENTY STATION- MAKING SURE
WEARING IN THERE TERREL TAILORED
TOWARDS THE AUDITORS- CONCERNS.
SENATE QUARTERS THANK YOU YEAH I
JUST I WANNA SURE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE- YOU KNOW THE QUANTITY
THE BREATH AND THE DETAILED
INFORMATION THE IT'S AGAIN A
LITTLE IRONIC FOR ME TO SAY
THAT- BASE A MILE CAL ME
EXPERIENCED THIS IN OUR COUNTY.
THE BIG MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET WE JUST READ ATTACK.
ACTUALLY TEAM TO DO A COST STUDY
IN THE GENERATE ALL THIS
INFORMATION IF YOU WANT TO SEE
IF WE CAN MAIL IT IN TO EVERY
OFFICE IN THE LEGISLATURE IT'S
NOT HARD ONCE YOU HAVE IT I'M
SURE I ALSO LOSE ALL TWENTY
COLLEGES. TO GET. WELL IT WILL
YOU KNOW COME UP WITH BILL IS
ASKING REALLY INTO. AND
EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE THIS
INFORMATION COUNTY BY COUNTY
WHAT COUNTY BUT THERE'S GOING TO
BE COUNTY SAID JUST SIMPLY
COULDN'T AFFORD. IT TO PULL THAT
OFF AND THEN THE QUESTION
BECOMES. THE HAVE SORT OF
DISPARATE INFORMATION. WHAT
HAPPENS THEN SO. THAT MEANS
WORK- IN THE A PHARMACY BE A
HUGE APPROPRIATIONS ISSUE TO ASK
THE STATE TO PAY FOR. THOSE KIND
OF INDEPENDENT STUDIES OF PF
COUNTY SO. I THINK. THERE'S
PROBABLY INFORMATION EACH AND
EVERY COUNTY ALREADY HOUSE. I
WOULDN'T CREE A BIGGER
CORPORATION PROBLEMS TO JUST SAY
YOU NEED TO THE FINAL THAT
INFORMATION UP HERE YOU KNOW
FAIR KEEPING IT IN FIFTY EIGHT
SILOS WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AS WAS LOOK
. IT WHAT IT IS. SO WE SO MUCH
MORE SUPPORTABLE BILL LATER ON
TO THE ROAD BUT- HEARING THAT
FOLKS ARE TRYING TO WORK. IN
THAT DIRECTION RIGHT ALSO. OKAY
TODAY- BUT WITH A COPY OF THAT.
I HOPE THAT WE CONTINUE TO HELP
THOSE RESERVATIONS LATER SURE
AND I THINK YOU CAN. GET ON THE
ONE OF THE POINTS A DOCTOR CAN
MEET AS WELL AS- YOUR THE POINT
TIME COUNT. YOU KNOW MOST OF
COUNTIES ARE PARTICIPATING THAT
THAT INFORMATION CERTAINLY
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE THAT THEY
CAN YOU KNOW CERTAINLY MOVE UP
TO THE STATE THIS POINT TIME.
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
ITERATION- DOES ACCOUNT FOR-
WHAT YOUR CONCERNS ARE FOR THOSE
COUNTIES THAT- ORDERS
JURISDICTIONS AND JUST SAY THEY
CAN'T AFFORD IT- THIS STATE OF
AND THEN SEND THE STATE AN-
ESTIMATE OF WHY YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH IT WOULD COST THEM TO DO
IT. AND THEN YOU KNOW HOW CAN
STATE HELP SO- WERE MOVED ACT AS
IF THAT'S ALREADY IN THERE. AND
THE- AUTHOR IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE INTO. ACTION
THAT- DRESSES OF CANCER. IF I
MAY THROUGH THE CHURCH'S SAY AND
NOT GET PARTISAN AT ALL BUT IT
WAS- I WAS ON BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT HAD. OR DO. I'M
A REPUBLICAN MEMBER THE PURSUE
THE NINE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSING BOND WANTED TO
KNOW WHAT WHAT THE COST BENEFIT
WOULD BE A PUTTING PEOPLE
PERMITS FOR HOUSING SO THE COSTS
THAT HE CAME BACK INTO THIS COST
YOU EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A PERSON DO WHAT YOU'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS ALL THESE
THINGS LISTED IN THIS BILL A
RISK ASSESSMENT IN. HIS SAFETY
NET ISSUES AND CLEAN UP STREETS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND ACTUALLY
IF YOU GO WITH THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING MODEL COST YOU THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. UP
TO AT HIM UNANIMOUS VOTE IN
ORDER TO THE POND I I'D LIKE THE
IDEA THAT MAYBE THE SAME PER.
DONE WITH WITH ACTUAL BOLSTER
YOU KNOW THE ARGUMENT THAT WE
SHOULD BE. MORE IN IT BOTH THIS
BACK TO THE BATES PULLED PORK IN
HOUSING FIRST AND IT ACTUAL TREE
FOLKS. CLOSER I DON'T I KNOW
WE'RE OFFICIALLY FOR POINTING
OUT THE EDGES OF THE TIME HAVE A
IDEA EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE. THANK
YOU. I SUPPORT A COUPLE GOOD
IDEAS TODAY SO IF YOU HAVE THANK
YOU. I'LL ASK- I'LL TAKE THAT IF
THERE'S NO MORE CONFIDENCE NOT
SURE. I THINK THAT IS MY CLOTHES
AND ASK FOR AN AUTOMOTIVE ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES WOULD. BE SO
GENEROUS AS TO MAKE MUCH I'LL
JUST I'LL JUST SAY THAT I I'VE
NOT ANGRY WITH A YOU KNOW. FOR
BUT MY ARM ON THE SIDE I'M
MOSTLY HANGRY BUT- NOT ANGRY I.
OF JUST THAT THANK YOU FOR
REPRESENTS CENTER WELL TODAY AND
I HOPE HE'S DOING BETTER AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE. THERE'S WILL BEST
TO WORK TOGETHER TO. IMPROVE THE
BILL IN TERMS OF THE DATA THAT'S
AVAILABLE AND- AND SO- YEAH I
JUST. THOUGHT ABOUT THAT'S ALL I
HAVE TO FEEL RANDOM BUT BUMBLE
MOVE THE BILL'S ACCOUNT WORK ON
. IT FOR MUCH. AT I'VE- OKAY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION CONSULTED YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS
THE PAST BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HURTADO AYE
HURTADO AYE JONES HI JONES I
CRITICALLY CRITICIZED HIM FIVE
AND- GALLAGHER. VOTERS FOUR ZERO
THE VOTE WAS FOUR ZERO NOT BILL
IS OUT. SHE RECALED TO. WE
HAVE- WITH BOTH OTHERS. WHAT WE
WHAT WE HAVE UP NEXT WE HAVE
AGENDA ITEM THIRTEEN I THINK IT
. THE REQUESTED I KNOW OUR
SIMPLE CHOIR YOUR FAULT OF THE
PRESENT BELIEVE THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO. WITH
BETTER CHAIRED MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OR MAKE AT
THE STATEMENT BRIEF AND WE DO
HAVE A TWO WITNESSES WHO WERE ON
THE LINE AND GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP AND HARD WORK ON THE
HEALTH BOTTOM LINE IS THIS AT.
FOURTEEN THIRTY IT'S CRITICAL IT
SPAIN SUFFICIENT BENEFITS FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN HOW
FRESH SOLELY BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY UTILIZED A USDA FOOD
PROGRAM. EXCLUDE SENATE
CONFIRMED. THE FOOD DIVISION
PROGRAM ON RESIDENTS- BOTTOM
LINE IS THIS. IF I AM NOT HAPPY
IF I'M A SNAP CAL FRESH
RECIPIENT. ON A MONTHLY BASIS I
AM RECEIVING RECEIVING A PROXY
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS
TWENTY EIGHT CENTS OF. IF I AM
ON THE AT FOOD DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM ON INDIAN RESERVATIONS
ALSO KNOWN AS FDPIR I'M
RECEIVING ABOUT NINETY ONE
DOLLARS AND TWENTY CENTS A MONTH
. THAT'S A DIFFERENCE OF SEVENTY
THREE DOLLARS EVERY MONTH WHICH
IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH BUT IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT IF YOU'RE
LIVING IN POVERTY. WHAT WE KNOW
IS THERE ONE IN THREE. FAMILIES
ACROSS THE NOT BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE THE KLAMATH RIVER BASIN AT
WHICH IS UP ON THE NORTH COAST
SURVEY FOR NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES 92% 92% OF ALL TRIBAL
MEMBERS ARE. IN A REGION WHERE
FOOD IS SCARCE IN THEIR
HOUSEHOLD. SO WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS ALLOW IT AMERICAN
FAMILIES WHO ARE RECEIVING FDPIR
TO ALSO RECEIVE THE DIFFERENCE
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT'S IT. IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE PASS
THIS THIS WOULD BE A GAME
CHANGER FOR SO MANY NATIVE
AMERICAN FAMILIES TODAY WE HAVE
A PLAYER- CRUISER WITH US TODAY
IS POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE COVER
TRAVEL FAMILIES COALITION. ALSO
GRATEFUL THAT WE THURMOND JOE
JANES IN THE YUROK TRIBE WITH
THIS TODAY I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO BOTH OF THEM FOR THEIR
HARD WORK RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
HELP AND I DON'T. I PLEASED. WE
HAVE A WITH EARLY WITNESS NUMBER
ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS CLEAR CRUISER
I'M A MEMBER OF THE GROUP OF
VALLEY TRIED AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS THE POLICY DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRIBAL. COALITION
THE CALIFORNIA TRIBAL FAMILIES
COALITION IS ATTRACTIVELY LED
MEMBERSHIP ORGANISATION FOCUSED
ON SYSTEMIC CHANGE TO PROMOTE
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
TRIBAL CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WHICH ARE INHERENT
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTAL FUNCTIONS
AND ARE AT THE CORE OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. OUR COALITION
REPRESENTS NEARLY HALF OF ALL
ONE HUNDRED AND NINE TRIBAL
NATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. A
TESTAMENT TO JUST HOW IMPORTANT
TRIED SPEAK ISSUES CONCERNING
OUR NEXT GENERATION. FOR THE
PAST DECADE I HAVE WORKED WITH
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN TRIBAL
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING PREVIOUSLY PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT OF A TRIBALLY RUN FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM ON INDIAN
RESERVATIONS. I AM ON INDIAN. AS
THE- FUNDED USDA FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM PROVIDING PRE PACKAGED
FOOD BOXES TO INDIVIDUALS LIVING
ON OR NEAR RESERVATIONS AND
ADMINISTERED BY EITHER TRY
INDIAN ORGANIZATIONS OR AGENCIES
IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAMS PROVIDE
IMPORTANT BENEFITS. INCLUDING
EASIER ACCESS TO FOOD IN AREAS
WHERE GROCERY STORES ARE LACKING
IN TRANSPORTATION TO THOSE
STORES ONE AVAILABLE. IN MY
EXPERIENCE FAMILIES OFTEN FACE
DIFFICULT CHOICES AND MUST
NAVIGATE COMPLEX ELIGIBILITY
STRUCTURES TO GAIN ACCESS TO
NEEDED ASSISTANCE. IT'S
DIFFICULTY I HAVE IN FAMILIES
FACE IS WHETHER OR NOT TO
RECEIVE BENEFITS FROM A FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM OR TO
RECEIVE CALFRESH BENEFITS
BECAUSE BOTH ARE NOT AN OPTION.
FAMILIES WILL OFTEN OPT TO
RECEIVE ASSISTANCE FROM FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM BECAUSE THE
FOOD IS DELIVERED DIRECTLY TO
THEM. BY INDIVIDUAL THING- FROM
THE COMMUNITY. YET THIS
DIFFICULT DECISION HAVE GREAT
IMPACT ON CAMPUS. PROVIDED BY
FOOD DISTRIBUTION PROGRAMS
ANNOUNCED TO APPROXIMATELY TWO
DOLLARS AND THIRTY CENTS LESS
PER DAY COMPARED TO THE
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED TO RESIDENTS
RECEIVING CALFRESH. SB FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN SPEAKS THE REMEDY THAT
AND EQUITY IN ASSISTANCE FOR
TRIBAL INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
BY PROVIDING ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS IN AN AMOUNT THAT WOULD
MAKE THE TOTAL BENEFITS RECEIVED
FROM FOOD DISTRIBUTION AND THE
FAT PROGRAM ECLIPSE AND THOSE.
RECEIVING CALFRESH ASSISTANT.
FILLING WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
SMALL GAP IN SERVICES WILLHAVE
A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON TRIBAL
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND ELDER TO
FACE SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES
OF POVERTY. AND FOOD INSECURITY
ACROSS THE STATE. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS THE COALITION SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN AND AFTER THAT
THE COMMITTEE DO THE SAME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. YOU I'M THIS. DO WE HAVE YOUR NEW. YEAH
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOE JAMES
I'M A MEMBER OF THE EUROPE CARE
ACT LARGEST TRIBE IN
CALIFORNIA'S BORDERS THANK YOU
FOR THE TRIM OF THE YUROK TRIBE-
FOUR FOUR AGAIN I WANT TO. I'M
SURE IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
HOSTING- I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE KIND OF REQUIRED READING
THIS OR LEGISLATOR. THAT'S WHAT
. ALSO THE PRICE WITHOUT THE CAL
. WELCOME THANK OF THE
LEGISLATURE STAFF AND OTHERS.
WORK CURRENTLY NUMBER YOU'RE NOT
. THAT BENEFIT IS THAT- ANOTHER
FOR FROM ANOTHER FEDERAL PROGRAM
THE FOOD DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM
MONEY RHETORIC INDIAN
RESERVATIONS. WELL THERE ARE
MANY BENEFITS TO THE FDPIR
PROGRAM THE COULDN'T DIRECTED
GOOD LUCK HOUSEHOLDS AVERAGE
AMOUNT OF BENEFITS YOU SEE IT
OFTEN LOWER. THAN THOSE HE
BARTERED BY OUR PARTICIPANTS OF
CALIBRATION CREATING YET ANOTHER
DISPARITY IN ACCESS WE NEED
PEOPLE. EZQUERRA MY JOB SERVE
THE- WORK IN WORKS REVISED
HELPING BEING OF OUR MEMBERS.
FOR THE HEALTH OF ANIMALS.
IMPROVE THE HARVEST AMANDA'S
FAMILY OUR DEAR L. FIRST VIRGIN
OR SEEN WITH. AND MUSCLES
INVOLUTION IN IN OTHER THINK.
OUR RESEARCH THAT HAVE THE
LIMITED. WE CAN NO LONGER RELY
ON OTHERS SO. THE YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
EXPANDING ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA- THIS IS A PROGRAM
FOR NATIVE PEOPLE TO RECEIVE.
AND I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO DO
THE SAME. ALTERNATIVE BILL FOR
PRIVATE RESOURCES WHO NEED IT
MOST. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME
IN THE WITH STRONG SUPPORT AT
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN. IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY AND AGAIN ABOUT THE
ARE PEOPLE AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN NEED THANK YOU WALK UP. THANK
YOU SO MUCH ARE TWO OF THE TWO
WITNESSES FOR. YOUR COMMONSENSE
WILL GO HEAD TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
HE THROUGH MY- TWENTY HUNDRED.
THE NOT WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE.
IF YOU ARE A PART OF SB FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN IS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
IS IN SUPPORT ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY QUEUED UP
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT MOTHER
GIVES THEM MY NUMBER- EIGHT
PEOPLE GO TO A LINE NUMBER THREE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI A
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE DIESEL
GOOD THEATER I WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE
DO HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PAUL WITH NURSE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE TO GO IN SUPPORT MANAGER
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE WE
DON'T HAVE WE HAVE NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO WILL GO
HEAD TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
OPPOSITION BEGINNING A ROOM
TWENTY. THREE NINE NOW WILL MOVE
BACK TO THE- THE A TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN. YOUR IN OPPOSITION OF
F. EIGHT FOURTEEN THIRTEEN IS
ONE ONE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
OPPOSITION ONE NINE ZERO. THEN
WE COULD NOT HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP MEDICARE OKAY HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OR BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
CENTER PATH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK THURMOND BRING THIS
ITSELF. BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
FDPIR PROGRAM WHICH I UNDERSTAND
DOES PROVIDE CERTAIN BENEFITS IF
THEY DO DIRECT DELIVERY SO WOULD
THIS BE. CALFRESH ON TOP OF TAT
THE DIFFERENCE AND THEN AND THEN
OF COURSE. ARTEAGA A TO TRY TO
COMPETE USE THE KEY I MEAN THEY
CAN USE COVER TWENTY IS GONNA BE
AVAILABLE IN THEIR THEIR READ.
POLITIKAI WAS IT SENSE THAT. AT
TOPSHOP TOP OR TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE CASH OR I DON'T KNOW YOU
CAN AUGMENT THE FERPA IF YOU GET
THE SAME VALUES TO GET MORE
FOOD- US OPEN OF. TO WHAT DEGREE
PERCENT OF TAKEN PLACE BECAUSE
OF WHAT. THE POINT BASIS MAKE ME
WITH ARE YOU TRYING TO DO WITH
THE BILL. AND A PERSON SO I WANT
TO GET. TEN SIX THIS IS ON WHERE
THE END OF LIVE OKAY SO THIS
WOULD SIMPLY MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE SO TAKE A LOOK RIGHT
NOW TWENTY TWO TWO BY. ALL UP
RUSHED RECIPE READ BUT HOW SIXTY
FOUR. DOLLARS PER MONTH YEAH-
THE- FDPIR RECEIVES ABOUT NINETY
ONE BUCKS PER MONTH SO THIS
WOULD SIMPLY MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE SEVENTY THREE DAHLE.
SO OKAY TRY THE SIDE LIKE HOW
THEY WANT TO DO SO NOW IT'S I
GUESS YOU YOU COULD GET OFF YOU
CAN GET CALFRESH CARD YOU COULD
CATCH I KNOW THAT IF P. YOU CAN
GET MORE FOOD IT WOULD ALLOW
ELIGIBILITY THAT AGE WILL HAVE A
MEMBER OF THE ACT CALFRESH A IN
YOUR IT WOULD BE. ALL RIGHT. YOU
LIKE. DAVID THEY ARE PRONE.
HELLO THE GETTING EIGHT EIGHT A
THE CALL- ARE FOOD STAMPS NOW
MAY NOT BE AS BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE BILL BILL IF YOUR VENDORS TO
WOULD TO TAKE PART IN OF THE
REMOTE SEVERAS. INTO THAT THE
AND- BOB IT'S A SPORT AND- WOULD
MOVE IT PROPER TIME YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF BEEN VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SPENT WITH. WE HAVE A- AN- AND-
HAND AT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
CLOSE MY CHEN. FOR ALL THE WORK
THIS YOU'RE VERY CAPABLE STAFF
AND WOULD RISK. FOR AND I.
CONTROL RUSSIA'S THAT BUT FIRST
BE REAR TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PURPOSE HURTADO I HURTADO AYE
JONES JONES I COURTESY BUT AS
THE ALLY GALLAGHER. HERE ARE IN
I NOTICE FOUR ZERO. OKAY THE
VOTE WAS FOUR ZERO AND THE BILL
IS NOT BEEN GETTING MUCH ARE.
AND AT THIS MOMENT WILL GO. OF
THE WE HAVE SENATOR BAKER HERE.
THANK YOU FOR PATIENTLY WAITING
CENTER BACKER WE ARE READY FOR
YOUR BILL AS BEFORE ON ONE.
BUZZER PRESENTING I HAVE LIKE A
FIFTY SLIDE POWER POINT DECK IS
THAT OKAY. WE CAN. SOME OF US
HAVE TO GO BACK TO JUDICIARY-
THANK YOU VENTURE MEMBERS WILL
TRY TO BE LITTLE BRIEF BUT WE
HERE PRESENT TO SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE WITH THIS CRITICAL
BONE CHILD NUTRITION IT WOULD TO
FREO GOALS. ALSO CARE SCHOOL
FACILITIES THAT A BY BYE CACI'S
P. STANDARDS ELIMINATES THE
STATE MEAL REIMBURSEMENT PAY
PENALTY OTHER CHRYSLER BOXES UP
27% TOTAL. LOS I JUST SUPPORT
ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS FOODS FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN HOWEVER THE
CURRENT MEAL REIMBURSEMENT
STRUCTURE THESE FAMILIES VOTERS
MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE VENABLE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
THIS REPORT ALSO LOW HEALTH INS
I WORK FOR OF THAT MEANS BLACK
LATINO IMMIGRANTS AND THEN I'M
WITH US ABOUT FOODS EVEN MORE
HAPPY BECAUSE OF THE CODE I
DEMOCRATS. SUCH A YOUR SO HERE
THIS EVEN HUNGER COME OUT OF
THEIR OWN. MANY CASES WITH THESE
COSTS ESPECIALLY WITH WOMEN
SUPPLIES INCONSISTENT ROMAN AND
OTHER. ISSUES THIS PROVIDES A
METHOD TO REDUCE CHILDHOOD
HUNGER ENSURE CHILDREN ACCESS TO
NUTRITIOUS FOOD. M. AS WELL
CURRENTLY SET FOR MAY QUALIFY
FOR SIX OF SUCH CHILD CARE BUT
NOT FREE REDUCED MEALS FOR THEIR
CHILD IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY. IT
WHICH WAS WHICH WAS TRUE IS
ACTUALLY REPRESENTED A FOR THESE
FAMILIES AND WE HAVE TO.
WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY WITH
US TODAY. THREE CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR FIRST A
WITNESS. WINDS ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU CHAIR TITLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CAMERAMEN JONES WITH NURSE
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE PROBABLY
CORRESPONDS DURING SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE WITHOUT PARTNERS THAT
THE CAP OF ROUNDS BEFORE I WANT
TO START BY THINKING BEFORE BUT
SB FOURTEEN. FIRST WE WILL BILL
WOULD. ALL OF OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS RECEIVE HELP IN AND
CHILD AND THAT PROVIDE ARE BEING
VERY FAIRLY FOR THE COSTA YOUR
SERVICE. HELLO CONTINUE TO ALLOW
LEVELS OF. YEAH A RECENT BIG
RIGHT THERE OF TELEPHONE WITH
CHILDREN IN. SHOULD MORE THAN
80% OF PARENTS WITH VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
FAMILIES ABILITY TO AFFORD
ENOUGH FOOD. EXPLAINS SURVEYS
FROM THREE IN FACT A VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN ACTUALLY DID RUN OUT OF
FOOD BEFORE THEIR FAMILIES COULD
AFFORD TO BUY MORE. SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE THE LONG OVERDUE
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENT IN
YOUNG CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
CHILD CARE WORKFORCE. IT WILL
BRING EQUITY TO OUR CHILD
NUTRITION PROGRAMS BY ENSURING
FREE BILLS FOR MORE CHILDREN IN
CHILDCARE ELIMINATION OF THE
RESPECT. DON'T SEE AN ADEQUATE
SUPPORT THE CHILD THE PROVIDERS
TO PLAN FOR PARTICIPATION IN.
THE HE- WON. FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IF THE CHILD AN
ADULT FOOD SB FORTY EIGHTY ONE
IF I MAY THREE BUT INSTEAD THE
PARTICIPATION OF WHERE. WE ARE
THE INVESTMENT IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO HE SAID HE TO RESTORE
THE SMALL SPEAK WILL REIMBURSE
WITH THAT WITH THAT IN TWENTY
TWELVE HOWEVER ADDITIONAL.
NEEDED AT. PROVIDERS WITH A NO
FEE FOR. A STAB REPUTABLE. AND
REIMBURSEMENT ABSOLUTELY FOR THE
COST OF LIVING AND THE CONSTANT
WRITING QUALITY CHILD CARE
INCLUDING NUTRITION FIELD IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEST THE DAY I.
AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE- WILL MOVE ON TO BY
OUR LEAD WITNESS NUMBER TWO.
HELLO YES YES THE LAST PLEASE
PREPARE ME YESTERDAY GOOD- HI MY
NAME IS SELECT A LIMO AND I'M A
DAYCARE PROVIDER AND- WHAT WHAT
I WANT TO THANK YOU. HEAR HER
TITLE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. YEAH OKAY. MY NAME IS TO
LET THE LENO AND I'M A DAYCARE
PROVIDER IN TULARE. AND I'VE
BEEN DOING HEALTH CARE FOR OVER
TWENTY SIX YEARS. AND- AB. RIGHT
IT WORKS VERY MANY CHALLENGES.
ONE THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IS THE
COST OF FOOD. GOOD SHORTAGE IN
KEEPING THE CHILDREN. ADEQUATE
ADEQUATELY SAY SAID. EATING A
HIGH CALL OF HEALTHY FOODS SUCH
AS FRESH I WENT TO SHOPPING FOR
A LOS WHICH USUALLY COSTS FIVE
DOLLARS A POUND AND NOW IS NINE
DOLLARS. THANK I DIDN'T CLEAN MY
- PAY MORE AT TRIPLE FOR THE FOR
YOU RIGHT I TAKE CARE OF OVER
FOURTEEN CHILDREN AT ONE TIME
AND THE COST IS REMARKABLE. HE
KEPT METICULOUS. KIND AND-
REMARKABLE. THERE IS A SHORTAGE
OF WITH THE DISTRICT IS NOT
GUARANTEED. OUR MAIN GOAL FOR
THE CHILDREN AND I CAN CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
DIET AND LIFESTYLE FOR CHILDREN
AGAIN HAVING AT THE BACK. END
FUNDING TO BUY THE FOOD IS
INSUFFICIENT WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR FOOD WITH LOW FAT
AND SUGAR CONTENT SUCH AS
BRUSSELS SPROUTS BROCCOLI
ANOTHER AND OTHER VEGETABLES AND
OTHER. HIGH NUTRITIOUS FOOD.
PROPOSED F. THE FOURTEENTH ONE
THAT ARE AND ARE STILL BECAUSE
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO GET THE
PROPER NUTRITION. THEY NEED TO
HAVE A HEALTHY LIFE. I THOUGHT
THAT. IT HELP MAINTAIN HEALTHY
WEIGHT BECAUSE THEY'RE EATING
NUTRITIOUS FOODS. HIGH IN FIBER
AND MINERALS VITAMINS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL IN KEEPING OUR
CHILDREN HEALTHY AFTER WILL KEEP
THEM FROM DEVELOPING CHRONIC
DISEASES. SO AND I FEAR NOT
GETTING THE TRICK NUTRITION THEY
NEED FROM HOME. WITHOUT YEAH HE
IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PROVIDERS TO STAY IN BUSINESS
THE HIGH COST TO. BUT PAYMENT
WAS QUOTE OUR DOORS IT IS
EXPENSIVE TO PAY FOR FOOD AND
ALL THE THINGS WE HAVE TO DO TO
MAINTAIN HIGH QUALITY CHILD CARE
. ONE OF MY BIGGEST EXPENSIVE
EVEN WITH THE HELP OF CA CST WE
PROVIDED YOU'RE STILL STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT I WANT
TO. SAY SOMETHING BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN LISTENING TO THIS WHOLE
THING THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE AND
WHAT I'M CONNECTED IN THAT.
BILLS THAT ARE GOING ON AND-
BEST EDITED. I AM A I'M NOT ONLY
LIMIT AT PROVIDED BUT I'M OFF
MST P. AND I HAVE TALKED TO.
OVER. HOME PEOPLE WHO I WOULD
WITH- A MAN THAT AND WHEN
WITHOUT DRUG AND ALCOHOL. ABUSE
I'M NOT OF THEM THAT I. OTHER
HAVE WHAT A PRESCHOOL FOR A DAY
. WE NEED TO THAT IMPROVE.
ACTION TAKE CARE WHAT YOU THE
WHOLE SITTING AT THE BACK PLACE
FOR ANY CHILD TO LEARN.
PRESCHOOL BUT I YEAH WE NEED TO
AND I'M LOOKING THANK THE KIND
OF. ONE OF MY STRAIGHT AND I HAD
THE WHOLE. MY FOR YOU. AT THE
TALKING TO THESE AND WOMEN ABOUT
THE BEING ONE. WE NOT ONLY DO WE
NEED INVEST AND COULD IT BACK
WHICH IS. SAM DAY CARE HOME
SETTING WHICH IS THE FACT PLACE
FOR ANY CHILD WHO. AND CRISPS
BUT ALSO INCLUDE WITH YOUR- THE
PROPER. IT WAS. AND. THEY KNOW
WHAT TO DO TO HELP PREVENT THE
HOMELESS HEALTH I JUST HAD TO
ADD THAT GOOD BECAUSE YOU FIVE
BUT YES- IF I GOT IT OUT NIGHT
NOT A GREAT. THING YOU THANK YOU
. OF COURSE. IF YOU AND I CHILD
CARE WHAT WHAT HEY I THIS WILL
BE A PRESS ACTION FOR THE- HOME
THAT WE PROBLEM FIFTEEN MINUTES
HEALTH PROBLEMS AND- YOU VERY
CUTE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR- AND THEN WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ALL ON TO. THE
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. I SEE
THAT WE WILL MOVE TO THE TELL
PUBLIC COME MIGHT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE H. ONE. IF YOU ARE A
PART OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
IT IS ONE ZERO. AND IT'S ONE
NINE ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND WE
WILL START WITH MY NUMBER THREE
SIXTY. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS. SHOW THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY NUMBER THREE TWENTY EIGHT.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COLD WAR NEWMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER THREE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
PHILADELPHIA CREAM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF GENDER CARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
SENATOR FOR INTRODUCING
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE OH FOUR LINE NUMBER
THREE OH FOUR. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY A
MARKED- VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
BILL- I'M POLICY AND ADVOCACY
AND STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU.
LIE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY NINE.
HELLO YET ONLY MY JAAN ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO FIFTY
FOUR. MY NUMBER TWO FIFTY FOUR.
I NUMBER THREE THIRTY FOUR.
HELLO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY THE HUNGER FOR STUDENTS
FROM VIRGINIA THANK YOU. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT IT IS ONE NINE
ZERO. AND WE YEAH WELL WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS NASA WHY IT
WOULD CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILD
KERR NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
JUST A MOMENT HERE WE HAVE MORE
IN YOU. AND THAT NEXT WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
FIVE. HI THIS IS THE THIRD WITH
THE ADDRESS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COULD BE. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
WATER LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
THREE- GOOD EVENING THIS IS
DEREK POLL WELL WITH THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK. IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IRAN
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
MADAM CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU- NOW
LET'S- IT MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO KNOWN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES BUT WILL TAKE IF
ANYONE'S HERE IN THE ROOM- WILL
WANTING TO COMMENT ON IN
OPPOSITION THIS BILL. IN ON OKAY
IT WILL BE A PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE. IF YOU'RE NOT CHEN OF
F. B. F. FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
IT'S ONE NINE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
ABOUT THE VISION OF F. B. ONE
FOUR EIGHT ONE. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY GIVING UP
OPPOSITION MANAGER. OKAY THANK
YOU- HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
OPPOSITION AND ALL THOSE IN
SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE BILL
. MOVE OKAY GREAT. WE HAVE A
MTION OKAY I JUST WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE WORDS. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS MATTER FORWARD I
THINK. YOUR CLIMATE CHANGE- THIS
IS GONNA BE MORE NEED- AND I
THINK THERE'S- SOMEWHAT OF AN
EFFORT TO ALSO HAVE- THE
TRICIA'S. DANCE FOOD THAT WE
CONSUME BECAUSE JUST OF THE
INCREASE THE NEED AND SO. I
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO PUBLIC
HAVE. THE THINK THAT. THAT
YOU'RE GETTING TO THE TABLE- HAS
THERE'S A LOT MORE A LOT MORE
THAT IS THAT IS INVOLVED- OUR
FOOD SYSTEM THAT INCLUDES WATER
ENERGY AND ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS AND I THINK WE GOTTA
START HAVING SOME ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOWARD DEF
OF THE LOT OF THESE BUT I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH OF THIS THE
SPECIAL. WE HAVE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR. AT A COUPLE TO YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS THE PAST FIRST THE RIVER
REVERT TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HURTADO I FURTADO
AYE JONES. JOHNSON NOTING
CRITICALLY HI FOR THE AYE AYE.
HOW MURDER. TEN FIVE TEN I
VOTERS THREE ZERO. OTHER BOOKS
RESERVE THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU FOR THE RECORD I THINK THAT
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH ALL OF IT BUT
WE WILL GO BACK AND- ARE. GO
THROUGH THE BOOK THROUGH THE
VOTES THROUGH THE BILLS THAT ARE
ON CALL FOCUS WILL YOU PLEASE GO
OVER THOSE MEASURES. M. A. N. SB
EIGHT NINE SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG OF THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PAN. HI AND I THE
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS
FIVE ZERO LEVEL IS OUT- SB NINE
THREE SIX BY SENATOR LEYVA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. JONES BROWN'S
NUMBERING- THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. THE VOTE WAS FORCED ON THE
BILL ITSELF. AT. SB. NINE NINE
SIX FIVE SENATOR CONNOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. NOT VOTING
THE VOTERS FOR THE CRAFT OF WHAT
WAS FORCED ON THAT RIGHT NOW. AN
SB TEN FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
LOAN AYE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
JONES JOHNSON VOTING WITH THEM
SB TEN SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR
HURTADO THE MOTION IS WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO START THE VOTE ON
THAT WAS THREE ZERO AND THAT'S A
MEASURE ONLINE AND- SB A TEN
FORTY SEVEN MEASURE SICK OR ITEM
SIX OKAY DOUBLE IS THREE ZERO
AND THAT BILL. IS OUT. NINE SB
TEN THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR
HURTADO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
JONES. JONES NOW THE VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO. THE VOTE WAS FORCED
OUT SORRY FOR THE VOTERS FOR
ONE. OKAY THE VOTE WAS FOR ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT. AND SB AT
ELEVEN FORTY BY SENATOR UMBERG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JOHN I HAD
THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. THE VOTE
WAS FIVE ZERO AND THAT BILL IS
OUT. AS SB AT TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
BY A SENATOR JOE VOEPEL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATE I APOLOGIES THAT
SENATOR KAMLAGER HAS. ARE THE
LAST ITEM ON CALL IS AT THE
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
CORTEZ THE- AT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FOR BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
JONES. JONES NO THE VOTE IS
THREE ONE. THE VOTE WAS THREE
ONE AND THAT BILL IS OUT. THAT
IS. ALL ITEMS AND COST OKAY THAT
WRAPS THAT THE THAT WRAPS UP
TODAY'S HEARING I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THINK WE
JUST DID AN AMAZING. JOB TODAY
AND WE HAD TO DO YOU KNOW JUST.
REALLY GREAT CONVERSATIONS OF.
IT'S IN OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY AD NOW I THINK EVERYBODY
IN HERE IS IT THE TEAM THAT
HELPED PUT THE STICK WITH THE
HEARING TOGETHER. AND WE WILL
CONCLUDE THIS- COMMITTEE
HEARING. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.